foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
numbers
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wow
foreign
[Music]
guys we are about to go live best James
yes
what's Zoey here you already know hey
what's up it's going to be intense so
two players will be knocked out this is
the chest kid cup the chest will not be
kid-friendly the action Starts Now under
one minute now for Hikaru and what a
move I'll raise her look at him he's
biting his sweatshirt he doesn't know
what to do eight minutes and 59 seconds
beaten by one second could he have
swapped Queens though
Magnus has had no struggles against a
car over the board he should be happy
we have a winner Magnus Carlson takes it
he wins the air things Monsters the very
first event he's training
oh my God
oh and we see a reaction magnets
oh no hey Cara not come over here
is the winner of the chessable Masters
Fabiano caruana resigns what an
Armageddon game by Hikaru
[Music]
are in the losers bracket one of them
will be eliminated it's getting hot at
the Chaska camp and to make sure that
you don't miss any of it we've got
Grandmaster David Howell
Grandma Grandmaster
James Conti
big deal of action on day one what was
the highlight for you man I mean the
highlight s definitely are two upsets
two dragons Tanya got slayed yesterday
one of them hikarnak war or the other
the world number two alireza farouza
incredible performances by jvf and by
Dimitri callers let's see if they can
keep it going today
expect the unexpected other chest good
Gap such surprising results a lot of
action there James and I have to ask you
for all the chess kids around the world
what was the one big takeaway be like
Michael Jordan van Forest okay as he did
his thing yesterday I mean he was taking
down a Goliath like Hikaru Nakamura I'm
absolutely feeling Unstoppable at this
point from him
result for Jordan banffer is taking down
the absolute Beast Hikaru Nakamura David
what's that the most shocking day one of
the door I think so Tanya it's rare to
see such a big favorite like Hikaru
Nakamura lose on day one but he has a
second life and it's now or never
especially for Nakamura and feroza it's
uh their time to shine
it was a day of twists and dance that
saw the big names being toppled over
take a look at the roller coaster ride
on fire Michael Jordan red Forest it
ain't game seven but he's playing like
it's a game seven
I think ikaro's playing for a win
because Knight C7 David that was the
first draw I think Rook C3 signals that
Hikaru actually feels that he can pull
this out good is just hopping around
hoping now but the pawns are coming soon
that white king is going to come under
an attack E4 bring that Bishop in
goodbye end of the game
is a miracle yeah oh you could see the
anger F6 would have been very strong as
well but this is just looks like game
over I love what Jordan's done though
he's kept his King and Rook as far away
as possible literally as far away apart
as possible and uh therefore no Forks
Jordan van Forest takes it oh it's a
brilliant technique the black king
running out into the open now there's a
horrible Queen takes Port The Black
Queen on the diagonal coming and taking
the pawn in front of the white king
White's Queen has to swoop back and
defend uh-oh what happened I don't like
that move G5 baby
if you had played G5 White's in charge
there let's not forget that Dimitri has
to win the game a draw would mean that
alireza takes the match
I have lost it just feels like panic he
was the underdog in this match but he's
clearly been the better player today and
Dimitri Kola sticks it in the Army
Garden
great attacking chess there on day one
and that's exactly what we're expecting
more of take a look at the matchups that
we've got lined up today we will have
the winner semi-finals later where we'll
see Fabiano caruana take on knotted back
huge match there and of course the two
uh Slayers Jordan One Forest will be
playing against Dmitry collage but
before that we will start with the
losers bracket Hikaru Nakamura against
we've got shimanov against Jules but
we've got to talk about Hikaru against
alireza that's world number four playing
wall number five an amazing incredible
matchup David who gets by oh this one is
a tough one to call I'm going to say
farouza actually I just have a feeling
that he's going to step up another
couple of gears and Nakamura yesterday
didn't feel like he was at his best
controversial take I know but we'll see
wow David how they're saying feruja
might take this one James would you
agree with that well I'm gonna say Karu
is Mr you don't like me when I'm angry
okay I'm very mad right now I lost you
can see the frustration there just
yesterday was very angry about the game
of course for usual too as well but hey
Carl definitely shows the emotions a
little bit more I think today is going
to look for that revenge against version
oh one thing's clear the two players
have to forget about what happened on
day one we saw Hikaru there after the
final decisive game for Jordan with
masterful play frustration on hikaru's
face and at the very end he decided not
to resign but let the time run out with
seconds on the clock he gets up and
leaves Daniel we've seen this before
from Hikaru we have I mean it's not a
secret that Hikaru doesn't hide his
emotions uh positive or negative he's
done that before he did that in a US
Chastity game a couple of uh years ago
letting a couple minutes go down on his
clock uh without resigning so you know
when he's mad he shows it but when he's
mad he's really hard to play because he
steps up his game to what seems like an
impossible level so Ali Reza he has to
step it up tactically if he misses the
amount of things he missed yesterday
he's going to lose without even a fight
he is one player who has the most number
of decisive games so it's going to be a
very intense battle between these two
they both have to step it up and now
alireza he became a Grandmaster 12. he
is the youngest ever player to have
crossed the 2800 Mark and we've got a
little take by David Howell telling us
exactly what makes Olive so dangerous
[Music]
foreign
needs no introduction this Superstar
burst onto the scene as a teenager
becoming world number two at 18 years
old
however since then progress has been
somewhat measured
he's been inconsistent and his love for
chess has at times been questioned
on the board though farouza is dynamite
he's aggressive he's Dynamic and there's
a Fear Factor about farrugia's play none
of the top players in the world can ever
relax when ferrugia is sat opposite them
I have experienced the power of alireza
farooja many times myself
one of the most heartbreaking games of
my career came in the grand Swiss in
2021 when ferrugia beat me and went on
to qualify for the candidates
in this position I thought I was doing
okay with black however farugia is an
attacking Maestro and he shocked Me by
playing Knight takes Pawn sacrificing a
knight and he had calculated everything
perfectly the idea is that when the
Knight is recaptured suddenly this white
light squared Bishop is opened up to
capture the Black Knight and black has
too many things hanging this bishop is
suddenly attacked in the center the
black king is open and for example after
a capture of Bishops in the center white
can comedy recapture because the Black
Knight is undefended if you give alireza
farusha a tactical shot he will find it
and he will punish you as I found out
for myself
an absolute tactical monster alireza
David Knight takes eight six that one
hurt yeah perhaps I'm just influenced
and perhaps I'm scarred by that defeat
that's why I'm rooting for ferrugate or
I'm expecting him to uh really shine but
it's gonna be a close match it's gonna
be fun either uh either way and as you
mentioned that it's been a bit of a
struggle with the consistency with
alireza he's one of the biggest talents
the chess world has ever seen and James
I want to ask you he's been vocal about
his Ambitions in the fashion industry
has that made it difficult to balance
with professional play at that level uh
100 I mean even uh we've seen with
Magnus recently of course Magnus uh in
the recent interview was just saying hey
I'm a little rusty right he plays some
games right and lost some games drew
some games he's like yeah I'm a little
rusty haven't really looked at chess
haven't really studied chess so it's
affecting my chest right so it's the
same thing with farouza of course I
think that uh with him doing a lot of
fashion hey you know kudos to him right
you know Gucci res as we say right stuff
like that can't wait to see what stuff
he comes out with but it also is going
to affect some of his chests because
he's not really into it the way that he
was before
[Music]
I'm super excited for that one and of
course uh this season the action is not
just on division one we've got so many
big names in division two and division
three take a look at what went down on
day one
this is only the beginning of the chess
kid cup and we've already seen some
shocking results Vietnam had a big day
in division two as La Quang Liam and
newy knock trong Sun won fine matches
with new in upsetting former candidate
Dimitri andrekin
in one of the heavyweight matches
Vladimir fedesev ousted another former
candidate shakriar mamajirov in tie
breaks and then just resigned was it a
one move blunder fan favorite David
Anton guillero won one of the prettiest
games of the year in the chess kid cup
play-in and today he continued his
winning ways with a victory in the final
game over the Ukrainian Martin kravsis
the third division features two matches
in the first day and only eight of the
32 players won both matches tomorrow
we'll see Grand Masters Sam sevian
battle allenpy show Mikhail antipov
faced by tally bernatsky pantalahari
Krishna against Igor Lisi and finally
the young Dennis lazovic faces dingley
wren's favorite player Francisco Valejo
pons
and don't forget the winner of division
two punches his ticket into the next
events division one so there really is a
lot on the line for these players and
it's the one and only Simon Williams who
has been keeping us updated with all
that action Simon did you have fun on
day one I had a great time yeah it's
great to be back in Oslo um with you
lovely people here and a bit of a new
crew but everyone's so nice here it
makes it so much easier and uh of course
there was loads of action in the chess
and we're gonna have a look at some of
those results and some of the parents so
division two this is the winners
quarterfinals let's remember that it's a
double knockout so anyone who loses gets
another chance they don't get knocked
out straight away but you've got some
big names here fighting it out a very
interesting David Anton of Spain who's
got a lot of experience in this
competition playing against Vladimir
fedexv and then if we go to the losers
bracket it's double pressure for these
guys because if they lose their match
they go home well they're probably
already at home on their computer but
you get the drift they kind of go home
they're out of the competition and so
yeah some very exciting stuff there in
division two
it's been so much fun following the
action all around and not just division
two division three has some big names
big Grand Masters and also we have been
seeing a lot of young talents there Sam
Savion he took division three at the at
things Masters he's got a big chance to
do it again this time uh uh Simon he
hasn't died yet Sam and uh the
impressive thing about Sam is that he's
playing in another competition as well
so he's playing over the board and then
he's running back to his computer I hope
the connection is good to playing this
competition which is clearly the better
competition and there he is in the
winners bracket he played fantastic
chess yesterday and he's playing a very
experienced online player and in Pietro
and the losers bracket a lot of pressure
on there could we see the legend
gadokanski go home uh well I'd like to
hear a little see a little video of that
if that happens but look at those names
there and again double pressure for a
lot of these guys and I'd like to see
Harry and Harry go free he's the only
Norwegian playing yeah so uh yeah lots
of big names lots of big encounters
today I was going to ask you looking at
this list Simon that who's your favorite
chess kid from division three
I'm gonna go I don't know if he's a kid
anymore but I'm gonna say Ariana because
he's not really a kid because I I see
him in the pub very often
um but hey I'm gonna go for him anyway
so a bit of an older kid should I say
young adult maybe I wasn't in trouble
I'm not sure if you were supposed to
give that away but of course the fun
keeps coming and so much on the line
they've got door points they've got the
big ticket to the season final and of
course the big bucks take a look at the
road map of the biggest ever season of
the Champions Chester
each event in the Champions chest tour
is broken up into three
never before as the best players in the
world work to win their division and
progress to higher divisions hopefully
securing a playoff spot big prize money
and Tour leaderboard points here's
what's at stake in the three divisions
in each event the winner of division
three receives five thousand dollars and
20 tour points those with the most tour
points at season's end will secure the
wild card slots for the playoffs and
additional prize money the winner of
division two claims ten thousand dollars
fifty tour points and secures a coveted
slot in the next events division one
finally the winner of division one
receives thirty thousand dollars
150 tour points and a guaranteed spot in
the playoffs at the year the playoffs
will include eight players that have
qualified either by winning division one
or by earning enough tour points to
claim one of the wild card slots of
these eight players four will advance to
the live finals in the
end only one Champion will remain
so much to fight for and let's take a
look at the addiction that we start with
today we will be taking a look at the
Hikaru Nakamura versus alireza matchup
and of course it will be the losers
around one that we start with later on
in the day we also have the winners
bracket and some big matchups there as
well super excited to see Fabi take on
not a bag and of course Jordan van
Ferris Dimitri colas who scored big
upsets on day one it's gonna be
interesting to watch them fight it out
and this is the format for the players
in the elimination bracket it's a best
of two and that's the big difference
they don't play four games but they only
play two games against each other 15
minutes with a three second increment
and if that ends in a 1-1 die we will
see the bidding Armageddon we saw that
happened yesterday which uh saw alireza
go down to the elimination bracket
expecting more of that today James yeah
you know I don't think uh in elimination
is is definitely going to be somebody
today but I think it's going to be some
great chess obviously I mean Hikaru is
going to do his thing is what I'm
thinking I think Fabi actually is going
to win that one so I have my picks what
about you guys
and I don't know it's so hard to say I
mean no
instavanger he's ready to play Norway
chess and I found that I play really
well before and after classical
tournaments because you're in the zone
you're doing a lot of training so man
it's going to be a tough one for Fabiano
yeah
but right now this is
getting well do you think this will go
into an Armageddon or will this match be
decided in the rapid and we see Hikaru
there he leads their head-to-head in the
rapid with six wins David does that
modern surprise you it does actually
because I do remember some of these
games being very close often it is
actually Nakamura whose nerves just hold
up better but we mentioned the
Armageddon he covers chances will
increase if it gets that far I do think
frigid needs to strike as early as
possible and he only has two games best
of two to do that ready to start the
players any moment now any moment we are
going to have the first moves and the
best of two means that what each one of
them gets only one white for Hikaru this
is the critical Vibe one thing's for
sure no more London James oh yeah yeah
of course he probably not spend no time
there alone not to London with the
French the French right very close of
course E4 E6 we've seen a lot of
French's lately guys what's up with this
French wave you've been saying this
lately even origin Indians too as well a
lot of Indians were playing French it's
been a wave right now look at the Garden
surprised as we are whoa
oh what is this
at the top level for many many years C4
if at all and I should mention first
just playing under the French flag maybe
he's just being very patriotic here
playing the French defense but David
Magnus played the Polish in Poland it
didn't work out too well for him let's
just hope that's not the case today
at the end already the first surprise C4
by Nakamura
this one doesn't actually head towards
more traditional French territory often
it does lead to more open positions with
white accepting an isolated Central Pawn
normally we see the French defense being
very blocked up black suffering for
space that's why it doesn't necessarily
have the best reputation at the top
level but uh interesting starts this
game
surprising uh Nakamura and he gets
surprised himself now alireza frujo what
do we think of this yeah this is really
annoying in fact I mean I remember
playing French from the black side here
when that C4 happens you like what the
heck is that he's just sitting here
trying to figure out what do I do after
C4 now after you go D5 which is the idea
here we're just gonna trade everything
down we can also go D4 after that you go
C5
I do like the spice there it's gonna be
very spicy here sort of Sicilian like
almost yeah and we are used to seeing
the Queen spawn Advance on the second
move C4 has taken by surprise but let's
see if you've got more
so about this thought now one of these
two players will also be knocked out
shimanov against azul's Daniel you call
their action in the planes what are you
expecting from this one yeah shimanov
basically plays Everything super I mean
both of them are incredibly
unpredictable massard likes to be
creative in the opening
Shimano has shown a tendency to play D4
based openings in recent months
particularly in Rapid and Blitz but
again you know these players are
veterans of online chess they can really
play anything I think these games are
going to be decided in the middle game
rather than in the opening but the
Hikaru for Russian match on the other
hand that might have a different vibe to
it
we do have we're waiting for the first
moves on this game uh Shimano what does
he start with well he did have a really
good advantage in that first game
against Fabi and the narrative could
have been very different had he managed
to convert that but of course Fabi just
dominated the match after surviving that
first game uh big questions here and
perhaps while we wait for the players to
play their first moves guys maybe it's
time to jump back and get the update on
the French between Hikaru and alireza
ferrugia a second no surprise in that
one by Hikaru Nakamura playing C4 uh
David you said that's not an opening
that you've seen often and we also see
that the knights have been traded off
this is still a friend yeah is this more
of a sicilian now I think it's directly
transposed to a Sicilian Defense so they
started with the French they were
flexible they switched things up and do
we think this favors the Central Center
very blocked black has an extra Central
Pawn easy development and queen move by
now mirror what is this is he getting
ready to Castle his king queen side
Daniel I need help here explaining this
last move for white don't try it at home
kids
Queen T3 I've seen this move in certain
Sicilian lines I think he is at least
insinuating that yeah I might be Castle
in Queen side so be careful about castle
in kingside because I might send that
g-pawn down the board the other thematic
idea is Queen D3 to G3 uh could could be
very unpleasant particularly flag
deploys that Bishop from f8 then G7 and
E5 would both be hanging also known as a
fork could have said that in one word
rather than the four sentences but
Hikaru really making Ali Reza think and
I like it I think when you're in
somewhat bad form you want to get fresh
positions you know kind of come back to
your roots and dalireza calling hikaru's
bluff saying send it my way don't you
dare put that Queen on G3 wow
interesting stuff calling the bluff and
if this does happen I guess there are
two ways to deal with this either you
could castle and hope that after Queen
takes porn you are able to whip up some
conversation compensation I just wanted
to show we're having a great
conversation exactly conversation
compensation there's more than that
because Bishop takes porn I just wanted
to show one trick this is why black uh
was happy to actually give up the pawn
temporarily a nasty fork in the air
there instead Nakamura of course avoids
this with white and just exchanges dot
squared Bishops so maybe a more slow
kind of path to this game now more
strategic territory with this last move
I'm definitely taking a light here I
mean it feels like there's some holes in
Black's position we did started a fringe
and now we're playing E5 now of course
uh farusion being a very creative
aggressive player as well there's lots
of moves that he can make um to make
things obviously uh very fun here it's
more sicilian-like with the pawn still
on C6 very strange like oh it looks like
a sicilian but then it's really not
because the Pawn's still on C6 so maybe
it was more of an E5 opening but it came
from a French I know you you were
confused at home definitely it's
understandable because it's confusing
here I went from a French to some type
of Sicilian to now an E5 opening
whatever this is at the same time I do
like white because we do have the clamp
on the D5 Square we can castle queenside
and as Daniel mentioned here we can push
Gary the g-pawn Gary the g-pawn right we
can push that boy yes right yes Gary the
G bomb we can push him down the board
there have some fun I do like white so
chances here yeah I would pick white too
and this feels like the Nakamura type of
position just stability nothing uh too
flashy he's not taking too much risk at
this early stage and okay farouza now
offering an end game trying to get the
Queens off the board I think
strategically this makes a lot of sense
black has a really harmonious Pawn
structure but can Nakamura avoid this
perhaps Daniel well David in 1968 Lou
Williams for the queen shade in a very
similar way really in the tournament in
Mario del Plata wow in reality I don't
think that white should take on B6
um because that opens up the a file for
black it joins together the queen Side
Pawn structure I'm thinking Queen D2
Queen G3 should be calculated there's
some messy stuff going there the queen
takes B2 Queen takes C5 but Queen D2 is
a viable alternative I think James made
a great point that D7 Pawn is a
long-term weakness for black because if
you ever push it to D6 well you solve
the problem of The Bishop's development
but then the pawn remains weak so an
early decision to make for Nakamura but
I don't think he's gonna take B6 which
probably means he's going to take on B6
just to show that on the board it does
connect the black pawns now one nice
porn Island everything connected here
and uh yeah I think this looks really
really healthy for black so I agree I
think that would be the most sensible
move no other real way to keep the
Queens on the board
other than Queen D2 without allowing
crazy complications so Nakamura thinking
for the first real time in this game and
that's the move we're expecting here in
the studio I would love to see those
crazy complications but it's perhaps too
early in the day for Hikaru nakam where
to start with that well he is taking his
time to evaluate the end game or whether
to keep the Queens on the board but
definitely alireza faruja can be happy
with this opening outcome not just
keeping the clock in Balance but the
Queen stay on the board let's not forget
there is such a nice nice post on that
D4 Square black snail eventually once as
the game progresses can maneuver and
find its way to D4 take control of that
meanwhile that light squared Bishop that
Hikaru has still has to find the future
and the one feature that is happening
yeah we can go to the next game if y'all
like I mean we're gonna be uh there's
gonna be a long one king E7 yeah they're
gonna be here a long time guys a long
long time what you think David you want
to go to sleep you will never I love it
James I'm a grinder by Nature I love my
queenless positions where you can bore
your opponent to death I approve I think
Hikaru himself knows this wasn't
objectively White's best but he likes
that type of position where he can just
slowly take his time and outplay his
opponent a bit later on
and I think for those who might be new
to chess it's really interesting to
understand how you can evaluate these
kind of positions you can judge and
count upon islands that are there we see
for white there are two Pawn Islands
you've got three pawns on the queen side
four pawns on the king side all of black
spawns are intact they're together there
isn't a weakness but that D6 Pawn you
have to watch out for that one could be
a potential Target but black has enough
counter play on the open a file more
peace activity Daniel alireza should be
pleased about Landing up in this end
game yeah this is definitely equal the
eval bar don't lie
both sides really have a bunch of easy
moves Rook H to d8 secures the D6 Pawn
you mentioned the D4 post so it might
take black as long to get his Knight
there as it did for me to fly from
Charlotte to Oslo but it'll it'll get
there eventually 98 Knight C7 step onto
the bishop because that's legal and the
Knight D4 could be a long-term dream
I'm picardo does like these grinded out
positions I'm just curious how Hikaru is
going to pose problems here once black
plays rook d8 and secures that D6 Pawn
the B6 Pawn can be attacked with B3 and
Knight A4 but that's essentially just a
one move threat so I I think Ali res is
doing great here I think the likeliest
outcome is still a draw
who would you pick if you had to in this
position I know I would pick black here
without uh without even thinking like
any day all day of the week every week
of the year I'm gonna actually go with
why here because of the maroxy pine
setup of course nowadays they do say if
you have D5 or you get B5 in actually
black does has those nice options so the
bind here on e4 and C4 is you want to
get the bind in there obviously so when
you get to bind on the center so you can
play D5 it's a failure when they
actually are able to play D5 in many
cases so D5 maybe it would be played but
we can stop it for a long time the
problem is I mean this is not a moroxy
bond you don't have more pieces on the
board and then these morocci buying
positions a lot of times you do get what
they say a position that's really nice
for white you get the pawns on F3 and B3
you get all the light Square uh prop
problems or you give them to black as
well like you get cramped for um for
black you keep black and very cramped
but the problem is that you can't really
improve as much as you want after you
get this position you get F3 B3 and
you're like cool I got this great
position and then you're just kind of
like moving maneuvering trying to figure
out things here white usually is a
favorite there but black this is not a
maroxy buying the pawn is on C6 we can
try to play D5 or B5 at some point so I
do like white slightly there here's B3
right and then obviously Black's gonna
try to play B5 or D5 probably yeah and I
just fear for whites light Square Bishop
the light Square Bishop is stuck kind of
entombed within its own Pawn structure
and that often long term is the problem
piece so uh if you're far Asia you would
love to for example take the knights off
the board and just say okay my Bishop is
slightly better than your Bishop uh at
least my Bishop the black Bishop here
covers the light squares the pawns
covered the dark squares for white
there's no cover really here for the
dark color complex so yeah it's all
these small little details that uh often
do decide the game long term but uh for
now we don't need to worry too much the
players are just going to slowly improve
their pieces and the action will happen
later G5 wow the Queens might be off the
board but guy the G Pawn is alive in
this one G5 has been played and of
course this isn't really a bad attack
but gaining more space on the gang side
you want to control more more squares on
that part of the board this one is going
to be a grind it's going to be a long
fight between these two players let's
take this moment to check in on our
other match up as you Alexander Seminole
with the black pieces facing and this
one Queens are on action is on and I
should mention another French defense so
two out of two so far today uh playing
the French against the Frenchman this
time against Jean musad uh interesting
position what do we think uh who would
we pick here why definitely why we had
the space of course if we can move the
bishop maybe we can play King H1 f45 at
some point we just see aggressive
intentions the bishop there it is
they're the Bishops misplaced we got to
put that boy on D3 that's for me and we
bout to go for me uh Bishop D3 maybe
Knight F3 to G5 at some point the pawn
on E5 usually signifies that I have an
attack or go for an attack so of course
if there's a Pawn on D4 upon structure
points to the side you should play on so
black should be playing Queen side white
on the king so very very fun I think for
white here I definitely will take white
all day attacking chances
see black gold
beef your dog talking about rerouting
your Bishop is time for black to think
about how to create that play on The
Queen side and he starts with Rook B8 so
definitely B4 is on the radar the
minority attack where we will see the
two pawns that black has on the queen
side fight it out with the three pawns
for white so that eventually black can
have a weakness to Target yeah I think
you're right Tanya he should have played
this before it was too late because now
it might be white has the option himself
of locking this one down and this is
quite a typical idea I'm not sure
whether it's great here but uh for
example if black Retreats you could
establish a knight now on this square
and long term you have a clamp you have
control over this nice Outpost and James
your idea later on moving the bishop
throwing the F Pawn forward it feels
like you've really stabilized here with
white and long term black is left with
some real weaknesses especially this
Pawn I don't really like the black light
Square Bishop in this position so okay
instead of this he did however Play
Bishop D3 and
caveman style he's going for checkmate
Queen H5 take this H Pawn what do we
think is this as dangerous as it looks
Daniel would you get yeah I'm jumping on
the jungle massage train this is what I
always feel about these types of
positions where one side attacks the
king and the other side attacks and the
other flank well the problem is that
there's no King on the queen side for
white so B5 B4 that is Black's only
serious idea the problem with pushing
the d-pawn and trying to do the same
thing is that you're giving white this
very important E4 Square for his Knight
and from there then I could go to D6 the
Eva bars you know not amused uh that
sequence of events so we probably will
see blackplay before but white could
respond by ignoring or pushing uh C4 and
either option looks uh entirely entirely
fine Knight D2 to B3 like a combine
positional play with James more tactical
plan of f4 we want more F5 we live just
destroy the whole gang side I told you
that Donnie is my brother here y'all
didn't tell you y'all couldn't tell we
look exactly that's exactly right what's
up bro come on ridiculous out here yeah
it's very nice though B4 is on the board
there may be a rooster one could put
something on the file there or just
completely ignore him and just literally
go for me King H1 tried to play f45 at
some point maybe even a queen H5 I
definitely like that move and after G6
go Queen H6 to put the bishop on H4 and
try to get in there that way now of
course he will have a bishop E7 so
there's some stuff he can't defend with
but definitely white is is uh trying to
attack for sure we're trying to get this
made off very quickly yeah exactly
multiple ways to try and play this
position you could go strategic or you
can go straight for the kill and uh
Jewel he's spending some time now wisely
as all the top players do he realizes
that it's kind of a matter of taste and
it's quite committal whatever white
tries to do so he's just sitting on his
hands he's saying okay I'm gonna come up
with a long-term plan over the next few
moves and then I'm going to commit to it
and we go from there uh shimanov
meanwhile it's maybe a bit uh less
choice for him he's just reacting at
this point with black first he has to
react to it and attack against his dark
Square Bishop
and he's likely to drop back now classic
Jazz stuff right your opponent plays on
one side of the board you target the
other side this is going to be an action
on well all over with white going for a
king side attack black trying to create
weaknesses on the pawn structures on the
queen side falls back with the bishop t7
we are expecting also the A5 a pawn to
advance down the board meanwhile white
still has to push the F Pawn to try and
break open Black's King this is gonna be
a hot middle game but let's just zoom
out for a moment and go back to the
other big game we've got an end game
there already
is facing a pawn storm there's H4 G3
Harry and Gary on fire is are there
Queens on the board and they're just
missing
invisible Queen invisible yeah so we're
looking at the same position here wow
this is crazy fridge uh just uh despite
the absence of Queens going straight for
it he's throwing all of his pawns
forward on that King side for black and
I like it look at that white Bishop now
it is really stuck on the light squares
no dark Square control and it's an easy
path in for ferrugia's night as black it
could be good night versus bad Bishop
could be good night for nakamura's
trance is in the tournament he might
have to be going to the good night bar
after that exactly uh I do envisage and
now on the next few moves this night
coming into the juicy F4 Square from
there it's gonna sit pretty for the rest
of the game and you can't challenge it
I'm wondering whether you do this now as
black for example okay we can trade a
set of Pawns but black is going to be
the one fighting for the h file later
this Knight is gonna sit targeting this
weak backward pawn and watch out for
this one long term being a real Menace
the porno G3 might well promote to win
the game at the end looking good for
black I've got to say yes positionally
gross I mean like that's just it's
positionally gross right now especially
after the night coming to F4 he just has
a clear plan Knight H5 to F4 you can't
really even stop B and then you can't
really get this g-pawn off of the G
Square on G3 right so after we trade I
mean didn't even and you're trying to
play something like Knight F1 I mean we
even have Rook G8 there then swing the
Knight over to H5 and then to F4 it's
very tough here weirdly enough you can
even somehow get the king to G5 right
and then just to tell you how strong the
position could be get the king to G5
maybe bring the Rook down on the H file
I mean there's so much play on the dark
squares here for black and uh obviously
as you pointing out David too as well
the bishop on D3 is absolutely gross the
position I mean dark Square grows Bishop
gross I mean this is a bad position I
mean practically for for white right now
Daniel can you see anything good to say
what about the white position here not
much I mean nicaro hasn't gotten
anything started in the center or on the
queen side and another problem is that
if white plays H3 and tries to lock up
the king side in the long run once the
Knight gets to F4 there are ideas of the
bishop sacrificing himself on H3 One
swipe moves The Rook away from H1 and
those two menacing connected pastors
especially with another pair of Rooks
off the board are going to get really
dangerous this may sound all
hypothetical but that's how you want to
think in these types of end games right
it's not just about the next two or
three moves you want the game to head in
general direction that favors you I
still think Hikaru is probably going to
be able to hold this but he's got a long
task ahead of him and he's just not
looking like the Hikaru that we're used
to Tanya absolutely and as you're
pointing out these threats difficult for
Hikari to face them to think about them
keep them in his mind right now because
it could mean game over you got Knight
H5 jumping onto F4 but David I really
want to use this moment because the last
time we saw this position that pawn was
on G5 and now we come to this point
where there's H4 G3 that's already
happened and Black's the one who's
pushing on the king side Hikaru under
tremendous pressure we've got to do an
action replay how did Ali Reza manage to
get so much meanwhile Hikaru hasn't
built that counter play on the d-line
yeah uh let's go back in for that action
replay it was here that faruga started
the pawn storm the Avalanche he played
G5 gaining space why not you're putting
pawns on dark squares as well they
complement your Bishop nakama removed
his King
G4 why not just continue and H5 the
pawns just rolled literally no finesse
about this I'm gonna push the pawns hope
for the best and this was uh I think the
key move Tanya the one that impressed
you the most uh pushing forward this is
actually a pawn sacrifice but if the
Rooks had come off the board and uh
White had been greedy here look how weak
these white pawns are these are double
pawns uh this E4 Pawn as well tying down
White's Bishop long term and it's just a
temporary sacrifice now I think this
Pawn will fall off the board so Nakamura
is trying his best to keep things
compact he's trying to protect
everything and uh okay let's go back to
the game he has indeed captured on G3
and okay he's brought his Rook across
he's really abandoning the H file now if
black does plant the Knight on F4 I
guess the idea is to move his Bishop I'm
not sure which direction uh he's gonna
move it back and he's gonna at least
argue that he has a target of his own
this black D6 Pawn is backward and his
hit for now okay he's actually gone in
the other way uh other direction with
his Bishop but uh the threat Still
Remains Rook takes Pawn on tap next move
it does make sense though is he uh he's
just as you said he abandoned the H file
there it's a great way to put it here
because I mean he's been in the whole
King side over there G2 is well defended
and his argument is hey you are never
getting through there and I I can
actually see that the knights holding G2
very well D6 is hanging and there's a
rook d8 now on the board defending D6
here and I guess we just Shuffle Just
Shuffle back and forth here from this
point on because this is what you get in
these maroxy buying positions here where
sometimes you can't really do much more
than having a great position and try to
shuffle but of course Hikaru being
resourceful he goes B4 here Daniel yeah
Hikaru is saying listen uh you're not
the only one having your fun and that's
the thing about these open files it
seems so tempting to play Rook h8 to H2
and you feel good about yourself Until
you realize wait that G2 Pawn isn't
falling on its own it's actually the
most well protected Pawn in White's
entire camp and Hikaru is going to play
given the opportunity A4 A5 A6 we in the
mix remember that Rook on d8 is tied
down to the pawn on D6 so it's easy to
wax
um to exaggerate the extent of Black's
advantager I think the objective
evaluation is a lot closer to equality
than it might appear in alireza very
careful move Rook D7 I think preparing
to swing The Rook over to A8 in the
event of A4
yeah really nice move there staying
flexible is black and uh let's leave
these players to think for a while
aesthetically beautiful for black it's
just hard to improve and look at what
Nakamura is doing it's as you said just
uh kind of waiting just sitting uh he's
asking for user what to do next there
are a lack of Pawn breaks for black a
lack of ways to open up the position and
therefore if you can't break through
using the H file you might be a bit
stuck the position might fizzle out to
uh just to draw their neutral kind of uh
equality just neither side able to find
a productive plan
of the opening has done everything right
placed his pieces on the best possible
squares but where is the break can he
make more progress and it seems like the
experts feel that it's not gonna be that
easy another objective evaluation in
chess and then there's the Hikaru
evaluation James I want to ask you how's
Hikaru feeling about his position you
know he kind of thinks he can win every
position and if he does he gets very mad
right even if the position we're like oh
man it's a clear draw King Rick versus
King Rook he's like oh come on I just
could have won that like it was the same
with monitorial king or King Rook but
here I mean he wants to win I mean you
can never like uh be mad at a spirit
like that just very he always wants to
win always wants to go forward and
farooja actually has that same type as
well so it's very nice to see this class
of Titans here yeah wants to win but are
there any chances we've been talking
about the fact that Hikaru is being
resourceful everything under control but
is there a possibility that white can
start getting ambitious at all in this
yeah well there's two two Pathways I
think for for white to win this game the
first is first allows some sort of a485
which is unlikely because then the pawn
becomes a weakness the second is farusha
plays t-65 which he might not be
preparing he might be insinuating that
he's preparing it to scare Hikaru off
but if he plays that move the Center
opens up you get some Pawn structure
imbalances and if you're black you might
might misevaluate in certain cases the
resulting structure you might give white
too much activity so if Arusha gets over
ambitious then you know all things are
possible yeah and that last move that we
see by Hikaru it's sort of preempting
that break on D5 to us it might look
like one second he's moved the Rook from
an open file where it was targeting a
weakness to a file that's absolutely
blocked with the Knight and the pawn in
front but actually that Rook on E1 will
be ideally placed
at any moment goes for the break the
central break of D5 which is definitely
something David that alireza is thinking
about yeah he's thinking about it right
now if you do push your Pawn forward I
guess we'll see a bunch of exchanges
Tanya and uh here I'm not exactly sure
what uh Nakamura wants to do it looks
very tempting to move your knight to
this Square for example Target this Pawn
with your knight and Rook you could also
make an argument for simply capturing
and after all of these exchanges it's
not clear who this is favored actually I
would say potentially white because this
one is a very dangerous Pawn long term
uh Annie the apron over here but uh okay
farusha decides against this keeping his
cards close to his chest he just pushes
F6 he's just saying okay I'm protecting
this Pawn so in that variation maybe
things will be a bit more promising for
blackened wow shovel Shuffle City I mean
you know hey Everyday I'm Shuffling this
is like you're gonna shuffle your pieces
back and forth here this is very likely
to be a draw unless somebody makes some
type of Pawn break I mean even a shout
out to Robert Bobby in fact a Hess right
can you spell chance without has no
chest without Hess here as you say
um whoever controls the Palm breaks
controls the game we learned that from
him a lot and he likes to say that and
it mentions that you have Pawn breaks of
C5 for white also for black at B5 and D5
so I mean these are like you know you
have one I have one I have one you have
one so this could level out and this
could easily be some type of draw but at
the right moment uh yeah you do have to
push one of these pawns maybe it depends
it's some risk involved pushing these
pawns yeah and it's on the board there
it is okay there we go belt's fastened
ladies and gentlemen buckle up yeah
unless immortal like me would have just
waited
right in the next game you know let's be
safe for which has got a minute Less on
the clock nah I don't care D5 that's why
he's so good for us you're always
creating action that's why he's a fan
favorite in D5 we're gonna see
everything come off the board Knights
Rooks Pawns will it just be a bishop end
game at the very end
David and I want to ask
Judy right now and only the Bishops
remain well no more because well he
might pick it up with that Knight and he
does we might see this happen in a pure
bishop and pawn ending I've got to say
with that G2 F3 structure if anyone can
be better will it be black yeah Black's
got this incredibly juicy idea of Bishop
takes F3 and G2 and I pointed this out
in a different context earlier David
pointed out White's Pawn majority on the
queen side the most dangerous type of
pass Pawn is what's called an outside
pass Pawn that's a past Pawn Which is
far removed from all of the other pawns
because in order to prevent it your king
or your minor piece have to withdraw
themselves from the other pawns leaving
them vulnerable to attack so this is
actually a very hard end game to
evaluate faruga he's gone D5 largely on
the basis of intuition David yeah I
completely agree he feels that this
position is uh relatively risk-free full
black despite the fact that white is
about to create a postpone he is very
much banking on the fact that for
example here white can never ever move
the bishop as you guys mentioned just to
put this on the board moving the bishop
would lose instantly always to Bishop
takes and running the g-pawn through to
Victory so he's just banking on the fact
that white is a bit stuck here and
actually in this position black has
multiple plans to try and improve
himself he can start pushing this Pawn
forward followed by the e-pawn he can
start bringing his King forward in well
both directions here you can even try
and snake it around the whole way
towards the king side and Black's Bishop
does cover the promotion square of the a
pawn so it looks relatively safe here
for black and if anyone I would choose
farooza's position and I think his
instincts are correct here the question
is in the current position does Nakamura
have an option can he retain the tension
does he have to trade everything off
maybe he wants to move his Knight to a
different Square we're just going to
figure it out now because he is actually
going to be under two minutes here we do
know that Hikaru is a beast but I mean
we're beasts matching another Beast like
I mean definitely top three four on
Blitz and bullet is so yeah of course I
am just as fast as you are it says
farouza many times so you gotta be
careful here I mean again in this time
trouble you do make mistakes when you
get lower on time and you can see almost
you know half the time here for free car
rule this is actually a great moment for
all the chess kids out there super
instructive for alireza farusha he
envisioned that an end game whether only
bishops left on the board will be super
good for him and decides to play D5
because it's the right moment to provoke
those trades and which is why Hikaru
Nakamura takes a decision do not
exchange those knights with the eval bar
disapproves of Knight C4 is there a
tactical shot in this position we need
our tactical wizard Daniel here I see
the calculation face I'm trying to
figure it out so Knight D5 to F4 is a
super tempting move because it aims at
the G2 Pawn but after the trade on D7 or
trades on D7 the B6 Pawn is also hanging
you might want to sacrifice that one but
then you're giving white connected
passers on the queen side two pass pawns
connected to each other very dangerous
for us version doesn't touch that with a
10 foot pole he says why do I need to
move my knight away from D5 it's doing
great it's defending B6 it's keeping the
C4 Knight at Bay and remember that H
file that I still possess I'm going back
to it and now the infiltration might be
quite a bit more dangerous with the g2
Pawn not as well defended White's also
distracted by the more open situation in
the center I like that choice yeah I
like this choice too I think it's very
natural from farusha I did take a peek
there at the computer the winning move
well the computer says it's winning was
extremely difficult not human at all at
least the winning idea it was actually
to push this Pawn forward play B5 and
then just jump in with Knight E3
allowing a nasty check what we can't
blame for Rouge that's crazy oh for
missing this one sorry this would just
have led to Pure chaos which would have
been good for black but instead he plays
a far more natural move bringing his
Rook to a uh h8 and now the a pawn has
started rolling this one is anyone's
game uh again we see the engine
suggestions and looks good for black but
not nothing easy here no easy path to
victory for farugia
this is not a quiet end game anymore
they are going for each other it really
could be anybody's game and let's not
forget it is only a best of two in the
elimination bracket A4 played both
players playing less than two minutes on
the clock
if you had to make a prediction at this
point James how does this one end yeah
actually I mean I feel the momentum in
for rouge's side right now he has a lot
of options you have the open a h file I
mean look at The Rook shifting back and
forth every day I'm shuffling right of
course you guys know that song Right
hopefully you do if you don't you can
listen to it today but you know every
day I'm shuffling he shuffled that Rook
back and forth I have options I got a
patch g-pawn over there I feel like I
have more initiative which is time space
activity things like this then white
does of course in these moroccy buying
type positions where the bind's now
broken white usually is just shuffling
in fact or trying to find good moves to
play and improve my position but we've
already improved it we got the double
Rooks the bishop is actually doing
something it's an active uh it's not the
greatest Bishop but it's useful in doing
things here and we're just kind of
Defending it feels like from White's
Point uh we do want to push the a pawn
have a pass a pawn but then again that
could be weak um depending on what black
does we can double the Rooks we can also
attack that pawn later so objectively
practically I think uh farouza
definitely has a nice chance here but an
maybe it's it's probably closer to a
draw and did you see Nakamura as well a
few moments ago he was just thinking he
was like shaking his head he's like I
gotta move I've got to move 30 seconds
left now and some big threats appearing
on the board suddenly Black's night
might at some point jump out the way the
white B4 Pawn is a bit loose and uh it's
not easy for Nakamura to even find a
move look at it 20 20 seconds and the
goal for Ali reserves just keep the
tension as long as possible because with
all these pieces on the board it's just
impossible to make the best move with
almost no time remaining with farrugia
down in a minute as well this is going
to be all out Anarchy on the board right
now yeah for sure I was asking for that
Andrew okay five he wants to trade off
the pieces but eventually you won
default on A5 to try and March down the
board I is black going to trade Rooks
you really don't want to allow the a
passer here no but if you play Rook B8
you allow white to get two pieces for
Rook even that position is hard to
evaluate it might be good for black with
the Rook invading B1 at the end of the
line you could also play Rook a to d8 in
order to keep the sort of General
character of the position 40 seconds now
for alireza so many decisions to make on
every move for both players yeah this is
a key moment if he swaps the Rooks I
think actually things will turn and then
we did he did oh that was a terrible
move yeah that white a pawn now is going
to be so strong potentially long term
still some threats whites Knight Under
Fire here has to retreat oh it's Bishop
really passive but that white a pawn is
going to be a thorny black side for the
rest of the game I made no sense to me
because Rook B7 was a safe option to
play for two results Hikaru seems
annoyed but that's just Hikaru doing a
car I think he's probably annoyed about
what he did 15 moves ago right yeah and
a check you've got to be slightly
careful where you go you can't step
forward to the third rank that the black
Rook would have come down with a nasty
check hitting the White Knight right the
white king living a Charmed Life here 20
seconds for both these players that
April you want a draw bro
I think if I were I would love
it right now but if I go King B1
actually in rugby two knowing Hikaru he
might get tempted by King B1 oh is he
gonna do it now you want to draw My Guy
this is his last chance second time
we've seen this position
King B2 is a draw on the spot
oh he's gonna go for it yes yeah
there we go it is a draw after all that
drama missed opportunity though for
alarisa for Asia
yeah wow that does feel like early
results got more reasons to be
displeased with that he was in control
in that game but Hikaru he is such a
resourceful beast and he does it one
more time they will play another game
but there is action on on the other boat
Jules musad playing against the
Alexander shimanov the Queens are still
on the boat and there's a king on each
tree wow this game has turned around
completely white has not gotten off the
ground on the king side on the other
side of the board he is a pawn down and
the bishop on D4 in a little bit of
trouble but it can be easily defended by
the Queen the King on H3 definitely not
safe Black's got a lot of avenues
including Queen C1 which would threaten
a very nasty check on H1 White's got to
be very careful here
yeah to trade queens or not to trade
Queens that's the first question for
black I agree I would want to keep the
Queens on because white king is the
weaker of the two that's typical chess
wisdom if your king is safer keep the
Queens on go for checkmate why not and
ends the game and okay shimanov here
okay he keeps the Queen's on I was gonna
say it would have been risk-free to
trade for Queens but also your winning
chances would have been reduced and whoa
Retreats James surely this is going to
be a win for black just looks so
pleasant to play what was funny I am
that guy I'm that guy that's like nah
I'm good I'm good here I'm Nigel short
king walk into H6 now of course you're
gonna get made it on National Television
if your king is on H6 in this position
but it is some things that you can do
with like F5s coming because we do have
the back rank that uh the problems of
the the uh the pin here you know with
the Rook so you can't move the bishop
because we'll take right and uh the
light squares are defended by the queen
so if I get F5 in 10 seconds maybe some
problems here so Queen d8 okay Queen B6
defending d8 but F5 is definitely
something to look at here I mean we do
have the options to call the Bishops
here and I feel like the light score
Bishop if we can play F5 and take on E6
we have some chances here but of course
definitely you have to uh be very very
careful because your king is out in the
middle of the street there it is let's
go
with seven seconds will he be able to
handle this position there are big
threats that Shimano is facing three
seconds he's gonna make a move to the
house take him
to check I guess he wants and queen C6
checks some sort of Perpetual we have
four and control the eight six square
oh that's interesting
so why might be taking over here oh yeah
definitely
she's had trouble here
I think the queen was headed to eight
six we see Shaman over here
Bishop F7 and that is game over the
queen picks it up there's a check on G5
The Rook falls on V8 and shimanov he
shakes his head it's all he can do right
now yikes and he walks away after that
one that's tough wow what a loss my
brother and we see that Jewels
celebrating Queen G5 check wins The Rook
this is what is so tricky about these
formats you've really got to be on your
A-game with the tactics Shimano just
cannot catch a break particularly in
game one again everything seems seeming
to go his way but James Canty he called
it F5 it didn't come as quickly as we
thought it would but when it did it
caused total pandemonium in Black's
position you let his clock run too low
Alexander shimanov is on the ropes now
he has to win game two to force an
Armageddon
and absolutely intense round one and
David we have to turn to you what were
the big takeaways for just kids watching
around the world the big takeaway is
just to stay calm even if you're in time
pressure and go on the attack it's far
easier to attack than it is to defend
and uh just to show the closing stages
again in slow motion in that game
between Jewel musad and Alexander
shimanov black panicked here retreated
the queen allowing white to step forward
the attack Begins the black king peered
down on this diagonal by the white
bishop and it was this position where
the final blunder happened black needed
to slide across and give a check when
the white king Retreats actually
multiple ways to defend here but at the
very least you can slide your king in
the corner and the game goes on things
have turned but Black's still fighting
instead Queen to G6 allowed a nice
killer blow always look for checks
captures and threats Bishop takes a nice
double attack forcing the queen away and
another double attack wins the game
checks captures and threats write that
down a hundred times right now what a
game one we've had and this is the score
line only one more game remains in the
elimination bracket and Hikaru Nakamura
survives a bit of a scare there with the
white pieces alireza ferrugia created
his chances out of a French defense on
the other hand Jules Musa did play the
French defense and won his game against
Alexander shimanov after a big Miss by
plaque while Jules was the side which
faced the French there it's going to be
a big round two coming up but before
that we're gonna go into a short quick
twitch break
[Music]
been on Farm today in day in his game
one against he kept it precise he kept
it in control with black he was the one
who was pushing and the one thing we
know about alireza when he's down to
those seconds in those time scrambles
his chess is from another planet take a
look
the A7 Pawn at the right moment yeah I
think a car is waiting for that he
watched that match for sure
and but you can't check now that's oh
wait what do the cards do
you moved it from he's gonna get flagged
here oh
I'll tricked him and and Oliver's trying
to win on the clock
[Music]
oh my God the Rouge is gonna send it
over time
no he's gonna win it he's gonna win it
yeah he wins it he wins it oh God this
is insane man this is insane this is
insane
and easy
this is brilliant this is insane
wall number four alireza ferrugia he was
the youngest player to ever break the
2800 bracket he is a former runner-up in
the world rapper championship and the
world Blitz championship and absolute
beast in these speeches format but we
have seen that consistency to be a big
question for him and David he's got a
big game two coming up against Hikaru
he's got to keep in control just like he
did in game one yeah good news and bad
news for for Russia good news he played
very well in the first game he had
opportunities the bad news is he didn't
capitalize on them so now with the white
pieces he has to find that killer uh
Instinct yeah
will start with the white pieces and for
Hikaru it hasn't been the studies
thought that we expect from him but
let's not forget even though he's done
in the elimination bracket I think for a
lot of us he's still a favorite to win
the tournament and we've seen him make
these huge comebacks Daniel last event
he was in the elimination bracket he
beat Magnus he beat Fabi he can still do
this listen that's just the byproduct of
of winning as much as he does we expect
him to win every tournament every single
match and sometimes we forget who his
opponents are right now as opponent is
the world number two player his previous
opponent was a super Grand Master who
has won the Tata steel chess tournament
but again Hikaru wins one game right now
he's right back in this tournament
nobody is counting him out but he is
playing very shaky right now as is his
opponent that was a back and forth game
that alireza is going to kick himself
Tanya for not winning because he was
really one move away that B5 line that
basically ended the game
was the world number two currently he is
world number four and that has also been
because of his uh inconsistency that
we've seen we haven't seen him that much
in classical play as well but right now
it is going to be about his opponent he
can't be too pleased with the way he has
started at the chess kid cup alireza
there looking confident with the black a
solid hold in game one he starts with
what James opening predictions yeah
farouzia can play really anything here
but he's very ferocious so I'm
definitely looking for some E4 here but
of course hey Hikaru is one of the best
to play against E4 he's going to play E5
very solid stuff it's hard to get
chances against him with that maybe he
needs to mix it up maybe with some C4 I
think C4 is probably a great option here
just to mix it up you got so many routes
you can go with the C4 option so I'm
saying C4 what you gotta do yeah uh
every time I play Furious he tends to
open E4 he goes straight down the
Italian game and uh he knows everything
there is to know all the little details
all the little
[Laughter]
it's the Italian game
and both players huge experts maybe
leading experts in this field Daniel
yeah you know who's not a leading expert
in this field you're truly like I can't
even get the move order I don't know
when to play D6 and D5 I always lose the
light squared Bishop with white there's
so many subtleties that the players are
completely fluent in you know when to
pull the bishop B3 lever when to play
Knight D2 to F1 to G3 I guess the answer
to that is now
um and of course for black Wendy you
Castle short sometimes delaying castling
that's in fashion I mean Ali Reza knows
perfectly what's in fashion Bishop E6 is
a move here so very hard opening to
study I think you'll back me up on this
yeah I've lost countless hours in my
life probably hundreds of hours trying
to study the Italian and my only
conclusion is just like you Daniel I
still know nothing and it's still so
confusing uh one little move order trick
often Changes Everything Changes all the
plans changes the evaluation and these
players have to stay flexible but
Nakamura he's really experienced in
these positions he does react quite
quickly he does commit his King to the
the king side and will the fact that
farugia hasn't castled yet play a factor
here white doesn't necessarily need to
Castle the king yet you can still
maneuver around there we go he's playing
the waiting game just covering some
squares and we'll see how Nakamura
reacts wow are you guys are keeping
flexible he hasn't committed his King on
the king side yet the Knight can jump
over to G3 he will take these decisions
this will be a slow start but we've seen
exactly how that ends up with the two of
them in round one but the other game
there can't be any slow start because
shimanov has to win on demand to force
an Armageddon he is trailing but the
good news for shimanov is that he starts
with the white pieces he can start
attacking but I have to ask you know I
know that as commentators we are a bit
hesitant to talk about body language
looking way too relaxed right now what's
going on but if he leans back any
further if I fall off that chair
that's funny yeah it looks like he's
just uh they literally don't care right
I think he feels real you know he
doesn't feel good about the loss
obviously but at the same time I think
he just is okay he's calm you know what
I mean you can tell he's not really
tense he's just chill relaxed I mean
usually you lean into the screen every
move like you've never seen the first
few moves before so intense but here I
mean he seems relaxed so that's a good
thing
yeah partly relaxed but partly
regretting life choices in the previous
game uh we've all been there we all have
that uh kind of dilemma how do you
recover from a loss and okay quick
opening it's a kind of an anti-saicilian
not one of the main lines uh not the
open Sicilian yet but there we go he
throws his Central Pawn forward and I've
seen this before a couple of times I'm
not a big expert here though Daniel no
I'm just captive I just wonder what
chair it is that allows them to lean
them far back and how he's making moves
with his hand on the map you just want
to know the logistics of his setup but
yeah this this actually is a fashionable
line I talked about this yesterday this
tendency to discover new anti-sicilians
and rejuvenate them just nobody wants to
swim uh in the crazy Waters of the night
Earth anymore this is a pretty
positional line white just develops
normally Knight F3 Bishop can come out
to F4 G5 and typically I think in this
line White Castle's King side and tries
to apply slow but steady pressure on
black center of course objectively the
position is pretty much dead equal
yep dead equal but plenty of scope for
either side to outplay the opponents and
black has a nice compact Pawn structure
white has the space so you have to give
to take and you're here very balanced
and I think a good choice for shimanov
no forcing lines still plenty of pieces
left on the board and uh if he can hold
his nerve then
uh he will get chances later down the
line looking at Terminal it just doesn't
feel like he's going for the kill in
this game and that better be deceptive
because he needs to do exactly that he
has to win to keep his chances alive in
the chess get cup the good news is that
there are still a lot of pieces on the
board a lot to play for here Knight D5
has been paid and very often black
doesn't want to trade on D5 allow that
white Pawn to get there take away more
space open up the e-file that just give
gives white a lot of play in the center
Knight D5 is not a move that you usually
want to make if not that night that
white has planted there can be a bit of
a nuisance for black yeah it can be a
nuisance and black did ignore the
temptation to capture and shimanov
saying please capture my knight in the
center I'm putting her extra pressure
now on F6 if you allow me I will wreck
your Pawn structure by taking here next
move and uh now the question for Joel is
do you take I don't really see any other
attractive option you could potentially
drop back but this looks odd somehow it
looks really clumsy uh I think maybe now
it is time to take and Tanya you
mentioned this point a real kind of uh
Thorn for black but you can kind of play
around it maybe trade off all the
remaining Knights and well it does
indeed go back wow wow do it
commentators get strikes again night eat
on the Wall shoes Musa playing with fire
in
addition but it might be kicked away uh
with E7 E6 when you play that move of
course the D6 Pawn becomes a weakness
and that's a very common instance In the
Sicilian you made the move C3 David
that's probably I was gonna say that's
gonna be White's move no he's playing
Rook 81. I'm not able to predict a
single one of these moves I guess Bishop
takes B2 might be met with C3 then and
then the bishop will have a hard time
rejoining its side of the board that's
like a mouse trap you invite the bishop
with the cheese bait on B2 and then you
shut it down and that's not a position
that black wants feels like somehow
shimanov might still be in preparation I
know he streams a lot he plays a bunch
of different openings but what he does
play He tends to know extremely well and
okay no temptation to take this Pawn yet
he kicks the bishop away I'm expecting
the bishop to drop back
maybe the whole way back uh just to
defend this pawn and uh still the
problem for black is how to get your
knight back into the action after
retreating sometimes you've got to go
back in order to go forward in life but
here I really don't like it for moosad
wow where will he retreat with the
bishop will he stay aggressive keeping
it on that h4d diagonal with the bishop
coming back to H4 oh will he fall back
while the samurai knows when to retreat
you've moved that Rook from A1 to D1 so
Bishop C1 does make a lot of sense you
keep your eye out on that eight six Pawn
you also keep the B2 Pawn defended uh
right now shimanov is having a thing and
let's take this opportunity to go over
to our other game alireza ferrusha with
the white pieces against their final
rapid game it started as an Italian and
Hikaru Nakamura has managed to get D5 on
the board alirez asking is in the center
his head is in his hands D5 trades now
usually when black gets a successful D5
in you've solved all your opening
problems can hikar will be happy right
now
well yeah you're right when black d
plays D5 under the right circumstances
but that's the key word when black plays
it under the wrong circumstances he's
overextended for a variety of reasons
one of them is that the queen on D5 can
be easily targeted to move Bishop to B3
the F7 Pawn will then be under pressure
that Knight on G5 might have something
to say the queen from D1 could come into
H5 so hikara has to tread carefully here
Ali Raza avoiding a queen trade there
with Knight G5 take C4 looks pretty
steady for black though yeah it looks
steady and uh actually the momentum
could well turn if black does get a
couple of moves maybe Shuffle the black
king into the corner start throwing
pawns forward in the center kick away
White's beautiful Knight in the middle
of the board I think suddenly Nakamura
would be extremely happy so far as to be
accurate he has to be active and
energetic over the next few moves James
uh do you see anything for white here
absolutely you have to be accurate and
quick here I think we do need to maybe
uh figure out where to go with the King
but I'm definitely looking at I'm a big
fan of ideas and plans where do the
pieces go so I do like Bishop B3
castling and playing F4 just trying to
play quickly here and trying to get this
off be active right it definitely puts
some pressure there question the queen
where do you actually put it when I
attack it first off you got to figure
that out Queen D7 does block it and
farouza says Queen H5 aggressive
intentions I'm gonna push E5 and try to
go Knight F6 and flex real hard when I
do it E5 is definitely right here
exactly E5 is coming wow that's an
aggressive move from an aggressive
player I'm a fan of it wow it's very
brave I've got to say but if the attack
doesn't work out if if you're not able
to somehow crash through on this H7
Square then you might lose a few moves
you lose a lot of time actually
retreating your queen a bit later on and
I'm not sure what I would do here for
black I feel a bit scared
variations but Daniel whichever Pawn you
push you create weaknesses right if you
play G60 we can have six let me tell you
one thing Hikaru is not gonna do and
let's push the F on the newer players
might be attracted to the possibility of
F5 it looks like it wins the G2 Pawn but
no it opens up the A2 G8 diagonal we've
got a queen there you've got a king
there oh you're not gonna have a queen
there for much longer yeah big blunder
there and I'm wondering whether
therefore Black's two most tempting
moves would be to block that diagonal
either by shuffling the king into the
corner slightly safer potentially or
maybe bringing the bishop out just uh so
that later Bishop B3 comes with less
force and now James you want to mention
that pushing D4 might be an idea if uh
black takes big blunder nice check
and this would be Checkmate next move
wow but I guess this can now be blocked
by the move F5 and uh no more Bishop B3
because this is no longer a pin the
black queen can simply move it can
capture the White Knight wow so uh that
would be on my radar for black I don't
know if they're any safer
for Nakamura
yeah what's the uh let's Thrill of the
eval I'm just one of the the engine
suggestions just to see what we have
so what do we have what's the moves here
just to see okay Bishop B6 so Bishop B6
Pawn A5 just don't care about nothing
that one's crazy they're never gonna
happen 85 A5 bro A5 I'm done on the
commentary plays that move I think we're
a little retire yeah right now instead
we're going straight to the good night
though that's crazy I think if you give
this position to 100 people and ask them
to go for a move with Black 100 out of
100 will not pick A5 yeah you've got a
queen on H5 I'm that H7 Pawn there are
all these tactics with Knight F6 you
don't play A5 here but Ricardo his chest
is from another planet if there's anyone
who can make that move it might be him
but that's gonna be a big chakra Bishop
E6 just feels so much more natural here
yeah the two other moves of the top
three there suggested for black yeah I
think they're very natural just purely
because of that Bishop B3 idea you
mentioned Dania yeah no I mean A5 move
on the other side of the board just
ignoring all of the threats and
paradoxically that often is how we
Define a computer move right our human
instinct to react because the queen is
on H5 we got to do something about it
the engine just looks at it laughs ah
there's no threats okay well you can
like spin the loop a little bit inside I
don't know if the engine is a Russian
accent but if it did I think that's what
it would be saying David okay
stockfish
stock for sure the stock for sure great
Russian accent though I've got to say
but uh yeah right now
looks like Nakamura okay he's gone into
the tank and he does play that's the
best move yeah
that's a first right Carl finds the best
one oh wow
and uh meanwhile what is the follow-up
for for Asia he's played very committal
chess he's kind of given away the center
black now occupies most of the center of
the board if black gets the move F5
White's getting kicked back if there's
no checkmate
will your position be left in Ruins I
really fear for farouza here I've got to
say
um I'm not liking White's chances at all
let me just cast or just get out of the
way I mean well of course you have to do
this this is principles guys where do
you put your king you probably should
Castle it now but I do see you know some
ambition maybe bishop G5 maybe bishop E3
and maybe you know Castle Queen side as
ridiculous as that is because uh he's
not casting King there it is okay we got
it so it won't be any Castle queen size
so we have castling of the king now and
maybe we can push with F4 at some point
just try to continue with our aggressive
aggressive intentions especially with
the queen sitting on H5 like it is
yeah and now knuckleberry does he get
ambitious does he start throwing pawns
forward in the center you might have to
give up a uh the bishop here a bishop
for Knight in that uh scenario I guess
you could make an argument for just
centralizing one of the black Rooks you
don't have to go for it yet but uh it
would be too tempting for me I get itchy
fingers I'm thinking okay kick away that
white knight it looks too pretty in the
middle of the board
and uh okay looks like he's ready to
move there we go why wait why hesitate
looks very sensible here and I actually
wouldn't play Bishop B3 now because
after Queen D7 the trade of light
squared Bishops at least to my untrained
eyes it favors black because the D3 Pawn
is then going to be weaker and the
bishop on C2 is easy to write off but as
we've already seen in some lines white
can play a timely D3 D4 and open up that
diagonal and as the very unknown chess
expression goes the threat is stronger
than its execution so keeping that
Bishop in your pocket on C2 is the right
way to go that's exactly what verucia
does he gets the bishop pair but black
gets uh nice control over the center and
still a weak D3 Pawn that white will
have to deal with for a while yeah long
term this bishop is going to be tied
down and the first thing that crossed my
mind was okay let's try and push this
Pawn forward go for the attack maybe
even trap this bishop but uh just to
show Danny's Point as well now suddenly
D4 would come with a lot of force you'll
be glad you cut this bishop on the board
because uh suddenly again White's attack
will be Unleashed so I don't think black
can get too tempted to push pawns yet
you kind of have to consolidate first
bring your pieces uh to better squares
before you initiate any further action
white has the bishop pair but the
Bishops aren't too impressive right now
and Nakamura does indeed centralize this
Rook sensible logical play by both sides
so far yeah really nice simple move Rook
to you just bringing all the toys to the
nursery he has got these ideas of
advancing those Central pawns down the
board but doesn't Rush with them and it
just feels that the big Trump in White's
position of the bishop bear is countered
by the peace activity that we see with
black hair the Rooks are centralized the
queen is centralized the A2 Pawn is
under Fire white can't really continue
bringing his own Rook from A1 to E1 so
alireza brings the other Rook to the
open e-file
reacts preemptively by retreating his
Queen now there'll never be a hit with
gain on a gain of time by white bishop
and I've got to ask you guys Bishop pair
or Bishop Knight what are you picking
here this repair definitely Bishop here
I mean this this actually feels more
Armageddon like if I'm going to be
honestly very Armageddon like because uh
I can't have the break I mean my Bishop
on C2 doesn't look that good either as
well so I mean okay we can't make we can
make moves here but it is quite
difficult to really make some real
chances against the black king I like
Black's position I mean the bishop pair
is a long-term trump card as Tanya
mentioned but Hikaru doing a good job
just biting his time and uh you know
those King side bonds are pretty
intimidating F4 could come at an
unpleasant moment and that Bishop on G5
would be cut off for now as you
mentioned David there is D3 D4 in
response and the player's kind of
slowing down right the smoke has cleared
alireza expanding on the queen side very
common idea in the newer treatment of
the Italian to play A4 B4 and once the
Knight on C6 is kicked away the E5 Pawn
turns from a strength into a weakness so
very strategically complex situation
here love it yeah really really tense
and
I don't know who to pick I've got to say
normally I'm 100 biased towards the
bishop here this might be one of the
rare exceptions however just because
black sports Pawn Center is so strong
and it still takes two or three moves to
kick away that black knight from its
nice perch
yeah I have a feeling somehow that an
attack against the white king might be
incoming black and Planet Bishop in the
center of the board somehow it just
feels like white is lacking Pawn breaks
lacking activity lacking energy in his
position and I'm not sure will be
comfortable I would be in time trouble
with uh White here over the next two
three moves for sure as I try to uh find
a productive idea meanwhile Nakamura
first to move
but that might exactly be what Hikaru
needs to do he needs to start building
that pressure on the king side because
for alireza right with that last move A4
he's hinting at a queen side takeover
that A4 Pawn could go to A5 fix the
structure we could see a piece landing
on A4 either the bishop or The Rook
putting pressure on that diagonal the
other idea the B Pawn can March down the
board asking questions to that Knight
which is a key Defender to that E5
Central Pawn currently attacked by The
Rook on E1 hikaru's position looks super
pleasant but it feels like he doesn't
have all the time in the world to just
sit
absolutely not you can't just sit around
here you do have to do something maybe
G6 as weaken some squares but it does
kick the queen away I mean maybe you can
go Queen H4 there then try to push F4
maybe trap the bishop in there weirdly
enough black does have some weird tricks
here A4 and B4 like farouza is doing is
actually the usual stuff you would do
here in an Italian game anyway I also
see maybe White playing an F4 in the
future somehow just to try to create
some chances here bring the a rook to D1
you couldn't do that before there was a
bishop A2 but you could trap the bishop
Bobby Fischer style B3 right um but Rook
a to D1 D4 F4 still chances for both
sides here it really depends on where he
goes next here and and me meaning uh
Hikaru I wonder what he's going to play
what do you think David G6 H6 King h8
like what do you do like a good question
if I'm gonna touch one of these two
pawns I would rather maybe touch the H
Pawn uh just to kick away this bishop
actually oh I'm a bit gutted there
because I was gonna say the other moves
that struck out to me was playing A5 it
was saying push those pawns for white
the only way to stop that was to clamp
down I was gonna say either H6 or A5 one
of the two Corner pawns and that's what
Nakamura does now no further advance for
white on that uh flank and therefore we
see a bit more maneuvering and White
Queen about to get kicked back so nice
centralization for white but still not
clear what to do next for either side
and
okay Queen H4 that's uh feels like the
White Queen might get trapped or the
white dark Square Bishop might get
trapped in some positions but nothing
yet still very very tense this position
something's going to happen and those
are very deep words but the situation is
not it's calm but it's the Calm before
the storm in the moment white plays D4
or F4 or black plays F4 all bets are off
the tactics are on and you want to give
yourself enough time to process those
complications for arugia doing somewhat
better job with his clock management but
both players accelerating their pace and
Rook to E6 yukaro not messing about that
Rook wants to move to G6 a bishop from
F7 can hop into D5 and so suddenly we
didn't think that the center of action
would be would be the G2 Pawn but it
very well might be yeah uh you said the
car before the storm something's coming
something's brewing and Rook G6 Bishop
D5 Dania yeah if white does nothing here
I'm not sure how you do nothing let's
say uh moves to the king then suddenly
yeah this is gonna be disaster time for
white
suddenly big big weakness well it
doesn't have too many Defenders around
and okay again preemptively look at how
the players are just reacting to threats
before they even exist white drops his
Bishop back and now the Rook slide
what's the plan to meet that one that's
a strong move there that's very strong I
think it's somehow you have to break
with D4 at some point you have to get
this D4 in open up this bishop your
pieces need to be active of course the
only thing you do have is like The Rook
on A1 the bishop on C1 D4 does come with
some activity right after Pawn takes it
weird maybe not take it back immediately
you can maybe make a waiting move I
don't know where yeah but Bishop D5 is
coming too as well so you have to do
something or like you mentioned I mean
Black's just gonna steamroll you here
after putting the bishop in the center
of the board as Donya mentioned here and
G2 is loose yeah looking very good for
black I wouldn't be surprised if
Nakamura plays uh that Rook swing that
Rook lift uh initiated already and okay
first he does maybe fight against your
idea James just trying to control the
center reacting in advance to White
opening things up there yeah it
definitely I can feel the tingles
something is about to happen and uh it
feels like it might be in Black's favor
definitely Hikaru does give that feeling
that something is always about to happen
on the board he does double up on the
e-line before bringing that other Rook
into the attack might be a moment for
white to start considering a potential
trade of the light Squad Bishop Bishop
to B3 you want to try and get rid of
that Bishop on F7 but a black screen can
also land on D5 lots of targets on the
king side the central pawns as well big
decision big moment for alireza here but
it's not only a big moment in division
one we are also getting an update from
our one and only
Simon Williams with us that big things
are happening in the other divisions as
well
yeah there's lots of stuff going on
Tanya I don't want to take too much time
away from this big encounter but both
division three and division two are
heating up we've got losers brackets
going on there so people are getting
knocked out left or right and center and
I'm just going to pick two players from
division three that you might not be
aware of and there was a great result by
the youngster Dennis lazovic who was
born in 2006 so he's definitely a chess
kid and it's a bit sickening really sort
of makes me a little bit depressed how
good these youngsters are and how many
of them are but he actually beat velie
Echo pons
um in the winners bracket so he's won
every match so far and Valley Echo was
one of ding's favorite ever players as
we mentioned yesterday so a great result
for Dennis there and um if we go to
division two against some really big
names there but I'm going to pick two
players
um which are of big interest and we've
got another youngster ranook sadwani of
India who we mentioned yesterday is
apparently won all against Alec senko
and Alex senko played in the candidates
um a while back so he's a very very good
player so that's a really tense matcher
again in the winners bracket but we're
trying to update this more a bit later
on and uh yeah I think things are really
heating up in this big Encounter of the
day
um and who are you guys rooting for by
the way am I allowed to am I allowed to
ask that question no no but I just did I
just did surely yeah okay see you later
guys yeah so well that's a great
question so I don't know who we're
rooting for but it does look like
looking at this position that Echo
Nakamura is in driver's seat right now
he has managed to create play looking at
that King side attack I have to ask you
objectively do you agree that Hikaru
might be pushing this one
yeah it seems like a very tense moment
at the at this exact point
um I think they both got opportunities
there I quite like when I'm playing
having more space and we can see that
black has more space he has more pawns
Advanced up the board it's a bit easier
to play when you have that space Vantage
but on the other hand and he raises
Bishops they they have a lot of
potential so I think it's it's any
moment now it's just gonna fire up and
come to life so it's uh it's very tense
that's for sure but I might even go
Armageddon I kind of want to see an
armaged in between yeah Legends of the
game so it's going to be interesting
that would be a lot of fun to watch
doesn't have the best memories from the
Armageddon yesterday but before that he
needs to keep things under control in
this one thank you so much I'm in for
those updates I'm mentioning the big
youngsters playing it's kind of hard to
call them talents and prodigies anymore
they're sort of like the established
Grand Masters now I've caught myself
referring to certain players as
prodigies and then I look them up on
Wikipedia and they're like 25 years old
they because like Sam sebian for example
is 21 or 22 but I somehow always think
of them as 12 year old GMS so I don't
know what that says about me uh farusha
is going to fall into that category
pretty soon he's an established GM by
now exactly these are the world's best
players with all the potential to be in
the absolute Elite in a couple of years
ronix advani uh the player with the best
chess tattoo in the world James yeah as
Simon was mentioning it's just 17 years
old James isn't very happy about that
yeah of course I mean hey look don't do
that at home of course it is 17 is a
little young there I was at 15 with my
first one okay but let's not tell anyone
that so uh at the same time the Roanoke
is a very cool cool guy from India and
uh going to come up as very strong
player as we all know so shout out to
ronak sodwani
and Simon will keep us updated with all
the action but action is here as well we
see some pawn moves now I have to say
the the last two moves that we saw by
alireza and Hikaru that little Pawn 286
and the little Pawn to F3 it just feels
like not the most direct approach for
the attack other players switching it up
to a more positional feel in the
position it definitely looks that way
and I do actually well I don't approve
of what Nakamura is doing I do like what
faruga has been doing meanwhile because
when you have the bishop pair the longer
the game goes on the more effective they
become and just the fact that Nakamura
didn't take the opportunity to pounce
didn't go for the attack does make me
fear for his chances conventional wisdom
says if you're facing the bishop pair
accelerate the play and he's slowed
things down Nakamura now it does feel
like ferrugia given the opportunity will
open things up and his Bishops will come
to life and he's got so many ways to do
it F4 and D4 both have to be calculated
Bishop C2 to B3 may seem to win the E5
Pawn but ikaro can respond with Knight
to G6 hitting the queen and
re-establishing Bishops big mistake but
it was not because of Queen B6 I
apologize yes so even better than the
Knight G6 good catch David it's Queen B6
check totally could see someone making
that I mean I just made that mistake
um and I'm not ashamed to admit it so I
think he's probably focused on D4 or F4
if he plays Bishop B3 I take
responsibility for it commentator's
curse that'll be another level that
would be crazy yeah but one of these two
moves
crazy which one is it yeah it's D4 or F4
the question is which one we do have
well look at the time here okay well
it's only a minute not bad D4 or F4 and
you got to make a move fast if I had to
pick one I would just go with D4 it does
open up both the Bishops principle
very logical you're trying to open up
the Rooks on this file you're trying to
open up these two Bishops on these
diagonals what could be uh more logical
than that but okay he goes for the other
one also looks good for white so it also
looks very very tempting and now I do
expect uh Nakamura to continue his plan
he did reroute the Knight so why not
continue its Journey this would attack
the queen attack this Pawn temporarily
and the game goes on but still very
tense very complicated stuff
this position it's really interesting
how he played F3 and then went F4 uh he
kind of it looks like just gave a move
to the opponent and now Hikaru with
Knight G6 hitting that queen and the
pawn and this was the whole idea
otherwise you just end up losing that
pawn on F4 you want to trade on E5 hit
that Queen on D6 and I'll be expecting a
queen trade here Knight H4 take on D6 we
should look is hanging on you too yeah
we should mention a very cool variation
right now if black does get tempted to
be materialistic here take the queen and
then suddenly take the white Rook then
this will backfire yes you win a rook
for black but at the very end the thing
in the tail the pawn will promote on d8
next move and I think the best bet here
would be to retreat your Rook the whole
way back give it up just for the white
Pawn so yeah Queen incoming really
tactical oh tactically aware that from
farrugia what a trick a whole
resourceful that is incredible that's
super pretty it's a rook sacrifice but
hikaru's got to see that he definitely
spotted that he can't pick up that Rook
for free but even after the queen trade
he can pick up the D6 Pawn would that be
something that he's hoping for right now
or is he just going to keep the Queens
on the board right can't pick up the
Jews so bash and the promise
pawnstration kick queen size can run
it's gonna be some weak juicers on Queen
side particularly A5 White's going to
use his Pony's rotated to B6 I
don't think he's gonna take on H4 I
think he's deciding between Rook takes
E5 and Knight takes H4 there's a scary
looking check on B6 here but white can
block it with his Queen so no alireza
didn't blunder his Queen you see the
evil bar shooting up there so first time
I missed Queen B6 now when I see it it's
a bad move uh I think he might play
Knight takes C5 but again the clock is
on 90 seconds that's kind of what
happened in the previous game so he's
trying to keep it more simple with a
potential exchange of the heavy pieces
yep simple chess however remember that
Bishop pair if the Queen's come off if
the Rooks come off as well white will
have a big Advantage due to the power of
His Bishop so Nakamura is banking on
this last move Pawn to C5 he's trying to
prevent white from stepping forward in
the center white light squared Bishop
still unable to really open up right now
so I'm going to take white here every
time I've got to say but Nakamura still
has the Queens on and if the Knight gets
uh gets into the position still with no
time on the clock it could be tricky for
white Nakamura shaking his head now is
it time for Ali Raza to go for D4 in the
Santa open up that that other Bishop he
starts with Bishop E3 he's putting
pressure on C5 you defended D4 coming up
E6 D4 bike might have to play F4 but
then he loses a pawn I think hikara
might have underestimated the D4 Pawn
break and then he's under Fire on both
sides of the board F5 and B6 if he plays
that move he's in trouble here after D4
I think yeah on the board on the board
instantly and Black's position is
riddled with weaknesses if you look all
over the board Black's pawns are easy
targets for White's Bishops Nakamura in
huge trouble and we do see the
evaluation bar inching up every single
move in White's favor alireza playing
some great chess over the last few moves
things have turned Nakamura it really
needs to pull the brakes here he needs
to find a way to escape by any cost
looks like he's losing a pawn as you
said Daniel in uh in every position here
yeah it's very important what you said
earlier David as the game goes on the
bishop here is something you look
forward to and in fact a lot of times
Bishop Perry says in Advantage even
sometimes at the cost of a pawn being
down upon sometimes you can have Bishops
but as the Bishops you know as the game
opens up most games do 2 as the games
goes on you trade you make some trains
Pawn trades pawns come off the board
then you start to see the Bishops open
up as you see in this position I mean
classic you know a classic right
triangle and see Carl says with the
Bishops here as the Bishops just opened
up because more moves happen trades
happen and now you see the Bishops
working here they carry in a little bit
of trouble and more than a little bit of
trouble however I like his last move
Nakamura jumping forward with the Knight
he's trying to set up some tricks and oh
alarm Bell's ringing here Daniel Bishop
D5 I mean I I was looking and trying to
figure out a response to Bishop D5 which
targets the G2 pawn and if that pawn
disappears then all hell breaks loose on
the king said alireza must have
something prepared here I was having a
hard time finding a move dang
other ways to keep control suddenly it's
chaos again and that suits Nakamura
although he's reacting yeah but he again
he's reacting to the way the game is
gone he will do that even if he wins
White's Queen right what are they doing
I had a winning like 17 rules if Bishop
takes up five but man that's terrifying
maybe Queen C5 terrifying with one
minute on your clock for both sides here
uh what is next for alireza that white
king coming under Fire Black's Queen
threatening to come over to G6 plenty of
threats here potentially the car was
going to be smelling the blood right now
he is down to 45 seconds with big
threats on Oliver's King you want to
pick up the F5 Pawn but you can't afford
losing the G2 Pawn because then the H3
Pawn hangs as well coming in with a fork
this is a moment that forces alireza to
go into a thing to burn the clock but he
doesn't have that much time he's now
down to less than a minute how does he
keep things under control on the king's
side that's the thing and he struggled
with this yesterday in time pressure he
made a lot of tactical errors Bishop C5
on the board I like that move Queen G6
there's King H2 just cold-bloodedly
hiding the king in the corner so buckle
your seat belts both sides under a
minute now and Hikaru leans in to try to
figure out the way to maximize this King
side attack after Queen G6 the one thing
you shouldn't do is pick up that Knight
watch out for the tender spot on G2
we've seen Maiden ones happen before
yeah Ali resin is all about that yeah
just to show a quick takes tonight don't
do it Queen takes would be Checkmate and
uh we won't see lightning strike twice
firstly because now Nakamura didn't
switch his Queen he actually went
backwards hitting this Pawn from a
different angle this one is pure chaos
Bishops against uh the Bushman Knight
combo here black going for the kill
though wow look at that white king
totally open in a classical game white
still with the advantage but this is
chaos and it's bullet chess now Daniel
we need uh we need some advice what
should white be aiming to do queen E3
was obviously trade the Queens if you
can black maybe bishop C5 back to D4 try
to create counter threats against
Black's King but Black's threatening
Queen B8 takes B2 there's so many
Avenues and angles and streets that you
have to keep closed for Rouge now with
25 seconds oh my God it's so hard not to
panic here Tanya it's insane how that
Knight defends the E6 check the Bishops
on C6 defends the EA check everything
under control which forced alireza to
defend that B2 Pawn he goes down at the
board with B4 the players are playing on
seconds anyone can get checkmated in
this position but it just looks like the
bishop chips are so much stronger right
now black screen it has to find a way to
the king side
it really does meanwhile black has at
least established material equality
winning a pawn back on the edge of the
board but Black's piece is temporarily
Queen D4 is it coordinated King F2 I
would play oh yes big threat on the
board and okay he spots it double attack
Black's Queen jumps in though with some
nasty checks where's the Black Knight
retreating to no checks right now for
black unless you trade the Queens then
the knight's still in trouble and black
could easily lose
I guess he's not made it I think the
bishop takes up four he's bluffing here
Nakamura Bishop takes up and you run oh
and you take it
wait but if he takes it the H Pawn is
the wrong Corner color so white still
has to demonstrate some technique here
gotta be really careful do you step
forward with the white king do you go
for checkmate wow three so I wouldn't do
it you know we take those and keep it
moving
Queen's gonna come off this is going to
be an end game it's winning for white
but you have to be a bit careful
seven seconds six he needs to make a
move
the car was so angry at himself right
now he does run with the King can't
obviously do it he's got 13 seconds on
the clock okay one thing to avoid you
mentioned Daniel do not ever push your
Pawn forward on the B file and allow the
black Bishop to sacrifice itself for it
allow the bishop to sacrifice for this
one
this one should be winning now Bishop B6
check
Bishop E6 check and King F6 ends the
game and it's the game Bishop E6 is over
King F6 Bishop D3 Bishop F5
God that is basic tactics there alirez
is still completely winning I think just
matches with the King on the other side
now but you still have to push that beep
on without giving it away the bishop
will block but it's it's still some
technique to show a lot enough technique
to show yep he knows he's losing but
still white needs to prove it
wins in the losers bracket
that's crazy look at the man himself
breathe just he can relax now he's
taking down the Goliath
what a match that was but we have to say
that alireza ferrusha today from the
start was the better player David yep he
was the better player Nakamura just not
at his best today and uh yeah ferocia
takes the result what a way to end
though on a mouse slip uh dramatic game
won a game and uh Meanwhile we're left
with more action today and this is just
in the losers bracket uh still plenty
more chess meanwhile this one what is
the material count it's two Rooks for a
queen and pawn level material but
shimanov with white needs to win
what do we think any chances here I
think I would take the queen if anything
the white Rooks aren't coordinated
aren't connected right now
putting an attack on the C1 Rook also
I'm the D4 Rook there Alexander shimanov
has to win this game to force the
playoff otherwise it will be the end of
the road for him I love that Knight on
D5 just plants itself there and
dominating those two Rooks not allowing
them to penetrate to the other side yeah
the Black Knight is a rock and meanwhile
white forced to retreat both sides
around 10 seconds so shimanov has a
chance if he keeps his nerve uh black
well black here going for the white a
pawn however if that pawn drops off the
board looks like safety for June yeah
this is too many pawns there's too much
I mean usually you'll take the two Rooks
in the night usually but I mean it's
just too much you also have to deal with
the pass a pawn now the Knight is
cemented there on D5 the roads are
actually passive so all we're doing is
really yeah Shuffle every day I'm
shuffling just moving them boys back and
forth trying to figure this out it's
also a very low on time for both these
guys here and uh he was bullying his
opponent with the thought of a
repetition because he has draw odds here
a draw be enough to get black through to
the next round and yeah you can just
keep dancing around with the queen
enjoys enough yeah
now there's only one weak spot one
tender point in the black position
that's the F7 Pawn next to the black
king so as long as you don't allow one
of the Rooks up to the seventh rank
you're safe and I think jewel is very
aware of that now the black queen
threatening to slide across with a nasty
check
white is the one on the defensive here
if anything last try he's gonna go rugby
two I think but the queen can slide back
to E7 and defend the b7's ground or
normal circumstances you'll be playing
this for a win he is playing it for a
win but obviously he'll take a
repetition if it presents itself okay
these are just one move threats by
shimanov and oh Queen B7 that pawn gonna
go further
yeah walking into a pin there White's
night retreating but really
uncomfortable on the diagonal Black's
Queen peering down and oh there's a nice
night Fork bang game over hit the button
double attack and that wasn't sure
[Music]
Knight C3 he just
hasn't thrown in the travel yet but it
looks like it's absolutely busted now he
loses more material Jewels moves out
will be advancing in the loser's bracket
and the end of the road for shimanov
yeah heartbreaking result it turned into
just the just the space of a couple of
moves in the first game and the second
game shimanov he had to gamble he had to
risk and uh we have to admire what he
tried but nerves of Steel from the
Frenchman
what an action-packed elimination
bracket that was few would have
predicted to be knocked out on day two
he has been on fire the entire tour
finishing Runners up at the Athens
Masters winning in Grand style at the
chessable Masters this one was a
disaster for him it was alireza ferrugia
well number four Super Genius who took
him down Oliver show is also back from a
great a second place finish at the
Romania uh branches store so he's
definitely feeling informed and
spectacular action in that game David so
many big moments so many big moments and
I just want to highlight the one moment
it slipped away for Nakamura the one
moment that cost him his place in the
chess kid cup and it was here he bluffed
it was already difficult for black the
white Bishops dominating the board but
he bluffed by retreating his Bishop
going for a check but it turned out that
the white king could simply run the
Knight was captured and this king walk
was decisive off after this check
perhaps what lakamura had missed was
that white could simply return the piece
give up the bishop and transpose into
this end game and uh we saw the final
heartbreaking move in a few moves time
from Nakamura retreating his Bishop
maybe a mouse lip maybe just having
given up psychologically here but uh if
he had retreated his Bishop the key idea
for white would be to step back
intercept and walk the pawn forward to
Victory great game by farusha but
heartbreak for Nakamura
some great technique there and that
means before we head over to our winners
bracket this is our score line Ali Reza
Fairuza he advances through in the chess
kitkov it is the end of the road for
Hikaru nakamuran Jules musad he takes
down Alexander shimanov makes his way
into day three of the chess kid cup but
of course we have to talk about alireza
faruja's great performance in that match
against Hikaru and we've got alireza he
is
joining us there from Paris alireza
congratulations
great game today it was a lot of fun to
watch tremendous match I have to ask you
against Hikaru he is such a beast of an
opponent in this format how did you do
it today
um yeah of course we are both
disappointed from yesterday and
expected between the winner Brandon but
yeah Dimitri played a lot of brilliant
from yesterday and uh I didn't have so
much chances I mean
um
and for for today I'm happy that
he probably didn't play his best and I
had chances if I use my chances so but
of course he caught up a lot of his best
all right so you mentioned that
yesterday was a very difficult day and
it didn't end well for you what did you
do to switch it up and get ready for
this big game
um not much because I don't expect
myself more money to get anywhere in
online tournaments because I never asked
even quarters and I think for the first
time that I won a match in Knockouts I
think in this series
so um it's a bit weird statistical
and yeah I'm happy today that I won but
I don't expect so much
that's uh that's interesting to hear you
guys have a kiss for us we've seen you
in those bullet speeches and you're
always so strong that you mentioned that
it's been a bit of a struggle with
online chess why is that the case
I don't know
it's all the FM's entitled Tuesday
they're unbeatable
are you having fun so far well today was
a great day
[Music]
yesterday was so tense so but today I'm
happy that they have but it was a bit
more calm and a great good chess and it
was good practice I think
and finally I want to ask you just one
more question before we let you go I'll
realize that today's match could have
gone either way both games were so
double edged what was your feeling while
you were playing it
there was not so much
pressure on me because I expected like I
just wanted to play good chess so at the
end it was trying to make good moves and
practice for the future tournaments and
um so it I was trying to be more common
it's it's a
it's not easy to play music or under
this pressure because I saw him in the
camera that was yeah he was more nervous
than me so that always
you mentioned that you saw him on the
camera do his Expressions ever impact
you is that something that you think
about while playing
a lot of things wrong because
she shows a lot I think so
um but sometimes he likes to do it to
treat people also stuff and what other
ways
um in general I like to look at him
because it's funny so
[Laughter]
thank you so much for sharing your
thoughts always and it's a pleasure to
have you and all the best for tomorrow
thank you
taking down one of the absolute bests in
the world is out of the Chaska or you
got big action coming up but first we're
gonna take a quick shot twitch break
[Music]
chess kid is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
at Magnus Academy we've taught chess to
a hundred thousand kids with Summer
around the corner we're gearing up for
camps
at online chess camps kids learn about
Chess in a safe fun environment from a
team of All-Star coaches
kids are grouped by skill level from
beginners up to national champions there
are never more than eight kids per coach
so every child gets plenty of attention
you might even get the chance to meet
Magnus and ask him a question or
challenge him to a game
each week has a different theme like
opening traps learning from your losses
or Magnus Carlson's best games
sign up by May 31st to get a 30 discount
join the 100
000 Kids and Counting that have learned
chess with Magnus chess Academy
[Music]
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only game
changing Innovations from the heroes we
admire to the joy of watching them play
our history defines us inspires us and
pushes us into the future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
the action continues of the Chaska cup
as we will be kicking off day two of the
Winner's bracket but before that we've
got Simon Williams back with us Simon
that was a dramatic round alireza taking
down Hikaru
it's massive wasn't it I mean all the
Hikari fans around the world they're
they're crying a little tear at the
moment and it was a really big encounter
I mean either I'm on their day uh could
be world champions even so massive
result for Andy razor there it's such a
big dream for these players to play in
division one and one of the ways to get
there Simon is to win division two and
we've got some big encounters going on
there as well that's right there's loads
of great players in division two and it
is a dream to get into division one
because uh that's the proper division
that's the high division where you can
make yourself a legend and um I think we
should take a look at what's been going
on in in those divisions so here we'll
start with uh the winners side of
division two and uh anyone who's been
winning this match isn't a great
situation and uh you can see some rather
shocking results I mean Liam Lee losing
there I mean he he was X Blitz World
Champion he's losing to his fellow
countrymen so that was that was really
quite a quite a result David Anton's
still fighting against Vladimir feducev
and the young Indian player that's a
fantastic result because kiril alexenko
is is a star and sad wani winning that
is is a brilliant result
the losers bracket who is going home
well Mama Jara stays in the competition
by beating creative and uh you can see
Dimitri Adrian another big name has also
stayed in the competition as well and uh
yeah it's getting very tense there
already so so I mean it's such a
grueling format and we see all these big
upsets and these results as you've been
pointing out what do you think is the
reason that we often see the favorites
kind of being knocked down
I think everyone's just so strong
nowadays
um everyone has the potential to win um
is quite a quick and exciting format so
uh Anything Can Happen really it's just
unpredictable and that's what makes it
great to commentate on really and to
watch so we love the unpredictability
and one player who is quite
unpredictable with his style is the
Indian Grandmaster he's just 17 years
old he has been making news well for his
chess but also for this super cool
tattoo I've got to ask you James what do
you think about that one oh that boy
fire I understand that's sick man look
at him I have to talk to him Young fella
that's actually really nice work from
that
that's a nice tattoo but he's 17 years
old what's his mom got to say about that
I mean
he's got a 12.
I mean with a tattooed like that you
should at least have some like scars or
something yeah if it's a chest tattoo
then it's allowed okay I guess so those
are the rules if you're 17 the only dad
is that a lot is the Knight and the King
on the Now who is the king in division
three because we are seeing some big
results come in we are so let's have a
quick look at division three and again
there's lots of action going on
um Harry Krishna in the winners uh
quarterfinals has impressed me the most
uh but also uh we we did say this young
player Dennis lazovic has been playing
so well to put a valley echo down the
division Alan pitcho also impressing Sam
Seville and I thought would win that one
uh but all these guys who've won that
match are in a great situation at the
moment all chances to go through uh to
the next stage Benjamin box stays in in
the losers section so does the legend
the one and only Legend
gatzikanski a veteran of the game and in
the all German Clash we see uh Vincent
Kmart go home another Prodigy and uh and
another rather disappointing result was
orientari there the only Norwegian we
want bit Norwegian love here in Norway
he goes home as well but David Navara
the sweetest guy he stays in the
competition and that will put a a smile
on a lot of people's faces
wow thank you so much for that Simon and
we will keep our eyes out on the other
two divisions as well and keep getting
some spicy updates from Ginger GM that's
a big spicy news for now at the cheske
cup has been the elimination of the guy
Nakamura what a performance there by
alireza and after what happened on day
one David that's got to be a huge
confidence boost yeah a huge confidence
boost I backed him to step his game up a
level and he really did alarisa farusha
today I'm still reeling actually it's a
bit of a shock and disappointment that
Nakamura has to leave us but uh what a
clash it was what a match James we're
just not used to seeing this happen not
at all I mean he Carriage is off two
days in a row I mean what like is the
sky really blue or like what is really
going on here but of course it is Rouge
if anybody can do it's definitely
Perugia and now for Russia is definitely
a huge favorite to go all the way
especially if we have to see what Fabi
does but I mean farouzia fans are raving
right now
and this is such a big game two Heavy
Hitters it is a clash of generations
saviano caruana will be taking on the 18
year old not the back of the Saturday
before this starts again guys round of
predictions what happens in this one I'm
gonna start with Daniel
um I hate making predictions because
they're so close in strength I'm gonna
have to go with Fabby for this one oh
Fabby what do you think James I gotta go
Fabio on this one too as well I think
the experience there the preparation I
mean he's played Magnus in a world
championship classical games made it all
the way through lost in the rapid
portion definitely looking for problem
and we are seeing a reverse Broomfield
David what do you think yeah
yeah I love Fabi but you guys have
forced me to say I'll do Satora Fitness
one and uh yeah reverse grunfeld so far
it feels like fabby's trying to move
order uh I'll do sator of here he's
trying some of that uh old trickery he
knows his openings inside out but is it
fair to say David that you're giving the
nodder back to abdisator
[Music]
definitely giving him the node they're
back yeah
and uh oh he's happy to transpose now
into a Catalan opening we talked earlier
about how the French can transpose into
a sicilian as we saw in that game
between uh Nakamura and ferrugia now
this started as a kind of offbeat queen
phone opening now it's going into the
Catalan
yeah interesting start to the opening I
didn't predict this from Fabi I thought
he'd be a bit more direct against his
younger rival me too actually it's
usually E4 I mean just go with your gun
to go to what you like the best here but
I think he just want to mix it up a
little bit which is totally
understandable I'm sure probably not a
break was prepping you for so he's like
oh let's play something different take
him out of his uh his comfort zone here
takes a3b4 looks good C4 also common
here you can many ways to play this
position you can play it not
theoretically he decides to transition
things back into sort of a Catalan
semi-tourage-esque structure some big
decisions on this one in the center
we'll see what the players decide but
now it's also action and the other
matchup as Jordan van Forest takes on
Dimitri collage this is a big one these
two players scored big upsets on day one
and today they face each other it's
going to be a fun one what are we
expecting from Jordan run Forrest run
yeah we need more great opening
preparation one D4 even though Jordan
also by Nature as an E4 player but man
Tanya Jordan versus Dimitri and then we
had Hikaru versus alireza this is the
winners bracket that was the losers
bracket mind-blowing stuff here at the
cheskid cup and uh this opening not
particularly mind-blowing a slav that's
pretty standard fare Queen C2 variation
has been sidelined but well known for
many years now yeah well known for many
years and it does have a more kind of
positional nature at least a reputation
uh Queen C2 it basically takes the game
into the middle game white has a little
bit more space if you look at the
Central Pawn structure white is the one
who can pull the trigger at any time
white is the one who holds the key to
opening up the position but Black Rock
Solid meanwhile and I've got to say if I
were Dimitri call out here I would be
extremely surprised that I would also be
relieved because Jordan he does have
this reputation for attacking and it's
not one of those types of positions so
far just interestingly I noticed that
Anish giri one of Jordan's good friends
who had this exact position himself
earlier today in a different tournament
and now it's appeared on the board here
so uh yeah maybe some Synergy there
maybe some work done on this exact
opening James who uh who are you picking
in this class yeah I actually like the
fact that white can be very flexible
here you can still go aggressive I mean
we saw a weird Catalan yesterday from
farucha accident we saw today even if
you're watching Sharjah Masters there's
a weird Catalan just thing going on with
Bishop G2 and playing H4 that we saw
yesterday and even casting queen size so
that possibility is still here too as
well I mean you see with the neural net
Network engines now and Alpha zeros H4
H5 right especially when you see a fin
Kettle Bishop here it's very nice you
have lots of ideas you can also go to
classical route Knight C3 Bishop D2
Castle Knight C3 B3 Castle right so lots
of options I like to have flexibility
and options black here also has not as
many going with C6 and D5 you are forced
to time to try to play certain ways of
doing things where does your Bishop go
you can cattle it or do you go Bishop F5
that's something you have to worry about
as well yeah Jordan didn't get the memo
though that he needs to open a window
air quality oh carbon dioxide levels
very high in that room yeah I think it's
grown from yesterday and then 75 degrees
Fahrenheit that's I mean I like it warm
but I don't go above like 73.
yeah sorry David 24. I forgot where I am
for a second yes thank you Europeans wow
and uh talking of getting hot this
position is splicing up C5 whoa already
moving the seaport for the second time
in this game losing a Tempo Dimitri
colors very direct play and look at this
pawns capturing all over the place uh
not a position I've seen I've got to
admit at this early stage
seven only E4 after this I like this for
I mean this is definitely a girl you
know what I'm saying E4 anyway like this
is up to Jordan's alley here he took on
D4 but I thought E4 was definitely
something spicy we keep D4 kind of uh
loose there but okay right he takes here
and we takes we have sort of just equal
position I think what's what's
attracting Jordan is the prospect of
castling and quickly putting a rook on
D1 now Queen d8 takes D5 is inadvisable
because of a small positional detail
Bishop on C it would hang and wow I'm
not able to predict a single one of
these moves he castles King side first
maybe so that he can take on D5 of the
queen no never mind and there we go Rook
D1 and suddenly the Knight on D5 Andre a
good deal of pressure particularly David
if this Knight moves away from D4 E4
will be threatened wax gotta keep an eye
on the bishop on C8 some logistical
problems here for black but maybe Queen
B6 solves a lot of them yeah I like it
uh just getting the queen out of the way
you never want to be feeling
uncomfortable with your queen set down
by a rook uh anytime so get the queen
out the way looks a bit loose this Black
Knight hanging in the air undefended
right now but you can always move it out
the way with Tempo uh and hit the White
Queen gaining time to retreat it a bit
later on so I think Dimitri has this all
under control he does indeed play Queen
B6
and either this is opening Theory or
it's very impressive play from Dimitri
colors so far I'm not sure what to
expect here from Jordan but if he can't
generate anything in the next few moves
watch out for black actually taking over
the advantage because this bishop this
uh kind of Silent Assassin from afar and
Archer is peering down this diagonal
very strong play and it's actually a
reversed Catalan pretty much this type
of opening so Jordan needs some action
here and now wow will he be able to do
that well one thing's for sure he has
played with confidence and speed and he
continues to do that he's about 14
minutes on the clock so there has been
an impressive amount of time usage there
but for Dimitri colas yesterday when we
had him on the show he mentioned that he
wasn't even sure about getting through
to the second round in the Winner's
bracket it was a big upset that he
scored against alireza ferruja but
confidence is key and Dimitri's got to
find that at some point because in these
formats it's so much about the inner
game he's got to feel that he belongs
long zero with the very best well first
of all I hope you canceled his
appointment from yesterday where
whatever his engagement was uh but you
know he's very modest obviously he's
ecstatic to be here and he's got margin
for error he's still in the Winner's
bracket so he could lose a batch and
still be in this tournament that's kind
of a dream scenario uh for Dimitri no
expectations on him it's actually that's
why it's really fun to play as an
underdog because you know you're not
really in the spotlight and uh he's got
good chances I mean let me tell you this
he's much happier to play Jordan in the
second round than hikar Nakamura
yeah and he is he continues with those
night jumps we see night before we saw
plenty of those by him on day one as
well hitting that Queen Jordan's
sidesteps we will sidestep from this
game for now and head back to Fabiano
caruana taking on not the back up to
such Rob of course the big matchup
between two absolute stars of the game
it's a clash of generations youth versus
experience there is it also a clash of
styles James absolutely I mean well
absolutely is very strong in like every
I think he's a universal player he's not
known for being super aggressive but
he's very solid very so I mean sort of
like Wesley so like precise but also
very solid he likes to play a range of
openings too as well the good ones like
nothing risky you don't see King's
Indian from him you only see a grunfels
or you see very solid stuff from him and
it's worked I mean world rapid champion
at its age the youngest ever right and
then Fabi is very direct but he also you
know is very strong calculated human
calculator Coe brand for us right
calculation over everything I mean
calculates and here I mean he must have
calculated or prepped himself into a
great position so far I mean the C5
square is on lock of the C6 Pawn is weak
I don't even see any good trumps in
Blacks position to be honest okay we
have active pieces to say the least our
pieces are developed when it comes to
weaknesses I mean that's really apparent
for for black here A7 coming week C6 is
weak C5 is weak right so and the C file
itself we have everything and we like
here with the white pieces
yeah some uh kind of I'm not sure
exactly what to call them they're not
quite hanging pawns uh this structure
with uh C6 and D5 but yeah some juicy
squares nonetheless James you pointed
out to jump into either the Knight can
jump in at some point a bit later on or
you can kind of plant a bishop on a nice
Square uh you do have to be slightly
careful I guess of this E2 point but
easily defended uh for example at some
point I wouldn't be surprised if Fabi
does take a timeout just to shuffle his
Rook across uh this does ring a bell
this position I'm not sure if I've seen
exactly this one but it was recommended
in some books by Robert averick a few
years ago just uh this way of fighting
against the tarash
um the terrorist defense and yeah
looking healthy for white but I should
mention Carolina has burned a bit of
time so maybe not loving his position as
much as uh it it looks uh visually yeah
what do you think Daniel if it gets any
harder than 78 degrees in his room then
his room might start to burn and now
he's wearing a sweatshirt so no comment
there but no this is the positional
Masters capablanca Rubenstein they'd be
very happy to have this type of position
full clamp on the dark squares on the
queen side Black's Pawn structure called
The Hanging pawns when you've got those
two ponds on an island in the center and
the C6 Pawn that's the base of the pawn
chain that's the one that you really
want to try to attack you can do it with
Queen C2 he centralizes his bishop and
David you mentioned the E2 Pawn being a
bit of an issue you can also fix that by
moving the queen away from D1 and then
pushing that pawn up to E3 which would
also have the positive effect of
supporting the bishop so plenty of ways
to solve that problem carwana with a
very small but stable Edge in this
position I think yeah I think we're all
in an agreement here that we like
White's position that we would pick
white but uh there must be something
going for black hair what should Abdus
photograph be thinking about he has a
big time Advantage how can he utilize
that how can he generate some kind of
activity some kind of play you often
need something to compensate for this
hanging structure
yeah
oh that's gonna be a hard one you can't
even really move the bishop I mean you
have to go d8 because the bishop takes
F6 is on top there right um now of
course maybe we could try moving to
Bishop's f8 to hit E2 because it does
hit E2 it's in between like Bishop f8
Bishop F6 Bishop E2 but I mean even then
like the Europe King side is kind of
messed up there I don't think we are
allowing Bishop takes E2 there so maybe
we do have to play Rook E1 but now we
have to worry about the knights uh so
maybe do we move it to E4 like I don't
have squares really like it doesn't I
have to kind of go there I can't go D7
E8 H5 is taken like I have to do
something there this isn't the easiest
position to navigate at all for black
yeah this looks like the best bet or at
least a decent practical try for black
right now uh at least you have one
active piece here the Knight on e4 in
the center so it makes a lot of sense
but I'll do a tour of weighing up these
options himself he's thinking okay how
can I at least plant one nice piece into
the center uh if you can't do anything
else and I don't see anything else
productive to do while white starts to
get organized in this next few moves it
looks like great opening prep by Fabi
gotta say
yeah I wouldn't make a mountain out of a
molehill though I would you know stay
calm here for black because you still
saw him and Rook 8 can come to ca not
the move you really want to play but
it's going to take a long time for white
to actually get around to winning one of
these pawns because good squares they
don't win new games they get you a nice
position Knight to C5 pleasant but you
know White's not winning or anywhere
close candy I know you had something to
say oh no I was just uh give us tactics
please we are the tactics no but this is
really good in fact you know it's funny
you know we do this all the time this is
Joe Bava reminiscent in a way without
the bishop on G2 obviously but you know
the lines with C5 right we've got the
Knight on A4 and the bishop The Bishop's
usually on F4 no slides but I mean
really white always just has a nagging
Edge because of the pawn structure is
better there's a bishop f8 move I felt
it I felt it definitely but I mean it
definitely does not feel good after like
we're okay rookie one even G4 with a
Tempo rookie one played and then
probably Knight E4 and just relax yeah
but try to do something with that if
I'll be doing something this kind kind
of really instructive for those viewers
at home especially the younger viewers
he was thinking during Abdul sotoro's
kind of long tank there I do the story
of was uh kind of mulling things over
for two three minutes Fabio was
instantly ready with his reply so
especially in rapping and Blitz just uh
watch out for that one think in your
opponent's time and uh Abdul's Torah
clearly has come up with that plan but
you mentioned there James at least one
good piece often does make a position a
lot healthier and that black knight now
I'm loving where it sat in the center
just peering at the white king as well
White's King side potentially slightly
vulnerable long term and it's slightly
harder as well for white to plant
Knights or any pieces uh into those dark
squares without allowing a bunch of
exchanges and it's not clear at the
moment at least to me who that favors so
big questions for Fabi now how to
improve his position
a little grass up here no that's too
much the night is uh in the center
planted on e4 there was a threat of
getting that Bishop to B4 to hit that
rook and David as you mentioned we are
seeing a bunch of trades on C5 but one
gets the feeling that if there were only
major pieces left black should be fine
you've got a Target on that E2 Pawn uh
it's a soft spot in White's position The
Rook on it the bishop on H5 but right
now the big question is do you really
want to trade that super nice Knight on
e4 for that Bishop that's a hard
question I mean giving me Nakamura for
Asia Vibes where you've got the bishop
pair you can eliminate it but that means
giving up a strong piece these are the
kinds of decisions that GM chess is made
of and oftentimes the strongest players
are just as unsure uh as any player
would be of making this decision you've
got to make it intuitively you can feel
the wheels turning a note or back set if
you're not taking on C5 you could
consider a move like Rook AB8 make minor
improvements on the queen side looks
like he's getting ready to make his
decision he's got to do that quickly as
well and this could be his chance to
neutralize the bishop pair or once that
Bishop gets out of there we saw in Ali
Raza Hikaru how strong the potential
that they have in a long-term position
uh not a backup disaster of definitely a
dilemma for him does he capture on C5
right now or does he keep that Knight
alive on e4 as I mentioned I'm biased I
would get rid of those Bishops I saw the
power of them in the fridge game but he
says no he doesn't want to trade Bishops
that black knight is pretty impressive
gotta say and okay he just maintains the
tension now Fabi is going to try and
activate maybe his Queen maybe he'll get
that white dot Square Bishop out of the
way just uh to ensure it stays on the
board there we go he does activate his
Queen until threats the C6 Pawn a bit of
a bit of a tender one in the next few
moves and watch out there is a pin as
well the two queens a bit of tension on
that diagonal you like it James yeah I
love everyone it's just worse for black
I mean even if we would have taken on C5
I'd probably like if they call it the
Lesser evil right is like maybe taking
well H5 lasting I like it h5e wants to
go H4 maybe we play H4 ourselves here as
Fabi but I mean you're just it's just
worse even if we do take yeah he moves
the bishop now so now we have the bishop
here but he's arguing hey at least I
have a knight here if we would have
traded the Knight for the bishop then we
do have you know a worse position where
C6 is just completely weak we play E3 we
double the Rooks on a C file we always
playing for two results in that game for
white here so I guess he wanted to keep
the Knight on the board to say okay I
have more chances here keep my position
and maybe options alive like maybe if I
could get a C5 in rookie six Queen D6
Rook CA somehow plays C5 and then use
the hanging Pawn structure to try to
maybe move forward it does weaken the
pawns a little bit but sitting around
and waiting is something that we don't
want to do especially uh Notre back here
rookie six is very common I like it
Bishop F5 maybe Swinging The Rook on the
H file yeah he's playing moves with it
look very aggressive uh abducible he's
not necessarily threatening anything
he's just saying to Fabi okay if you
can't get anywhere then long term maybe
they'll be something against your king
side
yeah I'm struggling for ideas actually
here for Fabi it there's no kind of
natural kind of easy looking smooth
moves that uh improve his position
necessarily well H4 is very tempting
tactically because I see the rook and
the queen they're on the same diagonal
so H4 would threatened sort of threaten
Bishop H3 which wouldn't win an exchange
but it would induce a very weakening
move F7 F5 would be necessary but black
and beat white to the punch as James
pointed out Bishop F5 and the light
squares on the king side have been
weakened so
caruana with some difficult decisions to
make here if he doesn't play H4 then
black could play H4 and then strike even
further at the king side with F7 F5 once
white plays G4 so far from a one-sided
position and if Carl wanna is to attack
the C6 Pawn he's got to do it
efficiently it's not clear how to pile
the pressure onto that pawn David last
thing I'll say Rook C2 walks right into
a potential x-ray so
difficult difficult stuff here and Fabi
does decide to push that H1 up he does
then I expect a quick decision from Abdi
tutorov looks Supernatural here just to
bring the bishop there we go to F5 and
uh no threats now for white and at least
he's solidified uh on the dark squares
here I do wonder whether later on in the
game we will see some sacrifices maybe
by the Knight on one of these two
squares maybe we'll see G5 at some point
if black gets really desperate there
will be at least some counter play
against the white king to fall back on
but uh okay Fabi reacts by attacking the
H Pawn a bit of a strange looking move
but uh also asking black a difficult
question you don't really want to push a
pawn for example to G6 to defend because
suddenly huge weaknesses on the dart
squares long term and uh yeah how will
black react to that big question I mean
you know me David I just want to play G5
my guy in The Rook can go to G6 at some
point like G5 is definitely tempting
right it's not that bad engine's like
okay it ain't terrible but it's not that
good either but it's not terrible and
then it asks do you let it think it
almost goes to Eagle G5 is definitely a
move and then we play something like six
and like go at him he did play H5 he put
the bishop on F5 he played rookie six
signifying I want his king size
something and then what is it is the
question and I like what he's done
instead as well he takes away that light
squat Bishop offers a trade so now
there's no more Bishop air advantage and
that pawn on G4 it looks like it's a
double Pawn but it also really cramps
down White's position
was there a need for Fabi to take on G4
at least that seems to me intuitively to
have been a strategic error yeah
actually my favorite porn structure in
chess let's just make a random move
let's say B3 my favorite Pawn structure
in chess uh is actually this one just I
call it the bug house structure you just
put your king uh on this square and it's
safe as houses tucked away and uh yeah
it's very strange to me that Fabi
committed so early and now the king is
not necessarily safe I can imagine uh
the queen somehow lining up on this
diagonal long term and causing some
problems for the Y King
and that moved G5 so I'm staring at it
family is in the air but you've got to
be super careful when you play it
because that Bishop on D4 will be a
monster just gotta make sure you're not
the one getting checkmated it's
definitely an idea that not a Beck has
in mind to blow open the king side King
G2 played quickly the good thing for
Fabi is that he has kept it under
control on the clock the clocks are
level but it is about who this position
is easier to play for and I think the
answer for that would be nodded back
with an open e-line the open b line
having the option to put the rook and
you add the Knight on e4 taking control
of that C5 Square White's got one plan
Target the C6 Pawn but black can also go
for the E2 Pawn doubling up on the
e-line yeah White's kind of a one-track
mind here he has to attack those Queen
side pawns less minor pieces there are
the harder uh it becomes to do that so
Rook C2 and Rook ec1 is I think what
fabby's leaning on which makes the next
two moves so important for an order back
that F2 Pawn E2 Pawn you might have one
of them for breakfast or I say breakfast
but that's hard to do as well he might
double with Rook a to E8 but don't don't
forget also about the A7 Pawn which
would hang
weaknesses everywhere you've got to
watch out for it A7 so easy to miss it's
definitely a tender spot in Black's
position that does Tie Down The Rook on
a that Queen on A4 is a multi-purpose
piece uh David it not only eyes the C6
weakness that we're talking about it
pins that C6 Pawn not letting it Advance
down the board but also keeps the roof
tied down to A7 yeah like you say
White's Queen very actively placed right
now but uh yeah it's unclear what to do
next just to point out Tanya's uh lines
there the queen does eye up this one and
this one keeping blacks pieces honest
the move I was instantly attracted to
was just to get out of this pin I want
to kind of cause some trickery I want to
kind of move my queen out the way
eventually uh now that the pin is broken
potentially push this Pawn forward just
sacrificing opening up this diagonal but
what else is up to satoro thinking about
he pushes his Pawn to A6 oh I'm not sure
I like that one The Rook is still tied
down to this Pawn even if it's not on a
dark square but uh yeah Dania you
mentioned Rook C2 followed by Rook ec1
ganging up on weakness I think I've
gotten installed that yeah maybe Rook a
to E8 because then tactically the pawn
is Untouchable on A6 because of C5 but
you're right white plays rook ec1 and
the A6 Pawn isn't the problem you
haven't done anything about your C6 Pawn
either white is faster to that pawn than
black is to the E2 Pawn in this case so
maybe a little bit of panic based on the
time that he has on the clock this
position very hard to evaluate I think
the next couple of moves are going to
determine who will be in the driver's
seat
fully agreed it feels like it could turn
if black whips up an attack great for
the queen and Knight combo but uh if not
then white has huge targets to attack
especially those blackboards on the
queen side
um who would you pick here James if you
had to imagine I like black I do like
this F5 G5 idea okay yes the league
weakens the dark squares for the um for
around my king but I mean yeah it
weakens it but it's only weak if you can
get to it now of course there could be
something later on but F5 and G5 are
really strong F5 is threatening almost
like F4 break that boy Way open there
maybe play some G5 in there too as well
F5 followed by G5 is really aggressive
but it also will get you in the think
tank here especially as uh Bobby's
getting lower on time definitely want to
throw an F5 in there and a G5 and then
F4 and we see who's attacking who
I love it March down the board with
those three is the first one that
Launches on the board is five is f Bond
and not a back taking David's advice
thinking in his opponent's time Knight
D2 and immediately Queen C2 hits that
Knight on D2 the Knight has to fall back
to C4 it's the only square but will he
throw in a check first on F3 it is
possible there's an evil tactic but
please go on oh no I I think you need to
hit us with the evil tactics no but it's
a long line there's this line I was
thinking Knight C4 B3 got it the night
drops back to D6 and then if white takes
the pawn on C6 if I calculated this
correctly after the trade of queens and
G takes F3 can't take with the E Pawn
because the Rook is spin if you take
with a king there's Knight B5 or F5
and I think white loses a piece because
Rook takes E6 Knight captures the bishop
with a fork so maybe that is the line
that Notre back was so busy calculating
on Fabiano's turn except he's fallen
into another thing wow that's insane
that's a crazy line the positions that
we have on the light board and look at
the position that we have on the
analysis board but we might be well I
don't think we had that but it's
definitely something that players have
to think about what are the chances of
this being an intense time scramble
they're both down to about four minutes
on the clock uh and who do you think is
stronger playing on seconds James
it's a good question uh it's about who
plays more I think Fabi has been playing
a lot online lately a lot and he's also
been in time scrambles he plays the
title Tuesday but also Notre back so
that's like uh it's kind of if I had to
give one I'll probably get a slight Edge
to file because he did make it all the
way through of course but I mean
norterbeck is called very close very
close
yeah and it's it's just crazy uh Daniel
you calculated a six move variation in
like two seconds I think that actually
is after satora's best bet because you
don't want to put that Black Knight on
the rim you don't want to put it on any
weird kind of superficial squares you
want to centralize it so retreating that
night super logical and actually pretty
strong I think he moves it into E3 okay
we can't pick up the C6 spawn what are
the tactics in that position is black
just playing for initiative I don't see
a way to keep the Queens on the board
here
this is getting very sharp do you have
to move the king here as Fabby I think
you cannot take that pawn the black uh
Rook would have been able to capture on
E1 at the very end after a queen trade
white would have lost a piece there so
you have to shuffle across and as you
say Tanya how do you keep the Queens on
the board you can't is the answer and uh
getting complicated now yeah there's a
big bin
the E2 Pawn is under attack can you
afford to ignore it can you give it up
and just go for the eight points
brilliant move forcing a pair of Rooks
off the board Fabi is on top tactically
this is probably going to bail out into
a draw wow
they required so much Precision from
these players and Fabi he's definitely
worked a lot on his rapid play over the
last couple of years after the 2018
World Championship match and we've been
seeing him he he didn't win The
chessable Masters David when he was
absolutely incredible in that tournament
the only player to stay in the winners
bracket throughout yeah he's just so
impressive Fabi and he keeps upping his
game especially in the online format and
the rapid format and yeah we mentioned
that it might fizzle out to your draw
but Fabi will be feeling optimistic if
he can keep some tension over the next
few moves uh he's got a couple of extra
minutes oh really classy move there from
Abdul sotorov I was going to say White's
trump card is the fact that you have an
outside passport and two versus one
potentially on the queen side that is
gone now and uh Fabi meanwhile Paul
hunting this is gonna fizzle out this
one is destined to be a draw most
Brooklyn games are drawn as they say and
this is one of them even if white has
three versus two on the king side at the
very end that is a simple draw too
foreign
games gotta say
that's what sets him apart from the uh
rest of his generation I feel he's able
to calmly hold look at him sitting back
sipping somewhere
he knows he's going to draw this one
very nice with the black pieces too as
well the professional way women with
white draw with black right so looking
very draw like here don't see any
chances for white right
yeah
of course he's trying H5
yeah and I've actually had that exact
end game I think half a dozen times in
my career for three versus two let's
imagine that all the pawns on the left
half of the board disappear uh well it
just has f g and H against blacks two
pawns there and that calm kind of way to
defend that is to put your king in front
of the H Pawn he's even forcing the
issue by trading more pawns off the
board after really
simple really classical stuff here
and yeah at the right moment he will
liquidate he will just trade off the
whole of the queen side yes it's going
to be two versus one but it should be an
easy draw yeah and that's even if white
is able to win the D5 Pawn which is not
a given either because the king picks it
up and The Rook on D3 is undefined and
black can play A4 then yeah I think this
is going to be a draw the only question
is in how many moves Fabi does Strike
King in D4 and I'm just a tour of does
not delay he can just play F5 and trade
all the remaining pawns off the board
you can tell body language neither
player
I'm too excited about this one it's
gonna end in King versus King and we do
have the draw
beautiful yeah a peaceful result but the
game was anything but peaceful we saw a
dynamic play by both these players and
it ends in a drama we've still got
action on in the other game in the
winner semi-finals so let's quickly jump
over to Jordan run for us Dimitri
Corollas they were the big news from day
one taking down Hikaru Nakamura and
alireza ferrusha they're fighting
against each other it's an end game but
I love how black spawns are on H4 G4
what is the spawn structure that we've
got White's got two double pawns there
the f61 feels really weak Black's got a
double who's better first question
the evaluation Bar says black so I'm
gonna trust it here I don't like White's
Bishop locked in if the Rooks disappear
black is almost guaranteed to win it's
going to be a good night versus bad
Bishop scenario the Black Knight will be
sitting pretty on the light squares but
uh while Rooks remain Anything Can
Happen Jordan trying to break through
trying to get rid of one of those Duo uh
that you highlighted Tanya those two
scary black Pawns
and protect it though you can protect it
just swing the black rock across looks
very strong here white F6 Pawn is doomed
level material right now but black about
to go Pawn up and once that black knight
jumps over to C6 how are you defending
the other weaknesses so why B4 Under
Fire D4 Under Fire and it all comes down
to this bad Bishop that white has the
dark Squad Bishop it doesn't have much
of a future because all of black spawns
are on light squares and that's a great
instructive point for all the chess kids
out there when you're playing in a night
versus Bishop you're facing the bishop
put your pawns on the opposite color of
your opponent's Bishop so they can never
be a Target
I'm struggling to find a defensive idea
here Rook H1 can try to go to C1 and
then a C8 but black stroke could shuttle
back to D5 at the right moment Black's
got all of the key Central squares under
his control White's Bishop is a big pawn
and David's showing that line right now
just Rook D5 and if you can get to that
B7 Pawn that's your one major hope to
get it past A5 one you're not gonna win
that pawn in a million years the Knight
on d8 is actually a great defensive
piece here so maybe that's out of the
question maybe swing your king and then
bring the bishop back to F2 and Target
the H4 Pawn that's another defensive
attempt
um but all of this is water under the
bridge I think black should win this
with precise technique yep fully agreed
it looks like uh Jordan as well
struggling to come up with ideas in the
current position he's down now under two
minutes he spent almost half his
remaining time on this one move because
there's simply nothing to do okay he
does swing his Rook back as you
predicted there Daniel and uh
yeah I think you're safe to take the
pawn on F6 why not this is definitely
yeah I mean Bishop is uh as you see all
the pawns are in the dark squares while
King E2 and look at the eval bar just
eat up the whole whole side of the board
there of course as it Blends in with the
board almost black is completely winning
everything can be played here marching
down the board H3 comes and that's a
strong Pawn because it's just going to
deflect all of White's pieces to defend
that pawn and that means the queen side
falls apart
literally all its pawns now are on the
opposite color to White's Bishop Tanya
so you predicted it put pawns on light
squares now it's only pawns on dark
squares for white only pawns on light
squares for black worst case scenario
for the bishop that poor Bishop on E3 it
wishes it was anywhere else other than
the square it's worse than Jordan's air
quality
not many things worse but wow Jordan's
air quality is actually significantly
worse than just a few moves ago
from the beginning now that CO2 is
increasing with every push that the
h-bond makes it gets a little worse
quality every time and uh quality of
this bishop is very bad obviously so we
have the queen coming in and we're going
we're going to Queen we can get the king
to E4 quite quickly too as well weakness
on F4 Knight C6 is on top somewhere you
have to use the king and the Rook to
defend obviously the Queenie Square we
can even Queen give up the pawn and
still end up probably winning this end
game it's just really bad for white it
means you're playing strong very strong
from 1966 maybe time to hit the button
yeah hit the button pretty soon
yeah you can tell Jordan wants to get
out of here he wants to move on to the
next game but as a professional player
you have to keep going as long as
there's even a one percent chance of A
Swindle of a fight back where is that
one percent chance that's the big
question on the clock I don't know wow
but even on the clock things don't look
good for Jordan man first he's down to
about a minute uh symmetrical Arts he
makes his debut in division one of the
Champions Chester and he has been on
fire so far with the black pieces in
driver's seat The Rook on H5 the King on
F5 it just seems to be dominating the
board the only thing remaining is to get
that Knight over to C6 and start hitting
those Pawns
on the board
s are going to start dropping like flies
you can even take uh you have your
choice of which one to take
oh with that poor white Rook as well
sitting in the corner totally stuck yeah
game over Daniel One swipe plays Bishop
takes a shoe he won't be able to get
that Bishop it's gonna move from E3 to
an even worse Square which does exist
and that square would be H2 I think
Knight C6 will be the nail the final
nail in the coffin here
yep those pawns are right for plucking
right now just go for that B4 Pawn
I mean you can do anything as you called
it Knight C6 and White's actually in zuk
Swang pretty much you can't move
anything right now another Pawn drops
two point advantage
you can go back to Knight C6 again and
like take the third one that's crazy
yeah for the game centralized that night
put it on D5 put it anywhere there we go
push that button to B4 everything's
defended that Bishop on H2 is that a
bishop
what Bishop on H2
wow that's been the nightmare in White's
position that Bishop on H2 isn't going
anywhere the only active Beast The Rook
on C1 that's the last hope that Jordan
has is a difficult technique what's the
easiest winning plan for black here
David oh I'm not sure the easiest
there's a there's a bunch here if I'm
not mistaken you can actually just take
White's remaining uh F Pawn pushing this
one forward makes a bit of sense the
black girl can always step back to the
seventh rank if it really needs to to
defend uh the weakness on B7 white has
no counterplay essentially White's King
is dark Bishop is stuck pawns especially
the F4 ball and about to drop
I think he's found a really nice uh kind
of thematic sadistic way of doing it
just dropping the black Rook back there
we go protecting the final Target for
white on H7 and yeah he's just gonna mop
up the black porn will act as a
distraction and uh black will win on the
rest of the board essentially
two pawns and Counting and that rook's
coming to C7 he wants to try to trade
that Rook take control of the open C
line the G7 and take F4 I mean my first
coach would always remind me the number
of moves in the game isn't recorded only
the results is recorded so you can take
as long as you want to I don't think
he's going to take all that much longer
King takes F4 and press the button as
one wise man likes to say hit the button
start a new one yeah actually done you
mentioned uh the move's not counting I
pride myself in uh going for as long as
yeah exactly I want the most then the
torture 100 moves yes please yes what's
your longest game David no 236 but
meanwhile this game
say that again 236.
you're also seeing some insane player
here by Dimitri colors as he takes the
win with the black pieces the players
will be playing four rapid games in the
winners bracket three more remain we saw
a draw in the Fabi Abdul sattro matchup
and Dimitri Cola has reasons to be proud
about the start that he's just had with
the black pieces taking down Dutch
number two David exciting game exciting
game it was a bit up and down but I just
want to highlight for everyone at home
especially the chess kids out there one
thing not to do and uh it was actually a
strategic error that cost him in the end
Jordan van forest in a very dynamic
position very complicated position white
is about to lose a pawn potentially on
D4 this week this year but it was better
to give up this Pawn than go into the
end game that we saw a bit later on
throwing White's best piece forward
Knight F6 check allowed black to
initiate that whole dynamic we saw later
on of the beautiful night against the
terrible bishop and after black was able
to play G5 it was a one-way fight the
black king simply Advanced took this
Pawn the Black Knight far superior to
his counterpart here and the game
as we saw was history definitely want to
play through at home if you want to
learn about knife versus Bishop Dynamics
just some great technique there by
Dmitry golarz this is how you play an
end game take advantage of all the
weaknesses and that means that these are
the score lines going into round two off
the winner semi-final Dimitri kolas
takes the lead in his match against
Jordan van forest and Fabiano caruana
another
a tough combative fight could have been
anyone's game but eventually fizzled out
with a lot of Trades but it was an
exciting round one and we are expecting
more of that but first we do have a shot
twitch break
foreign
[Music]
Master Mike with us he is the chief just
officer of Chess kid and here he is
reminding us that every Grandmaster was
once a chess kid
hello there Champions just tour fans
it's feeding Master Mike Klein better
known as fun Master Mike on chess kid
I'm actually on holiday somewhere in
Madagascar but if there's one thing I
want to take time out to do is to tell
you about why chess kid is hosting this
awesome event before I do let me
actually start out by telling you a
story about the first time I met Hikaru
Nakamura he was 10 years old playing
right beside me at an open chess
tournament he lost to a Grandmaster and
he was really upset and I thought who's
this 10 year old you're not supposed to
be upset listening to a grand master but
of course it's that sort of feistiness
and belief in himself that led him to go
on to such great things in the Chess
World so why don't we Host this event
because we want chess to be as common as
music or art education if you think
about it if every kid learned how to
play chess as young he's the car who did
how many more cool personalities will
there be in the Chess World how many
more 2700s would be in the Chess World
so that's our goal and by hosting the
chess kid cup we hope that this
eventually happens all over the world so
pesh could you agree with you see pesky
agrees if peshka agrees you should agree
too I can't wait to see the exciting
conclusion of the chess kid cup and
again chess kids so happy to be
sponsoring this event
that was so much fun thank you Mike and
speaking of big chess kids well we've
got a very special guest who's joining
us all the way from Minnesota honestly
she's been a phenomenal player she's
just 13 years old Alex welcome to the
show
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
we're so happy to have you here with us
Alice the last few months we've been
seeing this incredible rise and maturity
in your game and tell us what makes that
possible for you
to Chaska definitely
um uh at the name of this club uh chess
kid was
how I first started to learn and play
chess and
um supported me throughout my entire
Journey from when I started
and um in the past few months I think a
lot of credit also does go to
um the amount of tournaments I've been
able to play in all which I released
John the US Chess Federation has been
extremely great
um they've supported me with the thrift
Fellowship which I received last year
um and overall I have a lot of people to
think for my recent results
that's super cool to hear and Alice I
was following your games at the protest
League recently as well as the American
Cup and it was just amazing to watch you
play the first thing that comes to my
mind is you were playing against this
really strong Grand Masters but you were
so Fearless how do you do that
yeah I mean I suppose against these
stronger players because I know them
like they're like so famous they're
really strong
um I usually just sort of expect that if
I lose then it's okay so therefore I
think that my plate is a bit more like
um without playing without too much fear
of losing because losing is not
something that I'm afraid of it's just
really great to be playing against these
really strong players
Alice you've already accomplished so
much in your chess career from World
youth Chess Championship victories to
drawing Hikaru Nakamura in the protest
League it's a great performance at the
US Women's Championship what do you
consider to be your proudest
accomplishment to date
um
2022 last year because
first tournament on
a big uh high level and I wasn't
expecting to get any results but I
actually got second place so that was my
most memorable experience and it's
definitely a really good one
wow Alice it's so amazing to hear all of
this from you and it's so inspiring and
before we let you go I have to ask you
one last question that there are so many
girls across the world young kids boys
and girls we're watching you play You're
Fearless ambitious player on the board
what would be your advice to chess kids
across the world
uh yeah try to just enjoy the game
um chess is really a beautiful like game
it has a lot of aspects geometry art
um and it's just important to enjoy the
game and if you do so you your level
will naturally go up as you continue to
study
some really cool wise words from you
Alice and we hope one day to see you on
the tour as well
thank you thank you so much for joining
us and all the best but before that
actually what is your next on one where
can we watch you play
um I'll actually be leaving for a
tournament tomorrow
um it's a tournament in New York
um and I'm thinking my last time Norm so
uh it will last uh from like
two days it starts in two days and uh
lasts for about a week
from all of us here in the studio all
the best Alice go get that final I am
nam and a GM soon
thank you
uh honestly she has been such a
phenomenal player we've seen a meteoric
rise and she's just all of 13 years it's
been amazing to watch her play and from
one talented young girl to another we've
got a very special piece coming up for
all of you tomorrow and it is on the
eight-year-old bodana sivanandan uh
David our very own David Howell actually
visited her and had a great conversation
and he has a little uh look at what's
coming up tomorrow
[Music]
my goal is to become the youngest I'm GM
in the world or if not then the youngest
gym in the UK after that I want to play
in the world championships and get world
champion I think it will be Harvard I
still think I can do it
[Music]
oh that was amazing to have this dream
and ambition to become the youngest GM
she's she finished second in the British
women Blitz championship at his eight
years old that's amazing to see James
see absolutely strong eight years old
too as well and she has dreams and
Ambitions here never let anyone tell you
what you can and cannot do she's telling
you they're eight years old she's
telling you what I want to do that's
awesome we got to see more of that for
sure yeah awesome chess kids all around
some of them as well in division two and
three and as always we've got Simon
updating us with the action Simon what's
been going on
uh loads of stuff's been going on I'm
just going to show you a little sweet
tactic now we all love a bit of tactical
play I know you do James yeah your
tactic
diamond and I have to admit that that
young girl we just saw actually lost her
in a similar as well so that was uh I
was going to say embarrassing but she's
so strong
um but this was um a big big game it was
in the quarterfinals and it was between
uh two of the favorites fedexv and
fedesef was playing with white pieces
against David Anton of Spain and it was
a very messy position uh and the the
Finish was really quite sweet it was
black to move and David I'm sure you can
uh show us some moves there with uh the
Black Knight now jumping into the
position so we saw Knight D3 and now can
you spot the cheeky tactic here The
Cheeky tactic that won the game was
Knight to F7 check wow boom put that in
your pipe and smoke it uh say English
people and um this was a very nice way
to get a back rank check mate after Rook
takes the queen comes in to the back
Rank and black can't defend and it's
going to be Checkmate I would say one
more thing though if we just go back
before Knight F7 was played if you're an
artist as I know we have some artists on
the past I didn't see Knight episode
there we have an artist our own artist
on the panel and Daniel points out that
Queen C8 would have been the artistic
way to finish it because you pretty much
have to take the queen and now look at
this check mate that is beautiful the
Knight slides in and checkmates so that
was a very nice finish and that put
fedexv into the semi-finals or division
two so he's getting nearer and nearer
qualifying for the first division
known as the big fish what a tactical
Beast lovely finish that thank you so
much Simon we will check in back with
you but right now it is time to check
into the action in division one as we
are about to lift off game two and we
have seen amazing stuff amazing play by
the players some resourceful defensive
and attacking chest there and look at
not the back of the central that is full
Focus
yeah if you look up focus in the
dictionary that picture is going to be
that he's known for his focus and
especially with the white pieces he's
extremely dangerous so it's a queen's
Pawn opening no nimzo Indian transposing
now to the Queen's gamber declined what
do we think is Fabian a solid mood is he
just gonna try and survive with black
and go for it with white
goes in and now transposing to a line of
the names of Indian with G3 which has
been pretty popular usually black takes
on C4 in these lines and then goes
Knight C6 and tries to cling to that
pawn that knight from C6 then often goes
to A5 you get very complicated positions
here
very complication complicated positions
indeed and okay of this sort of just
sliding his Rook across normally he
knows things inside out if he chooses A
variation especially if it's quite
forcing where he's sacrificed a pawn
like here he knows all of the details
but so does Fabi so a big surprise do we
think rookie one that's not the most
common move as far as I'm aware well I
am up a pawn so I'm gonna take the pawn
here and keep it back in 1987. I was up
a pawn and I I captured it and I kept it
so do you think Dania well I think you
might play Knight f635 and put a little
bit of pressure kind of like Robert
hubner did and Tilbury in 1976.
um the only idea that I'm familiar with
and yeah rookie one is not the most
common move I think Bishop G5 is the
main line but Knight D5 and then the
Knight can drop back to B6 the key thing
for black is to keep that pawn on C4
because if you lose that pawn then you
don't have much to show for in return
for White's Superior control of the
center but definitely it's safe to say
that Fabi is out of book
yeah so the move we're expecting Knight
to D5 may be planting this Knight over
the other side is all about keeping this
Pawn if he does black is doing very well
okay one thing's for sure this is going
to be a fun one Fabi trying to hang on
to that pawn the idea is to advance with
the beep on you want to get B5 in you
want to keep that C4 Pawn defended for
us long as possible so this is going to
be a fight for the initiative the fight
is also on on the other board as Dmitry
colas did take that first win against
Jordan van Forrest with the black pieces
in convincing style and now he's got the
white pieces Jordan has to find a way to
stop the bleeding yeah
yeah first game
on a roll and this is gonna be a
challenge now with the black pieces Back
Against The Wall this was the situation
that Hikaru Nakamura was in against
Jordan Bend Forest yesterday ikara was
able to swim the swindlejordan in game
two but let's see what Jordan comes up
with in the opening this is the same
opening the Tamanna of that he used to
defeat noterbeck in the last round of
Tata steel an opening that he knows very
well assuming that he plays Knight to C6
here of course he doesn't
he played a night move every yeah every
call we make seems to be cursed at the
moment yeah okay so Knight C6 now he
first attacks the Central Point same
thing yeah
you know night or if it's all the same
that's all this is Sicilian sister for
the kill is that what Jordan has in mind
exactly right the seal for the kills
seal the end okay now here this these
lines get very very short depending on
what white does I mean every Sicilian
one is it not sharp really but of course
uh this nice C6 is usual usual Theory
but you could also go Bishop E3 you
could go Bishop E2 right you can go H3
you go A3 even Rook G1 believe it or not
I love playing Rook G1 in random
positions just because you can and it's
fun even richer report does a lot of
that too as well but Knight to C6 here
curious to see which way he goes here
yeah and uh obviously Dimitri Collins
knows this position obviously he's had
it before but now with the match
situation adding a bit of uh extra
flavor here does he choose a risky line
maybe the most ambitious for white would
be for example to take this Knight on C6
there we go wow that's print support as
well E5 yeah this line gets so crazy
Knight D5 and then white clamps down on
the D6 square with 94 and black usually
plays Queen C7 to induce F4 and then
Queen B6 there you go C4 there's a check
on before the Knight is often sacrificed
this is about to get crazy this is going
to get crazy and F5 also extremely risky
for black the black king now is gonna be
forced to stay in the center for a long
long time often white here plays on
passon capturing that F Pawn as if it
just moved one square and uh there we go
we're gonna see a nasty check now the
White Queen can check on H5 normally
that's the end of the game if you ever
allow a check like that for the black
king can slide across and try and hide
on d8 risky stuff from Jordan he's
really going all out for the win here
you guys are calling out the game right
now Queen H five check on the board one
things to show Jordan is not going to
find King safety for the rest of the
game but the way he's playing the speed
with which he's playing uh safe to say
that this is familiar territory this is
some kind of prep by him this is his
theory it's just really weirdly enough
this is actually Theory or a weird
Theory but 100 still Theory right now
now of course I'm taking white here
every time the king just looks crazy you
need to be on your p's and q's every
letter in the alphabet you're gonna have
to know here and know it very well
especially with the black pieces here or
you can just you know run the risk of
just getting steamrolled here get it
Rook to the D file here I can still
Castle I can defend against the b-file
threats right and I mean I can even kick
the Knight with C4 still when I want to
right in D7 which are King on the D file
we're coming there it's going to be some
problems if you don't know what to do
here it is weird I mean where does black
actually move the pieces here does the
king run to the queen side like how do
we develop the rest of the pieces yeah
and also we have to answer this question
James that can black get greedy right
now the F4 Pawn looks like it's hanging
but that night on D5 it's such a key
defender in Black's position uh David
after Knight F4 is there a Fallout is
there trouble for black well I see the
evaluation bar move and uh it feels like
you should move the queen I'm not really
tempted to take this Knight because the
black queen will simply replace it on an
active Square sliding back does look
like a double attack hitting the Knight
hitting the pawn
risky and uh oh
I don't really recommend this if the
Knight drops back to the center I don't
think you should take this Pawn you
might walk into a pin and uh also
there's a check on E5 instead you will
kick this Knight away from its nice post
that you highlighted Tanya and it feels
like Black's position is falling apart
the problem is I'm not sure what else
I've spent a lot of time with Jordan van
Forrest and the way he studies openings
is he thinks how much can I get away
with I remember what's being in a car
with him and he was like check out this
line and it was the ugliest chest I've
ever seen and he was like the computer
still thinks it's equal I can get away
with it and I was like no no I'm never
playing this it feels like one of those
positions again looks so dangerous for
black with this King on the d8 Square
but uh if he can get away with it he
will know what to do that's number two
Jordan van first was in Magnus Carlton's
world championship team for the 2021
match against Jana pamlici and Magnus
did credit him with all the fun offbeat
interesting entertaining opening ideas
that were there in the files it was all
Jordan van first and that's the kind of
Chess we've come to expect from him
that's the kind of Chess we love and
that's what we're seeing right now but
that King on D it looks like an absolute
nightmare to me yeah show this position
to you know a steiness or capablanca and
they'd say get me out of here and that's
an experience a lot of GMS have had
where you analyze and prepare an opening
for a long time your opponent deviates
from the engine's main suggestion and
you look at the position you say wait a
second why am I not completely lost
again so when you over rely on engine
analysis it's easy to miss the van
forest for the trees but I think Jordan
has reacted pretty decently with Queen
B6 which is a typical move in this line
reminding white who is in charge on the
B file in the event of long Castle there
might be made threats with Rook B8
tactics with Bishop f8 to A3 are not
uncommon as well so Polaris has to be
very careful here important decision for
white yeah huge huge moment and I'd be
fascinated to see what the computer says
in this position because it is so crazy
again you don't really want to push your
Pawn forward you will walk into a double
attack here wow look at this now it
takes S6 all the time
beautiful and then takes Queen G5 Bishop
A5 get off me yeah somewhere I'm not
sure oh Bishop B4 check is
Bishop E7
Bishop B4 check pin check oh C3 C3 no
and then take on F6 and H A are you
kidding me what is this and that line
doesn't even end there there's like
Queen takes B2 and then the queen goes
back to E5 and then checking including
Queen takes a five minutes
I'm talking with my brother you're
exciting okay this is our Dream right
here this is our Dream thanks oh taste
taste logical logical and probably ends
in a draw Queen five twenty four twenty
five so never gonna happen but the
problem for Dimitri call us right now is
either he has to fall down that rabbit
hole and take this Pawn for probably
spend the next 10 minutes of his clock
time trying to work it out or he has to
find Bishop D3 which is not obvious
either necessarily every other move
gives black a significant advantage and
uh I don't think Knight C3 the third
move on the list of the computer's
choices there at the bottom I don't
think that one's obvious either so maybe
this one is findable not Knight takes
Pawn maybe bishop D3 but you have to be
willing to sacrifice Queen takes Pawn
will simply be met by castles and white
will be over the moon here where it will
be thrilled because now you have a free
hand to attack once your king slices the
safety in the corner crazy position yeah
I was definitely a fan of Bishop D3 I
mean because Bishop D3 is like I mean
you are already this position is wild
what is what's a pawn in this position
so Bishop D3 Castle kingside right and
then you just okay I develop try to
figure out what do you do F6 is still on
top here Knight F6 is wild though that
is a wild line you guys that's my heat
there baby that's the meat he's a Madman
if he plays Knight takes F6 I've got to
say he needs an award he needs prizes
immediately Dimitri Collins if he takes
an F6 then he's thinking David he's
spent quite a bit of time here I I'm
sure he's calculating all of this it was
such a fourth sequence of moose after
Knight F6 it would be amazing to see it
land on the board then he goes for C4
another option and it's not the most
accurate one but a very human approach
you want to kick that knight from D5 and
it's critical stuff if black captures
the B2 Pawn Yeah it's a supernatural
move I wonder what he has in mind
against Queen takes B2 maybe it is a
check on A5 and then dropping back to C3
but you have to be very careful with the
f8 bishop coming out to B4 uh at a wrong
moment and challenging that D2 Bishop so
maybe a miscalculation by Dimitri
College obviously I'm influenced by the
Eva Barber Jordan trusts him doesn't
take on deep B2 surprise after a
surprise here in this crazy Cecil for
the kill game maybe you know it there we
go okay what is this all right here we
go calculation go into the think tank
see if we calculate I wanted to Castle
but there's Queen E4
and Bishop check okay the Knight is
hanging wow and it just say this is GG
like what is the move it's pure
calculation here right look at the body
language of both players Dmitry collar's
pure calculation mood right now he's
thinking okay I can give a check I can
take the Knight we need two looks pretty
good here because that does stop Queen
takes B2 oh we need to and Bishop C3
might be a big problem oh that's sick
yeah it's just a simple move yeah let's
show some of these ideas maybe black and
Fight Fire with Fire and just bring his
Bishop to pin yeah
but in castles or Bishop A5 and Rook D1
oh yeah yeah that's true that's nasty
this is just crazy crazy stuff I think
again we need some help here in this
wild position what does the engine say
we see the evaluation bar shut up for
white in this position is it a check
from this angle is it just castling
Queen oh that's castles okay oh yeah
King C1 it says oh
before
interesting uh way of saying the
computer there with this odd language
they're a huge huge move on the board
there I guess you've got to calculate
what happens after Queen takes Knight
Pawn takes Knight Black's gonna have a
massive Pawns in the center but
I mean who knows what's happening here
it feels like it you should be
checkmating the black king after a check
for example but if the black king
wriggles away your king is going to be
open as well this is where you just
start making random moves and about by
move 20 you make a move where the eval
bar doesn't plummet
[Laughter]
look at that post I was going to say
from Dimitri Collins a moment ago castle
and queen side the strongest Dania
you'll move Queenie tube retreating also
up there I think those are the two
strongest for white but it's so Random
at this point the players they're
guessing and I think they need two hours
on their clock not just eight minutes to
work their way through this Labyrinth
but you've gotta admire the audience
fast play in this position your knight
is attacked he doesn't care about it he
doesn't play Queen B2 but plays the move
Queen D4 a counter attack these are not
natural moves and it just shows the kind
of creativity that Jordan van Forest is
known for and capable of and the kind of
Chess that he enjoys playing there's a
direct threat on the Knight on e4 the
pawn on video hangs what are we what do
you think will Dimitri go for this queen
E2 idea I really like it with that
threat of Bishop A5 if you take the B2
pawn and there's a sense of security
when the queen is close thinking ah you
know that feeling when the position is
chaotic but you know your king is safer
so you know you're having more of the
fun it's wholesome so but Castle's Queen
said that is one impressive move you do
have to find a response to Queen takes
Knight there I think if he sees queenie2
he's gonna play it what would you play
here David Queenie or long Castle uh
Queenie too because I'm a coward but I
would be lucky that it happens to be
strong but uh I can't see him casting
there it is
strong as well so I'll play Dimitri call
us and now it's up to Jordan I think he
has to bring his Bishop out and pin that
white C4 Pawn if you've Retreat the
Black Knight it's going to end in
disaster You're Gonna Lose a bunch of
time the black queen is going to flee
the center of the board but white will I
think be winning on the spot there
scary times for Jordan and must win
situation we thought maybe before the
game but it's a full game match so it
feels like he's burning his bridges in
this one game
you say scary time for Jordan but he
seems so calm and composed he's chilling
he's keeping it on the clock he's up by
about three minutes Queenie two player
well this is an absolutely insane
position it's gonna get only more wild
but we will for the moment zoom out from
here because there is another Wild game
on and a very important round to in the
other win a semi-final uh there was so
much action that we completely forgot
about this big matchup not a big
updosotro playing against Fabiano Taiwan
on their first game ended in a draw and
in this one uh interesting position the
a pawn has kind of vanished off the
board I am expecting that the queen went
down picked that up Bishop D4 hits the
queen can white get even more greedy and
start picking up the C4 Pawn now
fantastic
now what else just take that pawn at
least have something to suffer for one
Pawn up for whites black has active
pieces but it feels like that's it it's
just activity for now yeah nothing more
fabi's last move Bishop D4 it's like
yeah you must eat this chocolate this
delicious freshly baked chocolate chip
cookie on C4 and he might want Knight F6
to G4 but that does seem like a one move
threat which can be pretty handily
parried with the move like E3 E3 yeah
what has an extra Pawn but Black's the
one with all the activity the peace
activity the Bishops are chasing the
queen but guys I have to ask you right
now there was so much action on the
other board a dramatic position you
think this is a good moment to jump back
keep an eye out on this but it just felt
like that could actually finish any
moment with one bad move yeah we
probably need to go back over there this
one I mean he's just uh it's a pawn it's
one Pond okay it is what it is a lot of
Chess left in this game a lot of time
too I mean we're falling asleep right
now right okay yeah let's do it let's do
it let's head back to Dimitri Kola
sticking on Jordan van forest in an
absolutely crazy position and we see
Jordan has taken a bit of a think here
Queenie too has taken him off guard yeah
he was shaking his head there a moment
ago Jordan he's realizing now that the
damage has been done and he needs to
walk a very fine kind of path here he's
walking a tightrope just to survive and
that black knight Under Fire he might be
forced to sacrifice material at some
point but with a king in the center like
this for black it's unlikely you're
going to survive what was wrong with
Bishop A6 again I mean Scott's get
scotch game I mean like just visit
Basics let's jump in this V6 is probably
because I mean moving the Knight he's
probably lost on the spot yeah I think
he's deciding between F5 and Bishop A6
but Bishop A6 does look like the move
yep just to show again if you move the
Knight disaster you get hit the black
queen is actually trapped here even if
it wasn't yeah even if it wasn't then
Bishop takes Uh Wood fork and win the
black rook and uh yeah that leaves us
with two options either we hit the
knights as you mentioned there
this one feels shaky as well feels like
there might even just be a night jump at
the very least maybe flicking a check
first all sorts of things to consider
but the movie we're expecting is this
pin along the diagonal you cannot take
this Knight because the White Queen will
drop
so uh okay how do we solve this as you
asked James big question feels like it's
either castles coincide or you leave
your king in the center and just bring
your Rook across one of those two moves
or both of them at least do threaten to
jump out the way with the with the dark
Squad Bishop checking the black king
picking up the queen in the center with
the Rook how does plaque react to this
you want to say a cruel line we're
talking about James please
yeah what we got here if White Castle's
Queen side E1 square and the reason that
might be important is after Queen B6
getting out of the discovery there's
Queen E2 to E1 okay posing the threat of
Bishop A5 which is a devastating threat
Knight before A3 Knight before a three
okay A3 S6 that's some super GM levels
why long Castle is better than Rook D1
is because you vacate the E1 Square for
the queen to land on so you can threaten
a pin on A5 that's a big chess game
moment right now incredible geometry
there Daniel uh he has played Rook D1
perhaps missing this idea easy to miss
course but still a big threat on the
board Bishop A5 check would be
devastating
do you have to move the king if you move
the queen out the way it feels like
something is wrong the valuation bar
reaction just doesn't like the concept
of Queen these eggs at all I don't see
baby Queen H5 I don't know back to that
no no but then Bishop B4 check will
always be a problem
so you want to get the White Queen out
the way out of this pin so that we can
uh safely eat this night capture this
night maybe we just move the queen
where's this Knight actually going
if it has to sit on some bad squares at
the very least we kind of uh line up
like we did earlier why do people play
this line of this Assyrian again with
black I just wanted to know why this one
this one's very wild there's many ones
you could choose from but this one is
definitely didn't seem like we got the
Sicilian we were looking for at all with
the black pieces
[Laughter]
the basics that's Rook D1 happened
already or is Dimitris because I think
he's still thinking whoops I thought
he'd play directory one sorry but no he
isn't uh yeah he hasn't committed yet so
maybe you'll move on the board Daniel
Castle Queen side that could be
extremely strong so for the kill more
like Cecil be killed sheesh wow that
would be super strong if he's able to
find this idea of Queenie one Bishop A5
that would be dimitriol are showing
exactly why he's here in division one of
the chess get Gap uh and there he's got
his head in hands as does Jordan ban for
us but for two very different reasons
right now I think he's got to find it I
mean he's just in the zone you can tell
how the focus is there and also I mean
limited moves you have Rook D1 and
castlequiza you do get the king save
that when there it is I mean you get the
king safe like you get the king safe
you're threatening Bishop A5 and then
you can move your queen it's very very
easy after you realize okay how many
moves do I actually have in fact in that
position castles is one he's working one
move at a time what was that GM it was
like oh I only how many moves do you see
ahead he was like one move at a time but
it's always the best move right like
work at it what do I have what is
available to me and make the best movie
Castle Queen side looks good Jordan is
in some just some trouble for real
is impressive super impressive stuff he
find
he fine Queenie one
because Black's got ta eat with the
queen right
right
can we move it better he plays it wow he
played King Size yeah yeah it's on the
ball so Bishop C3 doesn't work because
you simply pick it up with a knife
exactly and the queen only two hangs I
think Jordan finding probably the only
way to stay in the game so kudos to him
not tilting and Dimitri still with some
work to do Bishop A5 looks like it traps
the queen but no it opens up the E3
square and the worst thing for white
right now is to allow a queen worst
thing in general is Queen trade
definitely in this position yeah just
one square for the black queen to find
safety but good enough check and
suddenly things turn in Black's favor
Black is it pulled up remember still uh
quite High here so what else can
Dimitri find Queenie one anyway or I
don't know there's no threat there
it's not easy actually for white to
generate the killer blue and if there is
no killer blue then this one's still up
in the air despite what the evaluation
Bar says so Bishop C3 runs into Knight
C3 he does black does white have time to
make and the Queen on E2 is hanging
there's white have time to make a random
move like King B1 just stepping out of
Queenie tree or is that wait there's
rugby eight Bishop C1 Queen takes C4
just to show that
is it a mess
and you win this is a family fork or
royalty yeah what do you call it here
everything mama papa grandma grandpa for
everyone everything
what about Queen H5 then is Queen H5 a
move uh oh we play Queen E1 so what's
the idea if Bishop takes Pawn now that
was the first move that came to mind I
guess now Bishop C3 the idea is that
Knight takes C3 is not possible it
doesn't know uh it is not hit a queen on
E2 any longer so uh we'll be safely able
to pick up the black queen wow he
spotted Queenie one that's for sure
Tanya to answer your question earlier he
was ready to play Queen E1 after Queen
B6 he's played it again retreating
Sometimes the best way to go forward
incredible chest there and the geometry
right you go Queen side gasoline to
vacate that square on E1 where the king
belongs at the start of the game for the
queen this is amazing player there by
Dimitri very creative stuff uh David
after you take on C4 Bishop C3 does look
like a killing idea but is Bishop C3
possible anyway because it does hit the
F6 spawn and queen E3 check you can just
trade pick up the pawn
possibly yeah very possible wow so Rook
B it runs into Bishop C3 also it's D5
Knight is hanging right so many threats
forget about that oh D5
getting a headache just looking at this
position imagine being the players yeah
so Queenie one also side steps to pin
just by the way okay so what's oh we
play Rook B8 all right Bishop c three
has to be Bishop C3 it is a threat
mating one friend you know he's gonna
spot that one Queen takes B2 Checkmate
don't let olly Reza near this position
it's not Dimitri won yesterday one of
his games okay
completely agree uh with piano Soul
there very impressive played by the
German youngster but Jordan vanver is
also putting threats here Queen B2 we're
expecting Bishop C3 and how do you how
do you think Jordan will react to that
there's a clear threat on the queen I
only see Queen E3 as the possibility we
need to reach three take on F6 take on
D1 takes takes take on h8 and at the end
of the day I mean it's just like how you
ordered his net I mean it's impressive
he did not fail within this position I
mean it's equal is right after takes
takes takes
I mean this is like he navigated his way
out of this this is the worst seems like
it's over if you're black you're like
all right I I survived I didn't get
mated I didn't lose anything this is you
know your confidence goes up a little
bit here from the black side so that was
very good I mean impressive from Jordan
for the way he's offending so yeah this
is what uh Jordan is banking on this
final position that we've just showed on
the analysis board is there anything
better why is Dimitri closing here it
might be considering Nike 93 yeah but
then you've got to give up F4 with check
and then C format
it almost works though
now you can just take this Pawn though
yeah wow that's gross yeah no threats
suddenly it's the white king that's
under more uh pressure here in bigger
danger so I think he has to go for this
end game that we just highlighted oh
whoops not that Arrow he has to go
Bishop to C3
and uh the game will go on after the
queen exchange but not easy to navigate
this two minutes now yeah wake up Susie
he's Gotta Move wake up Susie there it
is the decision and he does he moves
that Bishop to C3 we are going to see
the trades of the queen ah he goes King
C2 not Queen E3 oh that's not this but
Queen takes C1
a big decision Queen E1 you recapture
with the Rook he might have forgotten I
know this sounds dumb but the bishop on
C3 is under Fire it's I was about to
suggest King C2 and I was like wait a
second black can take on C3 after the
trade of Queens David what do you think
yeah uh I'm just struggling to explain
this decision just trade the Queens off
and black is going to be a pawn up in an
end game and it's a very healthy Pawn
especially once the Queens are off
Black's King never has to worry at all
and there we go the Queen's quickly
disappeared talked about the bishop her
a lot today but it could be relevant
again Black's light squared Bishop a bit
stuck but the dark Square Bishop very
important piece just to pawn up for
Jordan wow you're in that is amazing
that's crazy I mean this position was
wild he navigated it very well one slip
from Kolar so he had to go down that
line he had to go down Bishop C3 Bishop
takes on F6 after taking on E3 tough he
didn't go through it now blacks up a
pawn Bishops I'm taking black here
is cracked under the pressure and it's
understandable it was so complicated
that position but this is going to cost
him and Jordan just putting all pawns on
light squares and that dark Square
Bishop is going to be the MVP in the
rest of this game yeah yeah that's a bit
heartbreaking that's the brutal part
about Chess you play all the brilliances
getting your queen back to E2 you go
Queen side castling you put your queen
on E1 and then one mistake and it all
slips out of your hands and that's what
Dimitri kolas finds himself and now it
just looks like Jordan up on the clock
up a pawn with the bishop pair he's got
the material advantage and all the
compensation for it
yeah uh there's one threat on the board
that white knight is threatening to go
and Gobble up the A7 Pawn so either you
defend it or you eliminate that Knight
I'm reluctant to trade off uh the bishop
pair but that end game looks pretty uh
straightforward as well
which one will Jordan go for take a
timeout maybe just defend that pawn
yeah looking uh looking good either way
and White's just reduced to kind of one
move threats here the two white Rooks
can't really do anything the white
Bishop a bit stuck
looks like a very one-sided end game
maybe even Rock A8 to keep the B7 Square
open for the bishop looks very awkward
but then can chase the Knight away later
with A6 Jordan trying to find something
a little bit less awkward than that but
clear the black is in the driver CD
should be able to win this game with a
two minute time Advantage as well I know
wow it does look like Jordan is on the
brink of equalizing this a match but
there's still work to be done and on the
other board we do see the eval bar gives
a big advantage to another back of the
sattro and David Daniel you both nodded
to the last move by yard and just
defending that Bond keeping things under
control but this is the game that we
have to rush to because there is a lot
of action on a lot of trades on and
white has an extra Pawn
yeah four versus three on the king side
and actually the White Knight here
beautifully placed that's why Fabian has
weakened his position to kick this
Knight away pretty much all that's
changed since we were last here is that
pieces have come off the board and that
favors the side of course with the extra
opponent Abdus tour of must be a huge
favorite to win this one wow yes I have
the extra Pawn so I'm a pawn Grabber and
he's up a pond and he's gonna take that
and push that boy all the way through
the a pawn is a pass Pawn to have a look
on the C file that's very active the
Knight can come in the E6 right my pawns
aren't as weak they are weak but not as
weak as we see C7 and F5 even the
seventh rank could be weak I mean white
is uh winning by a lot here says the
engine and there's a practical chance
here I mean we do see white winning this
but it could also like be some slips
here right Daniel yeah there's a pass
Pawn but man I do not envy Fabby here I
do not care wannabe black and Notre
Beck's sending his Pawn down the ward
White's Rook on A2 is such an ideal
piece it's guarding the second rank and
it's supporting the pawn from behind
which is what you're taught to do he's
got a small decision to make
does he keep the Knight versus Bishop
imbalance or is he not afraid of the
bishop capturing the Knight 96 to me
looks tempting because it also hits the
pawn on C7
he should be able to carry this home
yeah I think if in doubt just keep the
night there will be opportunities later
to trade off the White Knight for the
black Bishop all Rook end games have a
Jewish tendency as well so once you know
that keep pieces on the board and I
think very good decision that that White
Knight has got influence actually on
both sides of the board which is rare
normally the bishop is the superior
piece but right now Black's Bishop Just
Hits thinner I don't see any kind of uh
answer any reply to just simply pushing
that white a pawn
it's uh inevitable almost that it's
going to land on the A6 or A7 squares
tying down the black Rook
Fabi yeah he's uh clinging on here by
the skin of his teeth but this Pawn
advancing should signal the end or the
beginning of the end of this game
what technique Abdus tour of has yeah
it's crazy I mean the technique when
he's informed I mean he'd be you know
that when he became World rapid Champion
Ray a youngest ever he beat I think
Magnus and yawn in the same tournament
like that's crazy to do that it's at age
two and also you know with confidence
and you know we see it now here too
playing Bobby as he's just clearly
winning it's clearly winning he's
pressing for more and this could be very
bad for five years he might be you know
almost in like a must when two and a
half wins match right so you lose this
game you need to not lose again or you
know you're out it's just really rough
yeah really rough and uh okay I was
gonna say what would you do now keep
pushing as far as you can go or just to
maintain control and up to Satora from
Rook C6 you mentioned that tournament
the way he became World rapid Champion
James not just did he beat Magnus Jan he
beat like aronia and gelfand oh my God
most of them were with the English
opening as white he was just there on a
storm and uh
crushed them all essentially and uh what
can you do against the teenager when
they're that Fearless it's scary it's
just uh facing them and look at it and
board one of the Uzbek team that scored
the shot gold medal at the Olympia I
mean this guy is ridiculous and he's not
even 20.
I mean
this guy's so fun to watch he's got the
technique and the Poise of all
capablanca right the Tactical ability of
a tall the guy is truly Universal right
as you said it and now we know it's not
an exaggeration to say that I'm excited
to see him in Norway chess but first I'm
excited to see him finish this game with
perhaps Knight D4 and then either Knight
B5 or Knight C6 after The Rook moves
away he's got many Rhodes uh leading to
Rome here yeah and the worst part for
Carolina here is that he's completely
stuck even if I've used Turf were to
take time out just move his King the
domination is not going anywhere yeah
he's just gonna bring his Rook up to
this I'm gonna go King G2 I think that
would be the capablanca approach King H1
just because I can yeah all pieces of
light squares the opponent has a DOT
Square Bishop
still improved position but if you've
got Rook B7 then Fabi takes goes Rogue
D1 check and Rook B1 zakaruana playing
to the last drop of blood so it's not
just over yet he goes back to D4 and I
like that approach as well very strong
move I mean just blocks the file your
Rooks are not active those are not Rooks
looks really rough for the Rooks there
on D7 and A7 all they're doing is
holding uh and we're under a minute here
so definitely going to see some time
pressure issues or mistakes that happen
in time pressure Rook to D6 do we trade
or not to trade that is the question he
says no
he says no if there is a trade of Rooks
White Knight will replace the white Rook
on C6 with even more effect
oh poor Fabi here just struggling to
survive the next few moves I think the
White Knight Will land on that square
almost no matter what now and that white
a pawn will become even stronger you can
trade off The Rook safely now on your
own terms you can maybe be a bit fancy
here if you want to be Daniel you have
an idea remind me yeah well I'm trying
to calculate Rook takes D6 Knight C6 A7
and then quickly get your Rook to B8
correct and I don't think black king is
in time I think that's precisely what
Notre back is taking the rest of his
time to calculate you mentioned fancy
he's even fancier this guy's on another
planet yeah yeah look at this a fork you
pretty much have to capture this white
Rook now's the black Rook the blockade
is eliminated and so accurate it's crazy
crazy stuff next move you just move the
Knight no matter where and you advance
yeah wow Knight C6 it's on the board he
gives up his Knight and this is
like yep all right oh my gosh 25 seconds
with five he could have all the time in
the world in this position and it
wouldn't help him and that is it he
resigns and nodded back up the satro of
takes the lead in his match against
Fabiano carrano with some great
technique that we've got action on on
this one but before we jump into it we
are going to get a quick update from
Ginger Jam Simon Williams with all the
action that's on in the other two
divisions Simon what's up yeah hi there
brilliant play by Naughty back there and
I'm not going to take too long but a
quick update on division two so they've
actually finished playing for the day
and in the winners bracket we know who's
going to go through to the semi-final
inching closer to their place in this
coveted division one so we had no win
beating his fellow Countryman Liam Lee
that was a bit of a shock and the next
person to go through was feder Sev we
saw that beautiful tactic against David
Anton of Spain and then our tattooed
friend from India said wani hope he
asked his mum about that tattoo beat
Alex senko and the final person to go
through to semi's is operin who won
against iliano so those four players
getting very close now to a place in the
main event uh but obviously there's a
lot of action going on so we should
probably go back there thank you so much
for keeping us on our toes on all the
chests that we're seeing in the other
two divisions we are seeing qualifiers
in that one and it is the big question
who goes through in the Winner's bracket
here and looking at what we've got
Jordan has played flawlessly after
surviving that opening scare those two
pawns C4 D4 that's going to decide the
game
yep
that's something I do in a bullet game
wait
ah these bonds yeah if black would have
pre-moved then the beep on just Queen
the sad thing is even if black would
have played Rook G2 she could still
winning but yeah gotta try it out at all
what a game what a comeback way Jordan
the guy just won't go down yeah that was
crazy I mean you you it was so hard to
navigate that but I guess like
especially with creative players and
like tactical players like you know
sometimes we just like mess and you can
just see through it but sometimes you
can't that was a crazy matchup right oh
my goodness great job for me 10 moves
into that opening I would have
definitely been flagged but of course
Jordan van Forest keeping his cool and
his composure there we saw him and he
does level the math score wow this was
so such a talking chess so much tactics
and resourceful play and David there's a
lot to pick from but what's the big
moment for you oh I just want to
highlight again in slow motion that one
moment that it slipped away for Dimitri
colors he played a great opening Jordan
taking some really
huge risks there but it was here just
trade the queens and white would obtain
a huge Advantage actually the computer
prefers even the flashy Queen to D2
maintaining the tension what a crazy
move with the idea that this Knight is
attacked and if you do trade the Queens
where I can simply take back with the
bishop white has full control here and
after winning this Pawn back would most
likely have a cruise to at least a draw
maybe even Victory instead a really
strange decision from Dimitri Collins
slipping his King forward one square and
allowing the same game the Queens came
off maybe he forgot that after Bishop
takes there is a nasty night Fork here
checking and hitting the Rook instead
Rook takes a loud domination of the two
Bishops Knight takes Bishop now black
simply pushed forward and this bishop
was Unleashed black with an extra Pawn
as well Jordan went on to win the game
there it is a big chested moment you've
got to keep the tension well not in life
but on the chessboard and it looked like
Dimitri kolas was doing that amazingly
well till a certain point and then it
went all wrong which means that the
match is level between Jordan and
Dimitri meanwhile nor the back of the
satra the 18 year old Uzbek Phenom the
youngest ever player to be the world a
rapid Champion the Olympic a gold
medalist has taken the lead in his match
against Fabiano caruana but Fabiano
caruana he is one of the best players in
the world so that match is far from over
but right now Fabi has to win a game to
level the match and for us right now we
are going to go into a shot twitch break
and we'll be back with more chess kid
action
[Music]
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kit is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
decisive results with kolars and Jordan
we've seen two decisive games and
meanwhile not a backup disadrov takes
his lead against Fabiano caruana Fabiano
starts the next game with the white
pieces Daniel Willie strike back I mean
the way no direct played that game he
just looks completely Unstoppable the
confidence with which he handles a wide
variety of positions and then the
Precision with which he converted that
end game he is making a big statement
before Norway chess but Fabi is known
for his opening preparation I think he
should play one E4 and stick to what he
knows best that'll give him the best
chances of striking back
Fast Five test will a Fabi go with wani
for whatever he does it is his final
white of the day the clocks are ticking
and we know what that means that we will
have the first few moves in just a
couple of seconds one can feel the heat
in this match naughty back up to such
Rob has made it look easy so far against
Fabi draw it black without too much
trouble winning with white in a
convincing manner showing great
technique there and of course in our
other matchup as well we've been seeing
great chess not a back picture or Focus
there wow this guy is definitely one to
watch out for and the one person who is
watching out for him right now is
Fabiano caruana he has to win a game to
level the match
Fabi with white 1e4 by Daniel James is
that what you're expecting as well
absolutely that's what he plays best
that's what he knows best and it's on
the board
out of French what is this epidemic
fridge this is anishikiri's Fault
establishing your chest so everything's
Denise Gary's fault publishing a
chessable course has just uh corrupted
the uh the chess players around the
world with the French defense okay wow
Harry the H4 James let's go let's go
yeah that's every time I see this type
of a chest I just get hyped because it
is aggressive H4 Heritage Pawn ideas are
very simple we just want to go and make
you uh make mistakes and go for me like
really what it is the queen G4 H5 Rook
H3 Rook G3 Rook F3 like all kind of just
push everything to that side of the
board and just go for mate now of course
black can just you know go the other way
Castle Queen side but it's very
aggressive and aggressive chess is a
very fun chess at the end of the day now
what do you make of this opening Choice
by Abdul satorov he's one point up in
the match he doesn't need to take huge
risks but this is a really really
double-edged opening Daniel listen I
know black scores pretty well in this
structure actually I tried the French
four times in my classical chess group
I'm oh and four wow and the most painful
game was against forget his name is
evading me some Grandmaster during the
2017 us Championship raviano carawan
they beat me in 26 moves in this exact
structure where I played an early C4 and
he just checked me at me on the king
side with a rook left Rook H3 Rook G3
that's pretty standard fare Rook h4o G4
obviously black has his own stuff going
on the other side of the board this
personally is not my cup of tea but
Notre back you said it whatever he plays
he studies really intensely he is not
one just to experiment with random stuff
lots of attacking possibility so wide on
the king's side so the big question for
nordeback will be where will he find his
King safety and very often it's at the
center of the board and sometimes even
looking at a queen side King march it
just looks you would be inviting
sacrifices on that eight six square the
8-6 pawn is now a hook which also
invites the Jeep on to advance down the
board if given an opportunity to strike
on the king side things can get super
tricky for noddyback if he does go shot
side castling is it a good idea for him
to keep the king in the center for the
time being oh absolutely not in fact
actually with this structure here the
reason why you go C4 a lot of times is
you actually can run to the queen side
you can Castle Queen side the bishop A4
is actually really nice too as well what
you can actually do really enough is
after you move the knight in you Castle
Queen side the queen goes to G8 and then
over to H7 it's a really strange
maneuver but that's how you attack the
C2 pawn and usually you have to go over
K2 there right it's really strange
things
the other end of the board
and will be in this one but also the
other game where we have seen two
decisive results so far Dimitri Kola is
taking the first game Jordan van first
taking the second game the result is
even Jordan starts with the white pieces
we've seen some creative crazy chess are
we expecting more of that and wow we've
got a slav with G3 yeah this is a pretty
decent line it can transpose into a
grundfeld if black plays G6 that's
fashionable but if you want to keep the
slav flavor typically Black Goes Bishop
F5 Bishop G4 also a very interesting
sideline so colors has a pretty wide
Choice here and he's going to take a
little bit of time to make the decision
so Jordan again kind of making us I
wouldn't call it a second rate move it's
not I think worse objectively than
Knight C3 but you know trying to play
something a little bit unexpected and
fresh
yeah and uh Magnus Carlsen himself has
been known to play this G3 line and of
course Jordan has worked with him very
famously so uh yeah not that big a
surprise perhaps although I haven't seen
Jordan play it himself too often and
Dimitri does grab a pawn at least
temporarily brings his Bishop out now
that black C4 Pawn is most likely going
to drop off later in the game but
Dimitri will hope that at least costs
white several moves uh to regain it and
now I'm expecting Jordan just to play in
Gambit staff just Castle the white king
and kind of postpone the tension
postpone the idea of grabbing that pawn
till a bit later in the game I don't
think black's going to be able to save
it long term uh interesting start and uh
I think the big question is what can
Dimitri recover from that devastating
loss in the last game
that's a great question yeah of course
uh if he can recover from that he'll be
fine here if he's still thinking about
it it will affect how you play here
never really a fan of this from the
black side because of uh you always
usually get the pawn back somehow white
always gets the pawn back in these in
these lines and then usually White's a
little bit better especially if we can
even get E4 into as well we do have the
two Pawns in the center 95 and E4 looks
annoying Knight H4 E4 well eventually we
get this Pawn by we have a nice you know
steam row sometimes in the center so it
does depend you have to play this
extremely accurately from the black size
you don't have a very much worse
position even being up a pawn
temporarily
bt7 and yeah your Den I very rarely see
him feeding the king so Bishop I've got
to say normally it's just direct go for
the kill go for mate but this is very
strategic stuff this is all for the kill
see is here but again
and uh yeah what do we expect from White
on this move Jordan's air quality is
still not great he needs to find some
great moves though not H4 do you think
of that one it's all about that today
absolutely grab the bishop I mean I like
weight all the way I mean you grabbing a
bishop here we still can't play E4 you
can play like imagine E4 and F4
happening here right now like you make a
move like castles I go E4 Bishop G6 and
then F4 now you may have Bishop H5 but
the fact that I have so much space there
is saying a lot
but really wants to start pushing in the
center those pawns and it's really not
about gaining the material back here for
Jordan the last thing on his mind is how
is he going to win the C4 Pawn back it's
about peace activity it is about space
about trying to build an attack get that
pawn storm rolling Knight H4 first asks
the big question to Dimitri what kind of
Pawn structure does he want is he okay
with the capture on F5 which would mean
a doubling up on the F line or does he
want to waste another Temple falling
back with the bishop uh on G6 but time
is of the essence and Dimitri is still
behind in development he decides to keep
the bishop pair Bishop G4 and we can
expect white to continue pursuing that
Bishop H3 G4
yeah that's pretty standard fare in in
this lava white was H3 Bishop H5 G4
Bishop G6 and the question is does white
want to weaken his King side in order to
Garner the bishop pair
um after G4 Bishop G6 white doesn't have
to rush with Knight takes G6 because at
that point the bishop is out of
retreating squares and you know Jordan
pauses you can understand why G4 is a
very committal move he can also delay
that move and play a positional move
like a2a4 or the queen can move up to C2
uh to enable the e-pawn to move forward
James your move F4 I've seen that kind
of move in this exact configuration that
would be very much suited to Jordan's
style as well
I think you should play F4 I don't know
why I have a feeling F4 let's go oh yeah
we fill in the ground for the kill come
on baby we feeling aggressive let's go
come on here close it out come on Jordan
Frankie have fun Frank all right that
was Freddie Freddie it's gotten into me
yep Felix I'm Freddie or Frank it would
be Felix
fund the F Bond well F4 is definitely
gonna be a lot of fun if it is on the
board Jordan's slowing down which Pawn
will he push G4 F4 or move the queen
looking at an epon advance down the
center of the board a big moment it's
the first time that actually in this
match Dimitri kolos has more time out of
the opening than your van Forest
yeah potentially very important as we've
seen Dimitri did Panic slightly in that
previous game when he was getting low on
the clock and it's uh yeah Jordan I
think he's paused at the right moment so
much choices you guys have been
highlighting so many different pawns to
push so many different plans attacking
ideas for white that's uh I think again
good tips for anyone at home once you
spot two or three different tempting
moves that's the moment to stop because
often that's your brain's way of telling
you that this is a critical moment if
you choose a bad plan it could backfire
and uh here multiple plans and not
necessarily a right or wrong answer it's
just Jordan choosing what he thinks will
suit his style the best
it is David as you mentioned about
Jordan's approach in this position and
the thing with Bond moves that we know
another
bonds don't move backwards we know that
so you have to be super careful with the
decision and wow there is another pawn
move what is it Benny The Bee Pawn well
there will be no Benny The Bee Pawn
because it's about to be captured there
might be Quentin the queen up to B3 I
was struggling to find a name that
starts with Q Quentin the queen queen
find a single other name that starts
with Q you're right it's like Quest
when Magnus gets angry he's Magnus
quarrelsome Carlson
that's too funny wow okay Bishop B4
developing hitting the Knight and some
quarrelsome play goes on as white
defense that night with Bishop D2 all
right we will step away from this for
just a moment and come back to see what
happens but right now let's zoom out and
take a look at the other game with
Fabiano caruana thrilling the and
there's so much that has happened one
thing that we did predict Black's King
has marched all the way down to the
queen side guys break this down what is
this crazy position the pawn structure
the king G2 King 87 what are those Rooks
doing on the f file what's going on here
lots of questions
that's always the question in the French
defense that's the problem what is going
on is the key question and most of the
time we don't know who we're guessing
and uh the player is guessing too I
think they're just putting their pieces
on squares they feel are promising
especially if the position does
eventually open up and they're hoping uh
hoping that things do open up in their
favor right now I would choose whites I
think just because I like my space I
don't feel that the black Bishop is
doing too much of a job now on A4 it's
not really participating in the rest of
the action but
if there's no breakthrough then
potentially black will be able to break
through against the white king
uh James help me out here cool yeah in
fact uh these are tough positions
because the whole Queen side is locked
down over there that's where the king is
but it's very hard to get to it in fact
I mean let's say we get to the Brooks
double just like hypothetically we get
them both Rooks on B1 and B2 it's still
not clear yet especially even this move
Knight A7 what I could play is actually
play B5 Pawn B5 and lock everything up
on that side and really just kind of
Shuffle or try to make my own uh um
counter play on the king side which you
we actually do have some stuff over
there this one is very hard I think for
honestly both sides I feel like black
can actually make a little bit of uh of
leeway on the king side we do have the
Bishops that are defending things but
how does white attack the king like it
is over there it looks strange but how
do we get to it is the question
ah Daniel is uh is this a threat Knight
B5 next move for white uh sorry for
black here just going after the a pawn
or uh does white have a way to counter
that I think it's time to ask the main
question again what is going on well if
white perceives it as a threat you can
maneuver the queen from D2 to B2 you
could play Queen C1 in order to meet
Knight B5 with Queen B2 so that's a more
defensive option but keeping the queen
closer to the king side also has a case
to be made for it because eventually
Fabi will probably want to prepare one
of these kingside Pawn breaks you do
Shake The Hornet's Nest when you play G5
or F5 and this is what these positions
are often all about can white properly
time one of these advances blackstrokes
are menacingly doubled on the FL they
are just waiting salivating for the
opportunity to prove their worth but the
bishop on E3 is also doing an important
defensive job covering the F2 square and
taking the sting out of those Rooks
should the f file open
yeah and uh okay interesting move by
Fabi Bishop F3 he's basically saying
okay I'm aiming towards your king
actually and Knight B5 very quickly met
by Rook A1 so he did indeed think that
there was a threat against this weak
isolated Pawn but now the black king
hiding nice and safe on A6 and while the
Kings uh if we talk about who's a safer
it's actually blacks you will never ever
ever in your life listen to me very
closely get to this king of Isaacs
there's no way I mean you're gonna have
to sacrifice a lot of material that's
all on the other side of the board it is
just very difficult and this looks
honestly practically better for black
the king is safer and we do have some
some uh tension on the f file stuff
could happen and this could definitely
backfire
yeah things open up it might well suit
black especially if White's got pieces
tied down like this Rook I really didn't
like that move but maybe it was
necessary and uh yeah Abdus
just works things in his favor every
time you know those articles like top 10
cities to ride out the apocal so the A6
would be at the top of the list
nothing's getting to that King dream
holiday destination Basics you can't
move anything this is a crazy position
where you you have to move you have to
obviously calculate correctly on the
king side of the board this one is
really hard I think for Fabi to be
honest let's figure this one out wow so
fabi's Rook on A1 tied down to the A3
Pawn the queen on D2 tied down to the C2
Pawn the rest of the pieces completely
jammed on the king side have to make
sure that Fabi doesn't get a good uh F
takes E5 a trade in the center opening
up the F line so it just looks like Fabi
has to sit and wait ideas like G5 and F5
seem extremely far-fetched because
you're just creating more weaknesses on
the king side and let's say Fabi just
decides to make waiting moves here Rook
H3 Rook G3 how does black break into
White's position because it feels as if
nautiback has done everything right
pieces are placed super well for that
big blow but where is it well that's why
these games often and in the draw why
please work HD Rick G3 black quiz night
C7 B5 C7 or queen C8 D7 C8 and the owner
is definitely on Fabby to try to make
one of these Pawn bricks work because
Notre bag has got a one point lead no
Rebecca's chilling he's more than happy
to take a draw in this very position
he's got white in the last round yeah
and he's pretty easy to be with white so
with the black that is no big deal wow
David tough one for Fabi exactly uh and
it's no coincidence that Fabi is
spending a couple of minutes there and
he does decide to take a risk with his
last white of uh these four rapid games
and wow taking that pawn yeah James you
don't get a good feeling about that
gross it feels gross because I mean
black has just you have even the engine
agrees too you have options you also
have Pawn breaks at some point but I
guess his argument is if you ever try to
push something you're going to open
things up for me so I think that's what
he's looking forward to the question is
how does he take an order back is
calculating that now and if you take
what The Rook E5 is extremely weak but
how do we get the Knight there maybe
back it up it should be two Knight f395
we could get a very strong Knight there
um if Pawn takes I wonder what happens
on Pawn takes yeah the problem here
maybe black can back it up as well and
jump into a nice Outpost the D6 square
has been freed up by White's last
capture uh you mentioned porn takes as
well equally tempting because now it's
more likely you'll be able to break in
the center maybe shift your Rooks across
towards the white king but uh what are
the downsides here maybe this Pawn is
weak well he takes it with a rock takes
with the Rook doesn't want to create
that eight six weakness David that you
were pointing out and Savvy quickly
sidesteps with the King and now the
Black Knight could centralize itself on
D6 uh it just looks with this trade on
F6 black should be super happy because
he's got more to play for
yeah more to play for and again white
pieces are stuck tied down the queen
still tied down to this one as you
mentioned Tanya the bishop now is the
one tied down to holding this Central
post if the black knight ever Creeps in
it's going to be disaster uh really
looking good for I'll do a tutorial
right now and even if it creeps in while
the Bishop is on F3 after the trade may
seem like black is ruining as Palm
Street is garnering that D5 post for his
Knight that is a sweet Square for the
pony and Fabi this is what we talked
about right you choose the wrong moment
to break through on the king side and
you cause a lot more problems than you
had but you can understand fabi's
decision making Queen D6 instead is not
her Beck's choice I think that's fine as
well he's in control of this game
he's in control and he's also hinting
that at some point he might even
sacrifice The Exchange just to break
through towards the white king yeah
really nice Play Time Advantage as well
for black Fabby dropping back his Bishop
trying to curl up now he's trying to
make a safe haven for the white king
it's never going to be as safe as the
black king but uh interesting still very
tense so still Anything Could Happen
from this point and the one thing that
another bag has to be careful about is
not to get greedy with that a pawn at
that pawn on the edge of the board you
don't want to open up the a file you
don't want to give your opponent counter
play if black was to go with that Knight
capture the a pawn notice how the Knight
and the bishop are all lined up on that
same file white would fall back with the
queen hit that Knight on E3 and win that
Bishop on A4 but wow none of that David
big action nodded back with an exchange
sacrifice yeah he did actually sacrifice
this change I thought he was bluffing I
thought he was just uh teasing the
opponent but he's gone for it what do we
think of this yeah I thought it was a
bluff too because I was like well how do
you follow up I mean yeah you got to
exchange that but what you gonna do now
E5 maybe but then you open the e-file
and last I checked why it has two Rooks
and black is one that's a good counting
right so like here definitely something
to pay attention to what do you even do
with the Knight on E7 here I don't know
maybe he's just going for it that was a
big risk there definitely for sure yeah
you kind of want to move this Knight out
the way now drop the bishop back and
somehow open things up towards the white
king but it takes so long yeah I don't
think you're in time and your material
down now you are a rook uh for a minor
piece down
black
s the stretch more difficult
it wasn't a premature decision to give
up that exchange I think he missed King
H3 specifically because if the king had
gone the other way there was a
discovered attack with Rook takes D4 and
then you would have had two maybe even
three pawns for the exchange now if
Abby's King is the safest it's been in a
while but Knight G8 I think is excellent
it adds some oil to the fire speaking of
oil to the fire white is first to the
party with Knight to G6 and now things
are getting really crazy just I've got
to mention the Symmetry I think Fabiano
loved Abdul satoro's King much so much
King to A6 he was like okay how can I
copy that a mirror image I'm gonna put
my king on H3 and he's walked his King
over to the safe uh H3 Square yeah again
don't try to home anyone I would never
dare but uh these guys getting away with
it so far who's King is weaker I think
this is the only game that I've seen
where white king is on H3 and black
kings are in A6 it's the only game
you'll ever see Tanya with this King
configuration
too much on all right the night has
landed on E5 definitely an improvement
there from that H4 Square black falls
back with the Rook on f8 and now it just
feels like the momentum is Shifting
James and Fabi is in driver's seat
definitely you can feel the momentum
shift here I think he is definitely
feeling better I mean he got to exchange
we are up in exchange here this looks
really good for white I mean practically
speaking we can't probably play G5 at
some point my king is very safe over
there and my Rook defends C3 I don't
care about the a pawn at all so G5 maybe
we take and end up hitting G7 we also
have a plus H Pawn ourselves but I don't
think he's gonna take it if he does if
he does take it obviously we get the G
Pawn if he doesn't take it then maybe we
could play you know taking ourselves and
try to get something to the seventh or
even the sixth rank um there it is G5
and we live Fabi
are you guys surprised the evaluation
bar it's just bang in the middle still
it's not reacting despite the fact that
we're starting to love white come on
David it's obviously that equal what is
there able to talk about here balanced
position sorry Daniel I should have
known this is the very picture of
equality that's a great question though
right White's got this extra exchange
and we're talking about momentum shift
how do you explain that eval bar is
still giving this Dynamic well there's a
good chess expression which is overused
a little bit Dynamic equality it means
the position is imbalanced but both
sides have exciting chances that
approximately counterbalance each other
but there's a big asterisk there that's
with best play when you've got a
position like this you know that things
can swing in one or the other direction
with a single mistake and Bishop F3 that
probably was not a mistake Knight D7
here is a tempting way to try to pry
that Knight away from the E5 square but
the tension is at an all-time high
oh my gosh
well I like it down there just try and
get rid of White's best piece makes a
lot of sense if you don't act quickly
then this Pawn is simply going to drop
and actually it's the H Pawn that will
decide the game they'll make Simon very
happy if Harry becomes Harriet at the
end of this game in Queens
but Knight D7 you'll move on the board
and suddenly watch out for this loose
Bishop
Anything could happen here still at
Bishop G4
[Music]
can't afford a repetition here he has to
create his chances he's the one who's
trailing the match and it is here's a
final white after Knight F6 is there
another week and white just get greedy
and pick up the G7 Pawn wow we had a
tree wow and start a trade on E5
trade and rooked F6 this feels a bit odd
what's the idea is he gonna drop his
Queen back and maybe try to break
through on the f file
at some point I really want to get this
white Rook back into the game the
problem is this Pawn will drop at the
moment that white Rook moves so still
very tense I'm starting to like white
but yeah Abby can he do it can he clinch
this game
big big moment now the next few moves it
feels like it'll be decided there
and he is slightly up on the clock as
well this is his chance to level the
match he's up in exchange but again it
surprises us all that how the eval bar
still is somewhere around the equal Mark
Rook F6 has been played and I think it
also comes down to that Rook on A1 he's
an exchanger but for the time being Fabi
is playing without that Rook on A1 it's
tied down to defending that A3 pawn and
as long as that Rook doesn't come into
play it's going to be hard to make a use
of that extra exchange might be time to
actually do that rookie one yeah he's
played a great call Tanya now the three
Pawn is irrelevant if black grabs it and
even if the Queen's coming off the board
don't sleep on that A5 Pawn the path for
it forward to become Harriet Anna
um what's the male name that starts with
the name Alex becomes Anna uh that pawn
can promote to A1 Alex becomes Alexa
Alexander there we go
bang what else needs to be said wow so
are you rooting for taking this porn uh
Daniel or are you going to go passive
and drop the Knight back to defend two
very different approaches here I think
the latter so my intuition just says
that G7 Pawn can be picked off as well
and he does take on A3 let's go oh here
we go didn't like it Eric the evil bar
everybody it's a race now white is going
to take this Pawn I assume with the rook
and uh White Once you get this Pawn is
very quick to run forward with Harry
here it does feel like actually for the
first time in the game this black king
not entirely safe watch out for some
nasty sneak attacks around the back from
this bishop
I'm starting to think actually Fabi is
going to finish this game with some
tactics all right so I feel that the A6
King is going to be broken into how did
he get to me yeah it's like you're on
holiday and someone breaks into the room
and says okay I got you I got you worst
nightmare how does this happen we're up
on the match by an entire point and that
sacrifice on F4 even if it maintains the
balance it's definitely a decision that
requires a lot of Bravery a lot of
Courage but perhaps wasn't the most
practical way for not a back to play
given the math situation E6 spawn has
been picked up and after The Rook trade
Bishop E6 will threaten a check on C8
and also the D5 Pawn is it time for
black to think about a queen trade
picking up the C3 Pawn
trade queens start dreaming about
marching down the board with the Apon
yeah
definitely on his mind up to his tour
but if you trade Queens it's going to
become a Pure race whose pawns are going
to be quicker and you've got to be very
very sure about your calculation before
you embark on anything like that it
feels like abdulf not just as he lost
control but now he's running out of time
to calculate
at least finding a way to survive is the
first step but it's not easy to even do
that
did you see it I think he's a little
frustrated we saw a little bit of uh
just refocused area to reposition and
focus again here lots of times you can
understand you can kind of see he
understands this is very very important
right now maybe we just Queen f8 that's
strange yeah you're gonna have to go hmm
you're gonna have to just go for it what
do you think Diane what's your idea
maybe Rook takes C6 and then Queen f8 to
try to access F1 it's smells of
desperation but I think notrex initial
idea was to take on C3 with the queen
but upon closer inspection he realizes
that G7 Pawn is too weak Bishop C8 is a
potential mate threat that he might have
underestimated I'd go for something like
this just practically speaking oh happy
takes up the bishop yeah I like it I've
got to mention this bishop C8
potentially a huge threat also the D5
Pawn oh yeah oh we might say Queen off
right now because if you pick up Bishop
D5 that's Queen F5 check picking up the
bishop and queen f8 also defends against
Bishop C8 yeah I think he has to go for
this uh nice geometry there uh Queen f8
potentially one of the only moves to
survive but maybe the king I don't know
maybe you'll Shuffle across no checks
king the kings today yeah they're really
it's still up for grabs this game it's
anyone's game and we see the eval bar
should creep up for Fabiano caruana but
this is far from over it's a crazy
position and with a white skin in the
open Anything Can Happen the only
problem for noribbeck is that the minor
pieces are on the other side of the
board imagine bishop and Knight you're
my you you're able to get them on the
king side and we'd be singing a
different tune here
very different tune but uh problem is
your pieces are stuck where you put them
you've committed to that and Abdul
satorov
I fear for him in this game and if he
loses this remember vikan Zay and Tata
steel he lost the last round when he
only needed a draw here he's ahead again
playing really creative chess it's
backfiring could those demons come back
to haunt him he's gonna start thinking
now I should have played it safe I
shouldn't have played the French I
shouldn't have gone for these crazy
tactics shouldn't have gone for that
exchange sacrifice he was still in
control there the big one was the
exchange sacrifice I mean really if you
I mean going back if he didn't add an
exchange sacrifice in there it would
have been just a different game Queen C3
takes takes worked you won wow he goes
Bishop C8 check first oh that is a knife
because if King A7 there's a seventh
ring check if you go to B5 that's like
the worst Square on the board who goes
from the safest Square to the most
dangerous Square you might have to
because King A7 rookie seven looks like
you're just losing that g keep on with
Tempo and the H Pawn is definitely gonna
be Harriet yes and the bishop can slide
back to F5 and keep blacks Bishop at Bay
no this is
looking like disaster yeah you've got to
pick your poison here you know you're
probably crashing to defeat for uh by
update and he just needs to try and give
Fabi some practical problems I agree
with you Tanya just bring the king
forward if in doubt it's always just a
good practical uh try to confuse the
opponent bringing the Kings far forward
as possible retreating never scares uh
the opponent that much and also the
black king retreating to the corner is
not going to be safe anyway just advance
and hope for the best it's most likely
hopeless but best bet and he goes for it
just calculated the whole line while
nordeback was having a thing oh you're
gonna have to relax big fella what is
that movie what what the heck is this
what is that confusing your opponent
desperation here he's trying to block
the white Rooks path to that g-pawn but
I like it I think he wants he's banking
on his Queen side those passers in time
pressure are very hard to stop King C3
and then B5 it's super far-fetched but
I've seen crazier things than this he
might even give up his night for the H
Pawn and in the right circumstances the
B A pawns could overwhelm the rook and
Bishop it's very unlikely though wow
Daniel that Bishop could have been
picked up by the king or the Knight this
is a move of a genius Knight E4 is
unreal stuff you know what they say
about the line between genius and lunacy
it's pretty thin I don't know which side
of the spectrum This falls on Wow Knight
E4 that is that's insane stuff and we
see the eval bar still says that Fabi is
winning but it's definitely thrown him
off he slowed down it's not a move that
anyone in the world could have expected
does he save that bishop or does he go
for the Jeep on with Rook G1 that's a
great Quest save the bishop why not yeah
two pieces and just to show why he
played this uh crazy genius move on the
last turn if the black king had captured
then simply The Rook comes up the board
to E7 nothing to do this Pawn is simply
going to be captured one two three Queen
Harriet appears on the board so uh why
not slow down the opponent Knight E4 I
think Rook G1 Tanya is the idea to meet
it with Knight coming back just to
eliminate this Pawn at any cost and then
Place switches purely to the other flank
white has an extra Rook but black has
pawns uh so okay he does save things and
the Black Knight goes back anyway so
this Pawn about to come off the board
the king's gonna Advance still some work
to be done
he's Upper Rock now and the A5 B65 is
still a little far away or are you just
gonna start marching down with your king
king C3 pick up more pawns but it looks
like it's going to be too slow Rook g1's
coming in g7's falling apart this has
got to be a game over yeah A4 could be
met with B1 white is under no obligation
to use the Rook to win G7 you could also
use it to mop up some of the queen side
pawns yeah this is a good attempt I you
know Valiant effort by notorbeck but
fabi's got way too much time for this to
truly scare him you know it's a really
classy move by Fabi just advancing his
King protecting his h-borne he knows
that that YH Pawn is going to tie down
the Black Knight forever another classy
move threatening to take that black
knight and run through with the H Pawn
that might be dagger look F6 a big
thread on the board the H Pawn will be a
queening and he gives up the Knight
picks up the pawn that's a rook and
Bishop now can I get this off the screen
bro I'm down two pieces what's going on
this is not an instructive moment for
chess kids of the word
if you ever need to know when to resign
it might be might be around now we
normally don't recommend it but this one
should be hopeless David no one ever won
a game by resigning yeah
I don't think he's gonna win this one
anyway unfortunately they're fine and it
looks like Fabiano caruana will be
leveling this match not the back of the
such Rob he knows it's all over but he
did have it under control it wasn't even
the opening he played he did everything
right but just rushed with that exchange
sacrifice and after that Fabi showing
his skills the D5 Pawn Falls we are
expecting resignation any moment he's up
on the clock wow that means we will set
ourselves up for a big game four as the
match will be leveled out he's going for
the C2 Pawn not a bad he's a fighter
it's an absolute fighter
even in a dead lost position there's
nothing to fight with he's about to run
out of bonds yeah work out three
checking plus his username I think with
jess.com Uzbek fighter he's fighting on
he's uh keeping going
respect Warrior that's it uh how dare
you can use fighter and Warrior David
it's such a big difference
those big Fighters probably like
they're all fighters that's for sure the
eighth one's coming will fapi get
nervous
oh man this one is uh he's trying to
find the most precise way
[Music]
which means Dimitri will have to win the
final rapid game to level the match
right now it is all eyes on this one as
not the back's only hope is Alex the
Apon it is trying to March down the
board but with the rook and Bishop down
this is actually just insane stuff I
haven't seen a player fight this kind of
an ending at that level I have to say
David are you surprised
um I was surprised a few moments ago now
I'm thinking okay I spoke too soon
commentators curse suddenly there are
traps I'm looking uh at a couple of
moves for Fabi first move I just want to
give a check with the white Rook Force
the black king to commit I think this
was strongest but other moves well maybe
less clear and now the black king has to
protect the C4 Pawn you cannot let that
one drop so I'm expecting it to go back
to B4 and uh still there we go still the
a pawn running some work to be done but
after E3 you can always give up that
Bishop for the C pawn and when black
skin captures the bishop The Rook will
pick up the A3 Pawn so everything's
under control the B5 B5 first five first
and White's King is really far away so
like I mean they're still a little iota
of hope you're right
know what the fastest way to win here is
maybe Rook F1 to B1
if not a back survives this game I've
seen everything
two pieces down here right if he
survives and this is a draw Bobby's
gonna be hurt that's gonna be a that's a
psych that's a psych part there that
you're gonna have to get over very
quickly because there's still match left
both players down to
two yeah when we entered this end game
with white having an extra rook and an
extra Bishop Fabi had almost four
minutes so he's burnt most of his clock
already he better find a win now
otherwise the Panic will be setting in
and okay he does go with uh you'll move
that down you're retreating the white
Rook aiming to check from the front and
David you can see the tension on fabi's
face I think he also expected this to be
game over for not about to just resign
at any moment but the resistance that
naughty back is putting up zombies
feeling attention right now you off his
head
he's still like he's still inflicting
pain okay but if having just a couple
couple accurate moves away but B4 and A3
those pawns Alex might still become
Alexander there and before now oh my
gosh this is crazy bro Rook A1
a3c3
yeah I think black just can't make
progress past A3
yeah you're stuck with black
but this is amazing stuff by Naughty bag
I mean regardless of how this ends the
fact that he found this resource Knight
E4 marching down the board fearlessly
with G5
it's on the board deflection why not
distract the opponent throw it
everything at him throw everything at
him Pawns of the soul of Chess that's
what we're that's what we're taught
that's all he's got chat says sack the
king he doing everything sacrifice the
king I understand
okay this should be the killer blow now
there's Pawn's dropping with game of
time you can't push the beep on and
that's the problem in Black's position
with that Bishop on F7 don't pick up the
G4 Pawn just yet then that should be a
rezzy
hobby smiling as well it did take some
work I think this is in a long time a
position that Fabi had to win being up a
rook being upper Bishop it's not a task
that he's put to every day but not if I
got this outro showing some amazing
defensive ideas there oh wow what an
incredible round it has been with both
the matches ending decisively Jordan van
Forest takes a win Fabi takes a win
David what is the big takeaway well so
many takeaways from that round most of
all that the players love Fighting Chess
they love decisive games but I just
wanted to show how the other game
wrapped up Jordan winning that one
against Dimitri colas white here Jordan
van Forest had two dominant passports
pawns have been the theme of this round
and he clinched this game in really nice
fashion he played the move Queen to C7
eliminating the pawn blockader the black
queen and after this trade he had
spotted this really cunning move just
when it looks like his pawns are falling
he'd spotted he could come back slide
back with Rook D2 now if one is captured
there'll be a nasty check costing black
his bishop and one more move was not a
not sufficient to save the game Bishop
D7 the final killer blow here and uh
White now about to win the black Rook
with the nasty check great technique
from Jordan van Forrest
really nice stuff there David and once
again for all the chess kids out there
always be on the lookout for these super
critical moments and when you want to
trade your pieces when you want to offer
those exchanges often they decide the
result and speaking of the results this
is our score line going into the final
rapid game of the winner semi-final
bracket Garden van Forest lost the first
game and now he's the one who's taken
the lead in his match Dimitri kolas has
to win on demand to force an Armageddon
meanwhile Fabiano caruana also strikes
right back in game three leveling his
match both these matches going to be
super exciting either of them could go
into an Armageddon but before we get to
round four chess kid action we're gonna
take a quick shot break
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
do you love following chess.com events
and want to join the team
are you a passionate chess fan with
experience in organizing events and
tournaments you might be exactly who
we're looking for to come on board as an
eventual coordinator use command apply
in chat or go to go.chess.com events
underscore coordinator underscore apply
to submit your application now
[Music]
thank you
today
[Music]
do you love chess events and want to
help growthegame with chess.com do you
want to be part of the team that makes
tournaments like the chess kid cup of
reality we're looking for a driven chess
fan with experience in organizing gaming
events to come on board as the Director
of event operations use command apply in
chat to submit your application now
foreign
Focus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space
shifting your state with every breath
find your air of clarity now
[Music]
[Applause]
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever from the
heroes we admire to the joy of watching
them play
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game boom forever faster
welcome back everyone we've got a big
final rapid round coming up in division
one but we also had a Roundup of the day
in the other two divisions Simon what's
the big news of the day
um well we've got loads of action we're
just going to bring up the results very
shortly but I've been listening to
Daniel's puns and I've been loving them
a lot and I sort of came up one so the
big news of the day is that Nakamura is
now Naka no more uh
okay I'll see you later guys all right
okay and uh back to okay division two
let's get on with it now so sorry about
that it's time to throw that in this are
the players who have gone through to the
next round and you can see that um well
a lot of favorites gone through there
and again we've got our tattooed friend
go through Vladimir felicev and the
losers
um have to fight harder to get through
to the semi-final Dimitri adriatkin
um has managed to come through Tung Lee
Shaq mamajarov and goog Meyer as well so
there's a lot of action going on there
and of course they're trying to qualify
for the first Division and then they get
to play all these Legends of the game
and there's loads of prize money and
it's it's the big stage isn't it there
ten thousand dollars for the winner of
division two as well as the big ticket
into division one of the next Champions
chess store event and assignment before
we head to the round for Action I have
to ask you we've been talking so much
about the incredible Pawn action that
we've been seeing with Pawn storm down
the board now it's Harry the H Bond Gary
the jupon Freddy the F Pawn but you've
got to take us through all of them how
does it work right so you've got Harry
the H Pawn you've got Gary because
Gary's good friend of mine Freddy
because Nightmare on Elm Street had
Freddie right he's quite scary Eddie
Eddie the eagle Edwards the ski jumper
uh you've got D Derek I don't know why
Derek that's just a sad name see Charlie
after my cat B Bertie I don't know why
and a Harry Ari like Harry but Harry
Harry the apron so there we go that's
that's the names of the Pawns in case
you're wondering now we're not uh Simon
thanks for settling that because that
was a big debate that we had going on
and we were looking more of those Pawn
Stars down the board now we know exactly
how to call them Simon it's been a fun
day of Chess do you think we're going to
see an Armageddon I think so I think
it's been a long day very exciting day
and I expect we're going to get an
Armageddon coming up because uh you know
it's it's gonna happen with two games
going on uh but let's also just have a
look at division three as well I guess
just see very quickly what's going on
there because there's been so much
action happening there Sam Savion uh
didn't go through that he lost Alan
pitcho very good player has won that one
and uh well other results I think it's
worth pointing out Dennis lazovic this
young player
um has had a fantastic run so far and we
just want to keep you up to date with
these because this is your run up
obviously to division one this is
exciting you can qualify online through
this the top players and they got these
things in Gold to aim for Dave Navara
still in good to see that everyone loves
David and the legend get a camp ski if
you don't know what I'm talking about
there well worth Googling
and you yangy one of the strongest
Chinese players is
um going to be there in the next round
Donna chenko a bit of a Legend
um and this is the the losers round
three and uh finally the winners
semi-final pitcho versus bonusky and
Harry Krishna versus lazovic and you see
that picture and Harry Krishna are the
two players there who have guaranteed
their place and got through to the next
round and there was a lot of games going
on and it is even a bit confusing for me
but that's because there's so many great
players
that is what makes the Champions Chester
a season so exciting we've got three
division with big names big action Simon
thank you so much for that big update
and for now of course
the big news is the big fourth game
coming up in the winners bracket and for
Dimitri colas it has been his eight
decisive game but right now against
Jordan van Forest he needs to win on
demand to force an Armageddon meanwhile
that was some incredible play by Fabiano
caruana to level the match yeah it
really was and things were not going his
way out of the opening abusator I've had
everything under control but you give
these super GMS one little chance
they're going to pounds Fabi keeping his
composure at the end of the game despite
some heroic resistance by uh the Uzbek
Grandmaster it's all down to this
scintillating fourth game
and the clocks are ticking we will have
left off in just a few seconds and
before that happens uh Paul Armageddon
yes or no
it's a long day for them playing you
know I think more mistakes happen I'm
gonna say no wow both the games decided
okay wow David I'll say yes in Carolina
again I'd love to see that I'm gonna say
yes and colors and Forest just to be
different even though that's the least
likely of all the scenarios I'm gonna
say two armageddon's we've covered all
ground here and there we've got it back
up this outro starting with the white
pieces this is the final fourth rapid
game and result in both the matches our
diet he starts with a 1d4 are we gonna
see a Queen's Gambit declined
actually we saw this strange hybrid
between the uh nimzoo Indian and the
Catalan in the previous clash between
these two when abdusator of had the
white pieces of course he went on to win
that game this time it's a pure Catalan
and uh okay has he got a Twist a turn on
this one he plays Queen 33 he's played
this before
interesting but rare move normally White
Castles in that position what do you
think of this one
yeah same kind of thing you did in the
last white game right just making a
slightly offbeat move and Abby
not really caught off guard B6 happens
pretty quickly and he might even play
Bishop Ace Bishop A6 here it's kind of a
funny looking intermediate yeah I like
that I like that I like that it can you
know the B6 move was very cool I mean
try Bishop A6 and back to kind of
Queen's Indian like there's no pre-move
cat short castle if you're white right
yeah don't remove it that would suck
yeah he's not the type to pre-move and
okay he does take the board Fabi now in
the sense with his Knight well it does
indeed get away with castling but the
White Queen might well get harassed
watch out for that black light Square
Bishop to come out and kick her away I'm
slightly surprised I've got to say at
fabi's decision to take back in the
center with the Knights he lacks
influence now in the center white at
some point might be able to establish
like a nice Pawn Center there but he's
arguing that he will be in time Fabby to
strike at White Center uh maybe with the
move C5 white has that extra central
port now on D4 looks nice and beautiful
but if you can eliminate it trade it off
then play will be very much balanced so
Abdu sator of Knight C3
for
both players so far
hmm now what would we do here trade that
night or keep the tension I'm keeping it
there's a common trap here that exists
on a lot of these lines where you play
Knight takes C3 and this move doesn't
work in direct response to Knight takes
C3 but after BC white is actually
threatening Knight G5 good thing for
newer players to know so if I don't know
yeah H6 oh I'm stopping Knight G5 no
you're actually enabling it doesn't
matter how many times you defend that
square the problem is on the other side
of the board it's the bishop on B7
that's undefended and with it falls The
Rook in the corner so even strong strong
players have fallen for this time yeah
you gotta watch out for that tactical
trick there right now he is deciding
whether to trade on a C3 or not and as
Fabi has this thing we also have action
that is about to kick off in our second
game in the winners bracket all three
have ended decisively in this match
Dimitri goulos took the first win took
the lead and then we've been seeing back
to back wins by Jordan and are we gonna
see an Italian or a Berlin with a
Spanish
Jordan doesn't pay the Berlin ever I
think
um
he never plays it and then plays it yeah
yeah
it is the Auntie Berlin David yep Jordan
is ahead in the match so we can forgive
him just this once trying to play the
Berlin trying to force a draw or trying
to at least play solid and uh Dimitri of
course saying okay no end games for you
no forcing lines he's going to play the
Antebellum which which means all pieces
on the board or at least as many as
possible black now Jordan trying to
trade off pieces trying to swap off a
pair of knights whoa why does God greedy
grab the point that's gonna be a fun
Berlin so 95 what's the line here you're
giving up a pawn and how do you get your
compensation do you pick up that Bishop
on B5
do you have the option you could also
make an argument for just castling the
black king and prolonging the tension
white will lose a few Tempe later on
often you just play D6 just kick that
white knight back and uh Black's pieces
Sprint to life but first okay gaining
time against the white Bishop
and uh okay will he strike in the center
now Jordan both players very well
prepared blitzing up to this point
what do you think if this was to go into
an Armageddon would we have a favorite
in this one
it depends on who gets black whoever
gets black and that is and how much time
how much time they pay for correct yep
because they mean they're both ferocious
players here I mean it's very we see
nothing but strong chests from these
guys I mean people would first think if
you're just coming in and watching like
oh is this the loser's bracket like no
these guys be some top dogs to get here
right so it definitely could be
anybody's game in that and then
Armageddon for sure
like what is this capsules yeah castles
just get developed just go for the
attack that's what Jordan wants to do
but uh he's also got in the back of his
mind that a drawer is enough uh he's a
pawn down however I was also going to
mention these players they're at the
exact same age they know each other
extremely well there's a bit of rivalry
between the Netherlands and Germany uh
so yeah a bit of Mind Games here at this
early stage but uh yeah clearly having
predicted this Dimitri College
impressive stuff might support up black
has the burden of proving compensation
yeah with Jordan every single day I
would predict a sicilian would like but
the fact that he was happy to go into a
Berlin just gives the feeling that he's
happy to take this into uh the
Armageddon if it comes down to it but
right now this is quite a feisty version
of the Berlin so rookie eight you're
down upon but you're playing for peace
activity for compensation you don't want
to allow Bishop to G4 so night Retreat
would have uh invited black to pin that
Knight on F3
wow B5 that shows that Jordan is
prepared he has looked at this before
you don't enter a position and pawn down
when you only need a draw if you're
going uh yeah and then suddenly play a
move like B5 without deep deep computer
preparation suddenly alarm Bells must be
ringing for Dimitri colors Jordan
it's famous as the second he's famous as
an opening analyst he's uh yeah come up
with some crazy ideas B5 I need to start
studying this chess a bit more but
especially in this opening inspired by
Magnus Carlson's polish yeah uh defense
with a couple moves in between I'd be
terrified to be white here without crazy
preparation because the Knight on E5 is
on an island and it's got no way back to
the mainland because Knight F3 is always
going to be met with Bishop G4 if you
play H3 then you're weakening the king
side and there's a lot of tactics Bishop
C5 back to D6 everything's hanging in
the center
B5 what a freaking move right what a
move bro maybe you go uh maybe you allow
B4 but he might be going A5 and he's
grabbing more space I mean you can't
even move the Knight to E2 that just
seems like a disaster it seems like
maybe you could get away with it yeah
and just like no this is a disaster move
but the fact what's the what's the even
the sequence there this would be anyway
oh my goodness look at that move yeah it
takes there's a nasty check black will
win a piece throw oh scary stuff but he
does play rookie one very sensible
looking move and now what next for
Jordan do you keep pumping pawns forward
on this side of the board
makes sense to me and I wonder what that
move rookie won he does defend the
Knight on E5 does he want to activate
his own Bishop to G5 next targeting that
D5 weakness
hidden win Tanya makes sense could be a
threat how does Jordan guard against
this it's not ideal at least to push
report now to H6 evaluation bot doesn't
react but it does not look like a
logical move to me head spinning
so A5 could be met by Bishop G5 right
now not that easy for black for Jordan
to advance in on the queen side in this
position currently wow rookie one tricky
moment here for the metric for Jordan
One Forest will he play at six I kind of
like the move you just take away white
threat
yeah actually maybe it is that simple
Tanya you see your opponent's threat
you're aware of that and you've react uh
kind of preemptively that's what the top
players do but here it doesn't feel like
the essence of the position is just
playing slow moves with black you are a
pawn down
maybe it's just the fact that the uh
kind of position is so tense on the
queen side that you don't there it is
you don't touch anything there it is on
the board I was trying to show that move
as what not to do don't play slowly when
you're reporting down but this is one of
those uh rare exceptions
two maybe I mean maybe white kind of
does the same sort of thing just a
regular improving move you know two can
play at that game maybe H3 yeah
yeah loose pieces drop off that Bishop
was loose undefended so he Retreats it
to a nice safe square but now watch out
for the other white Bishop the light
squared Bishop massive threat to trap it
right now how do we react
we gotta push A3 or A4 is the question
maybe just go A3 is B4 you take and then
Bishop's probably misplaced on before at
least you have to move it again A4
allows B4 but he plays it anyway maybe
we go Knight B5 or Knight A2 I mean are
you going back to E2 Bishop G4 still is
a thing you're not going Knight A2 out
yeah you want to do this but B4 is
definitely the possibility
yeah can he sack is there something with
Knight D5 there 95 Queen H5 whoa what is
going on actually I'm not sure if it
works because uh there is the idea of
flicking this in at some point maybe now
on the next move Queen H5 James wow I'm
really going for it yeah well there's
Bishops yeah you just chill it should be
six too much so the idea I guess is in
this position to jump forward at least
you say okay you can get rid of my
strong Bishop ruin my Pawn structure but
I am left with a nice Knight on an
outpost actually two very nice strong
lights now for white but if you take the
other piece in this position then white
will be pulled up for a long long time
pass Pawn as well to boot
I'm liking it for white I've got to say
Jordan every time I see him play he's a
pawn down half the time it's fine he has
compensation here I'm not so sure crazy
positions
crazy position indeed big decision for
Jordan
and uh yeah I've got to say I like what
Dimitri's done he's asking big questions
he's got something to kind of cling on
to an extra Pawn even if you have to
suffer a bit you have something
long-term to look forward to and in a
must win situation you can't ask for
more really so a successful white I
think that's opening and David that's
such a key point in these time formats
with little time to counter your
opponent's idea even if you don't find
objectively the strongest move but just
forcing your opponent to things to burn
the clock and as a speed chat specialist
Daniel isn't that a really key point to
get strong and to get those wins in just
to force your opponent to think rather
than just finding the best moves all the
time yeah it really is and even with
this time control from Spectators
perspective we're so used to watching 30
second chess one minute chess 15 minutes
sounds like an eternity but trust me
when you're sitting there and you're
contemplating a critical moment seven
minutes disappears literally in the
blink of an eye you could be calculating
one line so it's this disconnect between
watching and actually playing where your
time feels like it's slipping through
your fingers in the meantime Rook to A6
this game just gets crazier and crazier
you aren't finding a creative way to
defend the C6 Square I'm loving this
yeah a creative way to defend to also
activate the Rook because the Rook can
at any moment shift to that E Line
double up that put pressure up in that
Knight on E5 Rook A6 once again Jordan's
creativity at its best we see the eval
bar gives a bit of Advantage there to
Dimitri colors and David what's your
take on it because visually I do like
Black's position why does uh the engine
prefer black uh prefer white hair good
question Tanya if I knew I would be
playing in this uh in this event but uh
yeah I'm actually a bit annoyed at
myself because I was gonna say you play
A5 with the idea of Rook A6 I was gonna
say that like five six moves ago but I
was like okay it will never happen
what's the root doing on A6 after all
and then it happens so uh wow creative
stuff by Jordan but C3 it might be this
that uh is so attractive for white right
now you're simply clear bring the
tension clarifying things and if you
simplify trade off all the pieces you're
left with one extra opponent white is
also has those really strong Knights
that we highlighted the problem for
black is you want to get rid of the
bishop pair Jordan has just done that
but what next looks like everything's
protected for Dimitri right now and you
have D4 coming to as well which is quite
strong D4 is going to be quite annoying
um maybe even a bishop H4 at some point
depending on where you put this bishop
if you move the bishop on C5 you might
have to go back to E7 in some cases
right because Bishop H4 is such a huge
threat The Rook does defend it on F6 so
we still have an ic6 ideas right but I
mean we got that extra Pawn I think
white is definitely stabilized here
engine gives white a small Plus
yeah it could be a growing plus as well
if black doesn't find anything over the
next few moves I could imagine a
scenario as you say James where White's
the one improving and black is a bit
stuck like you could swing your Rook
across for example but as you say D4 and
where's this bishop going and maybe F3
yeah cover the four square really limit
blacks minor pieces this is looking
super comfortable exactly with Dimitri
would want out of the opening a Time
advantage and extra pawn and
questionable compensation at best yep
dubious stuff and again you've got a
question and strategy in these kind of
situations where they just need a drawer
to play Such ambitious sacrificial play
from Jordan of
they're braver than me I'm gonna say
that these players and D4 the bishop has
gone back all the way back home to a
start Square on f8
what next for white yeah the F3 move is
really nice it's just like stops you
know improve right it restricts your
pieces F3 improve mine while we're
trying to restrict yours F3 is pretty
good
is up a pawn with some dominating
Knights there on E5 and B5 things do
look under control for the German
Grandmaster who needs to win this game
to take it to the Armageddon meanwhile
action is on on the other board as well
naughty back Abdul satra taking on
Fabiano caruana in their final rapid
game and this is a good time to just
zoom out from him as Dimitri goes into a
thing and let's pull up our other game
David do we have an update on that one
we do have an update we'll just get that
up in a moment it's looking very very
balanced to me those two uh yeah Titans
of the game really canceling each other
out in this one but abdusator if he's
not content to just sit back and accept
an equal position he's pushing forward
Pawn to B4 is the last move there's so
much tension in the center here at
Jameson what do you think to me I would
slightly prefer white just because it
feels like we're very active blacks uh
Black's a bit tied up but evaluation bar
tells us it's level yeah I actually like
this you can play on both sides here
studying just a little bit of Catalan
Theory and just studying chess period
you can actually play on both sides like
you know Bishop three yeah Bishop F3 and
G4 G5 has been uh well I always say to
play G4 G5 anyway but you can actually
do that you can play on both sides of
the board even play Maybe H5 at some
point and expand on that side of the
board C5 too is some problems here down
the diagonal for the bishop two with the
opposing each other the B7 and G2
Bishops so there are things there
there's tactics I mean you even have
something like okay move the Knight to
C4S some point and go into D6 exactly
right after C4 Knight takes C4 Knight D6
so there's some threats here I
definitely like white because of the
options and the the tightrope you have
to walk here to be precise I wonder what
he plays though
H3 there yikes maybe feels like you have
to do something about the center if you
can't step forward as we showed because
of this uh nasty pin along the diagonal
then it looks like maybe you just take
on D4 and hope that oh this is just get
what he took the other way wait so 97
Queen D7 Rook C7 he wants queen A4
hitting the Rook on D1 so that's why
this doesn't lose on the spot wow the
thing is white is under no obligation to
go for the tactics and he could just say
listen your Pawn structure is bad maybe
white could recapture on B4 covering the
after Knight takes D7 maybe or even now
but if you take on D7 first and then
take on B4 Rook takes C2 I think now
runs into Rook C7 and you don't have
that A4 Foursquare anymore
yeah beautiful double attack fork and
most likely a win for white in that
position looks like many tempting
attractive options there I'm really
surprised I've got to say by Carolina's
choice he's basically saying I'm going
to hold things together tactically but
the evaluation Bar says okay white
actually has something extremely strong
right now hey I'm liking what you say
Daniel Knight C6 also looks decent here
you get the bishop there I mean geez so
far is like all over White
C6 also a very strong take taken
huge huge weakness in the center of the
board Bishop power again he goes even
Knight F7 and Rook C7 looks good I mean
there are so many interesting options
wow Knight takes F7 and the bar doesn't
react maybe that was strong there Daniel
and Rook C7 and wow just all the targets
along the seventh Rank and Bishop D5
Rook B7 Rook ba Rook B7 Bishop D5 Bishop
B7 this is gross yeah this is very bad
wow I mean the Catalan is such an
annoying opening and you can just tell
how cute it's too good right David laugh
because he likes it openings yeah you're
right you're right bro it is a good
opening like us David So Carolyn's
really annoying and as you're starting
to see this here
yeah it's uh long term black is just
suffering here you have so many
weaknesses nothing good to say about the
black position apart from the fact
temporarily you are a pawn up so uh Fabi
needs to somehow
utilize that fact I'm not sure how I was
trying to get some tactics and tricks to
work maybe activating the Black Knight
oh and it feels like it doesn't actually
do too much after the night moves white
can simply take this pawn and everything
is dropping for black the night now
Under Fire and another Pawn would drop
at the very least
looking good for white I've got to say
in Fabi just wrecking his position I
don't understand that c takes before
move that we saw earlier just as we
jumped in
or K5 now ending D5
at least the E2 Pawn is under Fire if
White's Queen does get greedy and kind
of slide up taking that pawn right now
so white has to be a bit careful you
need to maybe play a controlling move or
two first like Bishop H3 or Rook data C1
and that's really what Notre back is so
good at right he keeps his composure in
these tense positions turn up the
pressure dial here at B4 Pawn is a thorn
and white side but at the present moment
it's not going anywhere
after Queen takes before Rook takes C2
their attempting moves there as well
such as doubling on the C file and
threatening Rook C8 but if you're taking
them before you got to find a follow-up
I love Bishop H3 it's a very practical
move yeah really practical lining up
some nasty threats The Rook the white
Rook on C6 wants to slide across just
one square pin that black knight to its
Queen
Black Knight moves The Rook might come
up to the top of the board to C8 that
white light Square Bishop peering down
staring down at some key squares
I take it back I don't think we'll see
Armageddon in this one what do you even
do here right now like I mean okay give
black a move right now we do have Rook
D6 we have Rook C7 we have doubling on
the Rooks we have all these moves where
does black move right now rig D6 is
definitely coming maybe bishop E7 but
then okay we doubled the Rooks like oh
man this is tough for Fabi here that's
the big question for Fabian he's got
about five minutes to try to defend this
position he's up upon but so much peace
activity for not the back he's got a
bishop pair the control on the c-line
and what pawn am I even talking about
those double pawns on the B line can be
picked up at any moment Fabi is on the
defense right now he is down by half the
amount of time on the clock troubles
everywhere but we did see Fabi survived
that game three from a difficult
position he managed to turn around and
Win It
can that happen in this one as well and
right now he needs to not lose this game
in the next three moves because David's
idea Rook D6 that is a devastating
threat
I mean he's stepping all over landmines
that's why Fabi withdraws his Knight to
f8 trying to redeploy it to E6 put some
pressure on D4 we know that Fabi is not
going down without a fight to the last
drop of blood norderbeck keeps his foot
on the gas pedal Queen E7
the queen takes it till the night hangs
oh this guy just does not let up just to
show this if the Queens come off at the
very end the Knight drops off the board
and that's just game over if you move
the queen right now this is a kill
attack you might have to give it up on
C8 David but then white picks up B4 and
B6 that's got to be a technically
winning position by the way Queen E7 is
on the board
56 there it is 64. but then Bishop F5 oh
see Tanya Bishop F5 hitting the queen
deflecting the queen these Bishops this
is
Queen takes and the black Rook no longer
defended not Bishop G2 Tanya's move is
the only precise one because then the
queen has E6 oh
Bishop F5 was so interesting based you
want to put it on F5 and not the
retreating G2 square but does that mean
that Fabi is going to lose material at
this point 100 it's gonna lose the game
wow you lose material how do you
compensate for that I don't think you
can with black man a Caroline is
dangerous no we're back with a white one
yeah this guy's a beast yeah this is a
sad necessity yeah
that's it it was choosing the Lesser
evil he picks up the bishop on D6 loses
in exchange he's down on the clock wow
Sabi on the brink of a match defeat
which would put him down in the
elimination bracket and look at naughty
back absolutely focused David here he
knows he's so close to wrapping this up
extremely close now he just needs to
stay calm and just to make sure there
are no tricks fabi's last move is the
definition of trickery because he wants
to potentially sacrifice the black Rook
on the third rank he wants to give it up
break open the white king if you can
prevent that I don't think black has
anything at all white is not just Brook
for night up but also that black knight
is paralyzed there's a pin eternally
yeah all white needs is one or two
careful moves here James what would you
choose I was about to say oh yeah these
three or Kings yeah but E3 is like the
the salt a very solid way to do it look
at the pawn structure it's beautiful
it's a beautiful Pawn structure here I
mean you don't even realize that he was
down upon this whole time you know
because the pressure you're like oh
Black's down Black's up a pawn like what
do you mean like it didn't even feel
like that the pieces were so active and
black was just steady defending you
don't even feel the pawn They Are Up In
fact you would really give it back just
to be able to get some type of activity
or to be able to stop you know Wise
threats here we lost some material we
down in exchange and almost losing the
game here uh probably is going to need a
miracle right now
it's really hanging by a thread now that
black Bishop is on a really ugly square
but it is defending its Knight it is
defending the black B4 Pawn you have to
keep that pawn alive if you want any
kind to play long term if you want to
survive any end game
so uh how is Abdus gonna just kind of
push that black position off the ledge
and uh win this game still some work to
be done Great quest yeah yeah there's I
don't think there's anything super
medium and you can play Rook C1 Rook C8
the issue is that you're not attacking
the f8 Knight there are Maneuvers that
are similar to this trying to go after
the D5 Pawn you could play Queen B2 to
E2 to B5 you have to figure out whether
the Bishop from H3 should eventually
move to G2 so I I think this is actually
not that easy you can also throw an H5
to try to weaken some of the dark
squares on the king side but the
abundance of moves isn't always a good
thing sometimes it makes you feel
stressed out
um we've all been there we try to find
the best moves suddenly we get into time
pressure and we end up choosing uh the
line which complicates things the most
yeah that's the last thing he wants to
do right now but he does have a big time
advantage and I like all of those ideas
I especially like this queen slide
because you do protect your king as well
you don't want to allow for example any
Rook sacrifices uh because you have to
be a bit careful of the pawns around the
white king but yeah you can take your
time here also Brook slide looks very
logical he does drop his Bishop back
there is a weakness in Black's position
on the D5 Square also very logical but
the bar reacts slightly
maybe the best move it's the white Rook
trapped if I drop back my queen you have
to give up material again or give back
some material rugby Queen C7 it's an
endless
wow The Rook has no space and he plays
it so you have to take on E7 I guess and
take on B4 motorbike definitely missed
that yeah and he's lucky he has a way to
keep the advantage he's paused now yeah
he keeps the advantage by giving back
the rook and this point will most likely
drop he'll be a pawn up long term nice
Pawn structure for white this little V
here but uh yeah some work to be done
and no material advantage for now at
least another back wow surprising stuff
dang look at the eval bro DeBarge is
disrespectful life I mean I understand
I'm losing a pawn here but the way that
the bar says this is over is insane
Bishop D5
okay
yeah the white Bishop is far superior to
the Black Knight at least and the B4
porn doomed so it's easy to understand
why white has the advantage but is it
enough to win
oh you feel something well it definitely
doesn't work I think Rook a three Queen
takes before Rook takes E3 those checks
are not to be trifled with the problem
is I think the king can escape because
all of White's pieces are protected so
it's worth considering but it's not
going to work F take C3 and the King
usually runs toward the centers like
King F1
Queen F3 King E1 and the problem is that
the queen and the Rook are linked up so
yeah yeah you can take some pawns but
you're not gonna save the game
gonna run away it's a safety so not
quite working but that's the type of
thing he needs to look for Fabi here he
needs to look for those types of kind of
swindles here to save the game
strategically losing long term for black
yeah so many twists and turns for sure
here I mean that's crazy that how strong
the Catalan can be even against some of
the strongest players in the world here
black was up upon basically the whole
game and but we never felt this Pawn now
we're getting the pawn back and with
interest
two minutes also for Fabi adding insult
to injury
if he saves this that would just be
crazy particularly with notorbeck's
technique which is displayed again and
again yeah he bloated The Exchange but
he was up in exchange so he had an
exchange to give back right maybe it was
all part of the plan maybe he thought
that this was easier to convert than the
other position entirely possible P5
okay just hitting the bishop but that's
just a one move threat the bishop can
move in any direction pretty much any
safe square and the advantage is
maintained center of the board Bishop D5
keep it eyeing the F7 weakness put it on
the long diagonal or a Russian Schoolboy
mode Bishop F1
safe move I think with such many paths
should win yeah with such different
players Tanya British perform was the
first one on my mind
and E4
yeah maybe not because of Rook A4
actually see that's exactly the kind of
sloppy mistake that I would make yeah
you don't need to rush with E4 black is
a bit stuck just clingy too yeah me too
Black's night and Rook are stuck
protecting their remaining Queen Side
Pawn on B5
so you do have some time before you
start the advance the Avalanche of white
Central ports
yeah yeah unfortunately for Fabi he
can't land his Knight on D5 because the
B5 Pawn Falls so it's difficult to start
rolling down the board with what was it
Bertie the beep on
um
good memory Beatrix the beep one
Bellatrix
so Knight D5 not a threat on the board
gives up to satro of enough time to
start improving his own King he's got to
watch out the tactics a little bit as
pointed out don't rush with Eddie the
e-pawn with Rook A4 coming in that would
start targeting all those Central pawns
things are in control right now Fabi
about two minutes on the clock and after
four minutes on the clock is this easy
technique at that level
definition of easy that's
normally you would back these players to
convert but Fabiano's very tenacious and
he will be resourceful if he spots a
tactic if you kind of give him one
chance he will jump on it so bring the
black king now
debate does look slightly tentative here
it looks like he's uh not 100 sure of
the best technique he attacks the Black
Knight but this only helps the black
Rook okay seven Great move he wants to
put the Rook on B7 potentially of course
it can be chased Away by White's Bishop
but anytime you have a passport an
outside passer like that you're gonna
have your counter play I would still
consider Rook B7 Bishop G2 just go back
to A7 and take the heat off that pawn a
lot of work to be done here for for
Notre back no question definitely it's
not that easy of course there's a lot of
times within games like this you have to
have the general idea where do I put the
pieces what's the plan here a lot of
times you do want to put the king
towards the center but his King's coming
toward the center you gotta time the
pawns the pawn pushes in the center
correctly right the bishop also is on F1
so you say B4 Rook C4 rugby seven
and you lose peace
he goes for it
again we're so different Daniel I would
have played the bishop to see foreign
but uh why delay things when you can win
a pawn but now still Bishop G2 I just
don't get
what it is that he wants is B3 crazy and
then draw K1 B2 yeah the problem is I
can stop that pawn of the bishop with
Bishop E4
nice
maybe we just show this on the board
while uh Noddy back thinks he just he's
double checking he's calculating here
the bishop hits the Knight trying to
remove the defender okay one and Knight
F6 might be a problem we'll show this in
a second I think you're right Dania here
the idea sorry a check first maybe uh
the idea is that the pawn can be stopped
by White's bishop and uh here we see
whites just two pawns up gonna win but
uh Danny I think spotted a really nice
resource there potentially for black a
nasty check forcing the white king to a
bad square and now suddenly threats
against the white king if you get greedy
whoops your win has disappeared
watching nowhere to hide wow it's not
over it's not over yet
for the track
what's next just slide behind that black
pawn maybe there it is
good end game technique in general if in
doubt put your Rook behind your
opponent's passport tends to be most
active there he's a machine he just
doesn't ever miss or fall for any of
these tactics it's crazy
so alert just so aware always thinking
about the opponent but also kind of kind
of combining it with what he wants as
well and now it's Unstoppable I think
he's going to win that B Pawn he's going
to step forward with this King now
I assume there's others definitely King
G2 definitely
maybe you'll give a check just ask the
black king where it wants to go
are you thinking now are you thinking is
he checking U2 E4 Maybe
and it all comes out to this right for
Fabi all hopes are on that beep on one
stuck Pawn Falls it's pretty much game
over the two Central past pawns will
just March down the board so he's got to
try and hold on to it for as long as
possible and get it all the way to B3 so
does uh Fabi if he's given the time Rook
B1 B3 coming in
is that the idea that he's looking for
Rook P1 next now go for it it's time
otherwise E4 the issue is then Bishop C4
Rook B7 white can start mopping up the
other king side pawns with the bishop
holding the B3 Square so I think it's
kind of darned if you do darn if you
don't Rook A2 can be tried but at this
point you're just creating one move
threats he's gonna work C1 to prevent
bishopsy for Fabby just fighting with
everything that he's got trying to make
it difficult for another back every step
of the way yeah really nice move
now strong yeah controlling the C4
Square David yeah you only find these
moves that the top players uh play by
thinking about what the opponent wants
the opponent clearly wants a bishop C4
next move no matter what so why not stop
it and uh now white can advance forward
the pawn kicking away the Black Knight
but this does create weaknesses the
further forward these pawns Advance the
more weak they will become so at least
some counter play or at least some hope
of counter play here nodded back though
very standard uh from him by this point
just finding all the best moves he's
going to use this Square potentially to
kick away the Black Knight he's saying
to Black okay you have no logical moves
no useful moves so I'm going to play it
slowly
and I think it looks good nice point
there David another chess kid moment
when and Dad ask yourself what's your
opponent's threat and that often is the
path to finding the best move in the
situation a rook C1 it's still bad news
for black but Fabi holds it for some
time Bishop D3 activating that Bishop so
now when the pawn jumps on e4 it will be
defended it will be guarded with that
bishop and white will go on to win the
B4 Pawn but Fabi again keeping the
threats going Rook C3 are we expecting
Bishop E4 Knight F6 not easy this should
be four Knight F6 Bishop F3 you have to
perform the right kind of gymnastics
with the bishop to be able to challenge
the pawn when it hits B3 wow and all of
that requires some calculation he's down
to a minute and nights are tricky pieces
in in time pressure V3 Bishop D1 you hit
the pawn you win the pawn but black
doesn't have to play B3 black and still
keep clinging to that pawn with his Rook
yeah maybe let's just put this on the
board while I'm doing Satora thinks very
very quickly here attacking the Knight
looks very logical kicking it away the
Knight has to retreat gaining time
against the bishop the bishop can
Retreat and as you guys have been
talking about if the pawn advances it
will be rounded up no way to survive any
longer for this pawn it will be cashed
in on uh on the next move and he's going
straight for this line okay first he
flicks in a nasty check just asking the
black king where it wants to go keeping
that King honest I think it will
continue protecting the portal next to
it so most likely slide back and then he
will drop back his Bishop this Pawn is
doomed long term
great stuff 10 seconds for Bobby wow
nine eight he needs to make a move five
Rook B7 he has to decide where to move
the king he goes King f8 all right
Bishop F3 still can't push the B Pawn
you lose it after Bishop D1 oh move G4
now to try to kick the Knight out of F6
so you can put that Bishop on D5 no oh
same idea even more elegant execution
Exquisite this should be a tree coming
up
brutal and here it is
there it goes about to hit the button
yeah fabby's yeah fabi's fighting uh
spirit here has been uh diminished
unfortunately no way to keep this one
going two pawns down no counter play
ER of time now after the tour of he's
done everything right it will be a huge
shock if he lets this one slip another
great move Knight D6 there was Rook D7
just integrating the tactics perfectly
and he's about to win a third Pawn that
might trigger resignation no Black
Knight no good squares for it to use and
I think Fabi you can tell body language
there he leaned back
has he resigned he has Abdus takes the
match wow what a big win there by
abdisature he keeps his farm at the
chess kid what a chess kid and that
means will be down in the elimination
bracket with not about wrapping it up in
the rapid game we've still got action on
on the other board and it's madness here
as well well it looks like we will be
having a second Queen and an Armageddon
my prediction isn't looking too bad
right now just saying I forgot I forgot
who predicted an Armageddon just in this
match
wow you're a prophet Dania you've heard
it before he hasn't won yet though you
have to get out of the checks and that's
incredibly hard to do in time pressure
you need to walk towards your Pawn most
often your best hiding place is in front
of your own porn it looks
counter-intuitive but uh once your king
finds safety you can therefore have the
time to uh kind of find the best setup
before going for promotion yeah just
keep advancing there we go black has to
keep giving checks just to delay the
inevitable of wide support marching
through
I'm trying to think Daniel what does
Daniel become when she promotes when it
promotes to a queen Daniel
becomes Dana Dana Dana but uh yeah that
white point is going to promote
how does Jordan prevent this or how does
he delay it no counter play the problem
is black has no past pawns that's the
currency yeah it's no pass Pawn
check correct and now so where's the
king hiding if you go to C8 you can get
your queen to d8 if there's a check on
it just solves everything because it's
lacking as well Black's King position is
awful if you have the King on G7 you
would have been able to give Queenie a
check he's dodging the bullets here
Queen B7 Queen E5 that's the second
technique when you run out of checks you
try to pin the pawn
wooden's fighting for his life and this
one the computer says it's winning yes
but that is irrelevant if you put your
King on the wrong Square it might just
be a draw immediately
so uh fine margin here
this is difficult okay here's the check
so where are we with the queen B7 Queen
five got a minute on the clock
I find that safe spot for the king I
can't I go Queen Seven here maybe Queen
B7 and then King C7 and then try to like
make your way to d8 I don't know exactly
yeah
so you couldn't have given a check on E8
as we pointed out with Queen C8 blocking
it so he's taking it's not the Deep on
can't advance and Jordan finding his
counter play the H Pawn is threatening
to March down the board
oh we have ourselves a game
oh and I can't play D7 we have ourselves
a game devilish oh my
God oh my God nobody cares about it
playing on seconds anything is possible
here look at the time
oh my God 20 seconds
under 20. and if it takes on G5 the
h-man marches down the board gives a
check the players are feeling the nerves
how's the king going to hide now
it's crack that makes it vulnerable we
that doesn't feel right you can give a
check from C8 or from C4 now both look
good for black
yeah the evaluation bar still says
winning for white but now the margin is
even uh lower suddenly all the checks
are coming Black's got quick counter
play you could certainly imagine the
black H Pawn promoting in the near
future
what do we think is he going to hold his
nerve Dimitri call us this Block Force
Jordan to think
give us a check he can come back to ASX
now I have to so many checks oh in the
corner King D7 was possible goes back to
C5 that's the most vulnerable part of
the board
any time
triangulating he's just trying to sneak
zigzagging his way up to the top of the
board here can he hide his King big
question decisive question here six
seconds for Jordan
I'm still protecting an Armageddon in
this one it's so hard to find a safe
spot for the king playing on seconds
Queen B5 check Dimitri's trying and now
don't give a check on E8 Queen d8 idea
key defensive resource for black there
gives a check from Asics but we've seen
this position but now black gets another
tempo for his Pawn oh my goodness
zero oh King is going Queen yeah
I think with D6 you have to play to
prevent King C7 that's it stop the white
king from moving and no way for white to
promote oh this hers he's blown it he's
blowing it is
unbelievable same with Queen C7 there's
no moves
yeah
desperation he's covering Black's
promotion square that H Pawn is covered
now by the White Queen on the diagonal
but
how to improve here as soon as the white
king moves there'll be a bunch of checks
can you see a queen C5 it's just a draw
now easy draw so close
Queen end games are the hardest
yeah wow heartbreaking for Dimitri
so close just did everything right he
needed to win the game and he made all
his chances but Jordan van first again
super super creative way to keep the
position defended and if this ends in a
draw Jordan does win the match and it
looks like we're heading there yeah
guaranteed nowhere for the white king to
hide the White Queen is stuck defending
the black H Pawn so she cannot block
there we go I think we're about to see
the result
oh Queen takes E3 but at this point
Jordan's only thinking about one thing
and that's repetition
and we have the result Jordan see the
relief on his face wow he has clinched
it wow and you can see the
disappointment on Dimitri kolas he was
so close to leveling this match with a
win but tricky tricky Queen endings and
Jordan van forest was glorious in his
defense creating that H passer we see
Dimitri there he did have a fantastic
day at the start he's the one who took
the lead in the match but Jordan there
with three back to back wins and we see
the winner of the match he's got reasons
to be pleased with his performance
there's such a great comeback incredible
and honestly Jordan has shown that
resilience he showed it yesterday
against Hikaru nerves of Steel today G5
in that Queen end game understanding you
have to create a pass Pawn of your own
when you're dealing with a pass Pawn
that's about to promote incredible stuff
from Van Forest he deserves to be where
he is and played on seconds that's not
something for mere mortal it's just
precise play there amazing chess David
what was the moment for you oh the
moment it was actually when Jordan did
push G5 as Daniel said creating counter
play in chess in general in all
positions especially in Hopeless
positions that's the way to save games
and uh it was this one moment actually
just a couple of moves ago black had
pushed he's trying to create a passport
of his own the most important thing in
Queen end games but this was the moment
Dimitri let the win slip through his
fingers he simply chose the wrong square
but it's so easy to do that in these
types of scenarios if he had chosen this
Square retreating he would most likely
have won the key difference is Jordan
cannot take this Pawn as he did in the
game because white is able to give a
check on C8 and once the Queens come off
white is first in the race because white
promotes with a check of course there
would have been more checks more twists
and turns but in the end Jordan great
defense he earned the victory
amazing chest there in the time scramble
that we just witnessed and that means
that no Armageddon but wow it's been an
intense day of action wait not the back
of this outro of taking a big win
against Fabiano caruana and Jordan van
Forrest we see there he started with a
loss two back-to-back wins and in a
crazy crazy game for he managed to end
with a draw and he takes his match
against Dimitri colas which means that
Dmitry and Abby will be down in the
elimination bracket and we are being
joined by one of the winners notibeg
Abdul satrov let's bring him on not a
bag congratulations
thank you wow what a day it was
defeating one of the best in the world
and I have to ask you another back what
worked well you've got so much to choose
from
yeah I think first of all
um the openings went my way and uh
actually I got a pleasant position from
uh from White pieces and with black
pieces I I had a
a fighting game and uh okay in the game
three
actually I got an advantage but yeah
this exchange sacrifice was completely
unnecessary
uh but other than that I think I think
everything went my way
it was an amazing match to watch and I
wanted to talk about that game three
because it was a big moment for us you
played This brilliant game with the
black pieces everything under control
and then you take the Super committed
decision with Rook F4 very brave what
was going on in your mind at that time
okay I thought
um
I think I thought it's interesting
sacrifice and uh to to create an
imbalance in the position
and I was also getting a uh some phone
break with E5 but I never
had a chance but uh I was trying to but
yeah I think
he played very well after the exchange
sacrifice and
I made a mistake and then he just
converted it I think
and then winning a game four not about
it looked quite smooth to us even though
you lost one game you were in control in
that one was it as smooth as it looked
or definitely ups and downs
I think it was very very clean game
actually
uh I found this before move which is
very important I think and after before
I I think that black is in huge trouble
yeah and the end game as well that you
played with the bishop manure it was
just a tremendous match to watch
naughty back and you are in Stavanger
for Norwich s a lot of the players from
the Chaska cup will also be there have
you met anyone yet
not yet but uh yeah I hope and it's a
great place and yeah I'm just enjoying
here and preparing
going in the amazing chest that you're
playing and I I'll ask you one more
question I like that there is the title
Tuesday coming up we are getting a lot
of updates that some of the players
playing in Norway chess will be
participating are you going to be there
as well
no no I think so I will not play
well I think it's been a big day of
chess for you and get some rest all the
best for tomorrow thank you see you
thank you thank you guys for joining us
he won a great match against Fabiano
caruana and the other player who made a
big comeback today after losing game one
is joining us from gone again it is
Jordan van Perez Jordan welcome
congratulations
hello and thank you very much
that was crazy match every
every game
yeah it was really really a tough match
um I mean I didn't rate my chances
particularly high after I lost the first
game with the white pieces but somehow I
managed to strike back
um with the black pieces merely in the
game uh after that so and then I also
won the third game but I mean the last
game was absolutely crazy because
I really thought I was going to lose in
this end game but somehow
I managed to survive it it surely was
losing at some point but I was trying to
create some complications and at some
point he he went drone but yeah it was a
really really tough match overall in
every game was was difficult
Jordan I want to ask you about
yesterday's match where you defeated
Hikaru Nakamura uh does it feel special
to beat Hikaru in a rapid match and how
nervous were you in that last game as
you were converting your extra exchange
did you kind of feel the Hikaru effect
in action
actually I was much more nervous today
um
because in the final of the big match
against nicaros of course also difficult
um I mean every match against the car is
going to be extremely difficult
um but the fourth game at some point I
thought it was gonna lose actually and
then he gave me this Rook takes H6 and
then the game completely turned around
and I was actually um in this end game I
I didn't feel too nervous after that
because I had no risk and I mean if I
don't blunder in life Fork I can never
lose that position so I was already
happy kind of to uh to be in that spot
um but yeah of course I was I was very
pleased with my play Yesterday
um especially the first game I thought
was was very nice but I guess he was not
in his top shape because usually he
plays better than this I think
and that was a fantastic match today it
was a fantastic match and after you lost
the first game today you made this
really impressive comeback winning two
games back to back how do you switch
your mind in these moments to come back
into the game
I guess everyone has their own ritual
but I just spoke to the bathroom
splashed some cold
water on my face
um maybe give myself like a little slap
on the cheek like wake up and then just
try to forget about the game like the
good thing is that the games
um come really quickly after one another
so you don't have too much
um time to you know feel bad about about
previous game and you immediately just
can play your next game but I have to
say in the second game at some point I
thought it was in huge trouble and I
thought I might just go down 2-0 a bit
similar to my match against the car
yesterday where I was winning in the
second game but also that game turned
around and so did this one and of course
when shooting with the black pieces
you're completely back and imagine you
may even have some momentum
yeah and you know while we're
commentating on your games we keep
talking about the creativity and these
unique opening ideas I think the world
talks about them in a time when it's so
difficult to come up with new ideas
Jordan you just seem to surprise us all
all the time what's the secret
oh I'm happy I still have this image
because I don't know if I'm doing too
many crazy things nowadays I mean I try
but like you said it's it's really
difficult to remain creative these days
and for example in today's match I think
I was out of the opening
um in every game it also depends on your
opponent's repertoire for example Hikaru
he plays a lot of nonsense in Blitz but
in serious time controls he actually has
a repertoire which he'll basically
always sticks to so it's much easier
easier to to prepare
so it really depends a bit on this and
that
um I mean yeah I tried to find some
creative ideas now and then but uh
definitely not as successful as I used
to be I would say and that's also normal
because so much has been analyzed in the
last couple of years
well it's always so much fun to watch
your games uh Jordan and finally my last
question to you you were a last minute
replacement here at the Chaska cup and
you beat Hikaru you beat Polaris you
continue in the Winner's bracket how do
you feel about your chances right now
um well I guess the next match is going
to be extremely tough as well playing uh
of the South roof uh if I I'm not
mistaken so formal former World rapid
chess champion already and one of the
biggest uh talents out there potential
world champion so
um yeah we'll see him I mean it's only
four games match so anything can happen
and I will just I will just try my best
but I'm already quite uh happy to have
gotten this far and like you said I
wasn't even expecting to play in this
event in the first place because I lost
to Anish in the qualification but
sometimes uh things you know go your way
so let's hope it will continue to do so
thank you so much Jordan it's going to
be a big fight tomorrow we're so excited
about it we wish you all the very best
thank you so much good night guys good
evening
Jordan Vine Forest is on fire here at
the chess kit golf he took down Hikaru
Nakamura today coming back from a first
round loss and tomorrow he's got a big
match against not the back of the satro
of these are the brackets going forward
to day three of the tournament and there
we see in the elimination bracket we got
a big match with Fabiano caruana taking
up Oliver what stands out to you James
here well perusian it loses breaking
karawana that's crazy there I'm actually
I don't know who to pick actually there
while it's tough Carolina and fabulous
maybe slightest to Carolina but then for
Rouge if he's really hot you know it
could be anybody's game for real
it is a lot of Chess action that we're
excited about coming up on day three but
for the Chess World of course there's no
such thing as too much chess because
take a look at what Hikaru Nakamura has
to say about his evening plans it was a
tough day in the office he has been
eliminated out of the chess get cup but
of course chess continues for Hikaru as
he will be playing in the title Tuesday
and there we see it's a takeaway
restaurant there in the photograph and
those are the orders and there's a
certain Magnus Carlson there Hikaru is
expecting Magnus to play the title
Tuesday as well that's gonna be a fun
one Daniel it will yeah title Tuesday
starting in about an hour
I think I'll be able to make it back to
the hotel in time so
you know I'll uh do my usual losing to
an FM in round two probably won't get to
Hikaru but it'll be a fun one I'm sure
your car will be there to rebound from
his loss earlier today yeah wow so there
is a more chess action if this wasn't
enough title Tuesday is coming up go
sign up for it or follow the biggest
names in chess are fighting it out it's
been a fantastic day so many ups and
downs and of course the action continues
tomorrow it's gonna be a big day tree
here at the Chaska cup and we guys will
be back to keep you on top of the action
see you then
you mentioned fancy he's even fancy this
guy's on another planet yeah look at
this a fork not a bag of the Statue of
takes the lead in his match Jordan see
the relief on his face wow has clinched
it
[Music]
oh
my God
foreign
[Music]